RESPONSE TO THE COVER NINETEEN
EMERGENCY TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
WE ARE LIMITING NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND HEARING TO OUR
SOCIAL DISTANCE GUIDELINES. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
MEETINGS HERE IN THE- STREET
BUILDING AND I ASK ALL MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE TO. BE PRESENT
IN TWENTY TWO HUNDRED SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM. TO ALLOW
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
WILL ALSO BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC CONTENT. YOU WILL
CALL. 877-226-8163 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN SIX TWO TWO
FOUR SIX TWO. YOU CAN GO TO OUR
WEBSITE WHICH WILL HAVE THAT
NUMBER REPEATED AND ALSO HAS
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL
BE PROMPTED BY THE MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER PEOPLE WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME
YOU'LL BE ON MUTED AND YOU CAN
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. MAKE
SURE YOU'VE MUTED THE DEVICE
THAT YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON. BEFORE GIVING YOUR
TESTIMONY. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUSIC
- WE HAVE TWELVE BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA TO ARE BEING
PULLED SB NINE OH FOUR BATES AND
SB ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE CABALLERO.
SO THAT LEAVES US CAN THAT WE
WILL HERE- LET'S SEE IS THREE
FORMS. YEAH OKAY SO WE HAVE A
FORM. OF A SECTOR COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT COULD YOU PLEASE.
CALL THE ROLL. BRADFORD AND SHOW
BOTH. TROUBLED HERE CAMARGO HERE
COME UNDER HERE SKINNER SKINNER
HERE WIENER. ALL RIGHT WE SHOULD
HEAR FROM OUR FIRST OFFER-
PROTEIN MACHEN'S YOU MAY PRESENT
YOUR BILL SB. THIRTY FOUR. WELL
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES ITIS GOOD TO SEE YOU
THIS MORNING THIS IS A FIRST FOR
ME IN THIS NEW HEARING ROOM- SO
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THIS MORNING. COLLEAGUES
LAST FALL IN MY DISTRICT A STATE
COURT HAD DETERMINED THAT A
SEXUALLY VIOLENT PREDATOR AND S.
B. P. INDIVIDUAL. UNDER THE CARE
pHOSPITALS SHOULD BE PLACED ON
CONDITIONAL RELEASE ALSO KNOWN
AS CONRAD. AFTER THE PERSON AND
FINISH THEIR CRIMINAL SENTENCE
AND NOW HAVING COMPLETED THEIR
CIVIL COMMITMENT BY RECEIVING
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT AND
SERVICES FROM THE STATE A COURT
DETERMINED THAT THE PERSON WAS
NO LONGER A DANGER TO OTHERS AND
COULD SAFELY BE RETURNED TO THE
COMMUNITY. HOWEVER UNDER
SUPERVISION THAT IS THE PURPOSE
OF THE CONRAD PROGRAM. ONCE THIS
DETERMINATION WAS MADE IT WAS
THEN UP TO THE COURT TO WORK
WITH THE STATE TO FIND A
SUITABLE HOUSING PLACEMENT FOR
THIS INDIVIDUAL. CONSISTENT WITH
OTHER RULES LIKE RADIUS
RESTRICTIONS AND ENSURING GPS
SURVEILLANCE AND MONITORING. BUT
WHEN IT WAS ANNOUNCED WHERE THE
S. V. P. WOULD BE PLACED THERE
WAS SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC OUTCRY.
PARENTS AND FAMILIES WERE
CONCERNED AND ON FIRST
IMPRESSION I TOO WAS INCREDIBLY
CONCERNED. THE COMMUNITY SAID
THAT THERE WERE FLAWS IN THE
PROCESS AND THAT THERE WAS NO
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE STATE.
AND LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES. SO I
TOOK A DEEP LOOK AT HOW WE CAN
ENSURE THAT LOCAL JUSTICE
PARTNERS COULD BE HEARD IN THESE
CRITICAL HOUSING PLACEMENT
DECISIONS. AND HOW TO KEEP OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE WHILE ALSO
RESPECTING OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
RESPONSIBILITIES. THIS IS A
RESPONSIBILITY THAT REQUIRES BY
LAW US TO RE INTEGRATE BACK INTO
SOCIETY INDIVIDUALS WHO SERVE
THEIR TIME AND WHOSE MENTAL
DISORDER HAS BEEN TREATED SO
THAT IS SAFE FOR THEM TO BE
SUPERVISED BACK IN THE
COMMUNITY. SINCE THE INCEPTION
OF THE PROGRAM IN NINETEEN
NINETY SIX THERE HAVE BEEN FIFTY
ONE S. B. P.'S PLACED INTO
CONRAD INTO THE PROGRAM. NONE OF
WHO HAVE RE OFFENDED AS PART OF
THE PROGRAM THOSE INDIVIDUALS
ARE CLOSELY MONITORED DRUG
TESTED GPS TRACKED AND RECEIVE
ONGOING TREATMENT AND SUPPORT.
CONVERSELY EIGHT ESCAPEES HAVE
BEEN RELEASED TO TRANSIENT
STATUS WITHOUT ANY CONDITIONS OR
SURVEILLANCE OR MONITORING
BECAUSE IT WAS TOO DIFFICULT FOR
THEIR COMMUNITIES TO FIND
SUITABLE HOUSING FOR THEM. AND I
DON'T THINK THAT'S OKAY. I IN
WHERE THE SYSTEM NEEDS TO BE
IMPROVED IT'S NOT OKAY FOR THE
COMMUNITY IT'S NOT OKAY FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL. SO SB TEN THIRTY
FOUR IS INTENDED TO CREATE A
MORE STRUCTURED PROCESS FOR ALL
RELEVANT COMMUNITY STAKEHOLDERS
TO COLLECTIVELY MAKE APPROPRIATE
LOCAL HOUSING PLACEMENT
DECISIONS. WHILE BALANCING OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL OLIGATIONS THIS
IN TURN WOULD REDUCE THE RISK OF
TRANSIENT PLACEMENT ALL OF WHICH
ULTIMATELY INCREASES PUBLIC
PREVENT ONE COUNTY FROM PASSING
THE BUCK BASICALLY AND JUST
MOVING THEIR SVP INTO ANOTHER
JURISDICTION SB TEN THIRTY FOUR
CREATES A MORE DETAILED PROCESS
FOR HOW A COURT MAY AUTHORIZE A
COUNTY TO PLACE AN STP INTO
ANOTHER JURISDICTION FOR ME THAT
IS A FAIRNESS ISSUE. AT THE END
OF THE DAY A JURISDICTION THAT
PLACES A PERSON INTO THE SYSTEM
SHOULD BE RESPONSIBLE FOR THEM
WHEN THEY COME OUT. RESEARCH
SHOWS OR HAS SHOWN THAT
INDIVIDUALS RELEASED BACK INTO
THEIR HOME COMMUNITY THEIR
DOMICILE RESIDENCE WHERE THEY
HAVE TIES TO THE COMMUNITY ARE
LESS LIKELY TO RE OFFEND. SO SB
TEN THIRTY FOUR IS ATTEMPTING TO
CREATE A THOUGHTFUL APPROACH
THAT CREATES ADDITIONAL
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
FOR THE PUBLIC IN ORDER TO KEEP
OUR COMMUNITY SAFE HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS- BUT WE'RE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND I VOTE ON TEN
THIRTY FOUR. LET US BEGIN WITH
ANY WE HAVE A LEAD WITNESS
INCENDIO OF MADAM CHAIR NO NOT
TO WORRY- LET'S. SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM THAT
WANTS TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. SEEING NONE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES- MODERATOR.
WOULD YOU OPEN THE PHONE LINES
AND ASK SUPPORT WITNESSES FOR SB
TEN THIRTY FOUR. TO PROCEED.
THANK YOU IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK
ITS SUPPORT OF SB TEN THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. IT'LL BE JUST A
MOMENT FOR OUR FIRST PERSON.
I APOLOGIZE FOR THE DELAY IT'LL
JUST BE ANOTHER MOMENT HERE.
IN LINE TWELFTH PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
SHANNON LEFT ON THE RESIDENTS
TALKING CALIFORNIA NINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN THIRTY FOUR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THERE ARE
NO OTHER LINES IN SUPPORT PLEASE
CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT SO NOW WE'LL
MOVE TO OUR ARMED. OPPOSITION
AND- WE HAVE IS LEAD OPPOSITION
PAT ESPINOSA FROM THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE- THAT- MISTER OR MISS
ESPINOZA IS GOING TO BE CALLING
SO MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
ALLOW ESPINOZA TO SPEAK. IT
MORNING MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. I JUST KNOW
THAT CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN DIEGO DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE AND DISTRICT ATTORNEY
SUMMER STEPHAN AND ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION AND WE APPLAUD THE
PRETENCE EFFORTS IN THE AREA TO
IMPROVE FTP LAW AND WE BELIEVE
THERE ARE. VALUABLE PROVISIONS
WITHIN SB TEN THIRTY FOUR BUT WE
ARE OPPOSED. TO ONE MAJOR
PORTION OF XP TEN THIRTY FOUR
AND THAT IS THE BILL'S
REQUIREMENTS TO INCLUDE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE
AND CONSULTATION IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
PROCESS OF LOCATING CRITICS
ACCUSING HOUSING WITHIN THE
COUNTY FOR PERSONS COMMITTED AS
STDS OR SEXUALLY VIOLENT
PREDATORS. WHO ABOUT TO BE
CONDITIONALLY RELEASED AND
PLACED IN THE COMMUNITY. AS THE
PARTY THAT TYPICALLY OPPOSES THE
DECISION TO CONDITIONALLY
RELEASE INDIVIDUAL BESPOKE THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY AND DIFFICULT
POSITION WE THINK THAT'S A
CONFLICT ALSO HAVE THE EIGHT
PLAYER ROLE. IN SELECTING A
LOCATION TO PLACE THE INDIVIDUAL
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY. THIS IS A
- INITIALLY NOT THE ROLE OF THE
ATTORNEY. AND EX ALL LAW WHILE
NOT SPECIFIC DOES ALLOW.
GOVERNMENT TO CHOOSE WITHIN
COUNTY GOVERNMENT WHO IS THE
BEST AGENCY WITH COUNTY TO THAT
AND SHE CAN AND WE HAVE- WE HAVE
THAT. IN OUR LOW BORDERS
SUPERVISORS HAS SELECTED. HELP
THE TEAM SERVICES WITHIN OUR
COUNTY AS IF THE ENTITY THAT
DOES THAT. BUT MORE BROADLY BUT
LEAVING WIDE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
IS NOT THE APPROPRIATE
INDIVIDUAL PLAYER IT ROLE IN
SELECTING A PLACEMENT OF THE SDP
WHO EXPECT CONDITION RELEASED IS
THAT THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY DOES
NOT HAVE FULL ACCESS TO THE
TREATMENT RECORDS AND THIS IS
THE TREATMENT DECISION.
OFTENTIMES IMPACT IF PEOPLE
ENGAGE IN. OPPOSITION FROM OUR
PARTNERS ON THE DEFENSE SIDE WHO
WILL CLAIM THAT. YOU KNOW IT IT
SHOULD SHOULD APPROPRIATE YOU
HAVE TO DISTRICT ATTORNEY PLAY A
ROLE IN TREATMENT TYPE DECISION
THAT HAVING ACCESS TO TREATMENT
INFORMATION. THE ARGUMENT IS
MADE THAT THIS WOULD HAPPEN
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THE
THERAPEUTIC RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
THE S. B. P. AND HIS TREATMENT
PROVIDERS. AND SHOULD PROVIDE A
MEANINGFUL ROLE IN THE PLACEMENT
THIS DECISION THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS HAVE TO HAVE ACCESS TO
TREATMENT RECORDS TO KNOW. WHAT
IT. ASIAN ON THE BEST PLAY. IT
WOULD BE IN THE ASK P. FOR BUT
ALL PROTECT THE COMMUNITY IN
ORDER MAKE THOSE. ISSUE IS
DISTRICT COURT WOULD HAVE TO
HAPPEN. AND WHAT TYPE OF TREAT
WHAT TYPE OF SUCCESS ON THREE
WHAT ARE THE TRIGGER AND WHERE
CONSISTS. FOR THEIR COULD BE
MEETINGS ASSISTANCE IN
CONSULTATION. BUT FOR THOSE
REASONS. D. CALIFORNIA JUST
TWENTY TO AS AS WE CAN GO COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE I
WOULD GREATLY OPPOSED CAN THIRTY
FOUR HOWEVER WE DO- RECOGNIZE
THERE ARE SOME VALUABLE
PROVISIONS AND WE'RE WILLING TO
WORK WITH THE SENATOR IN IN
MOVING THIS THIS LEGISLATION FOR
IF WE COULD COME TO SOME
AGREEMENT TO- REMOVE THE ROLE OF
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN
SELECTING A PLACEMENT FOR THE F.
FIFTY WHO'S BEEN CONDITIONALLY
RELEASED. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
LET ME GO TO THE HEARING AND SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN THE
ROOM WHO WANTS TESTIFIED IN
OPPOSITION. TO THE SP TEN THIRTY
FOUR. RIGHT SEEING NON MODERATOR
WE BUTTE PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY WHO
WANTS TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO TEN THIRTY FOUR. AND IN- FOR
THOSE OF YOU ON THE PHONE LINE
YOU WILL SAY YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION. AND THAT YOU OPPOSE
AND THAT'S IT. THAT'S THE POINT
WE'RE AT IN THIS- COMET. GO
AHEAD MODERATOR EIGHT. THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
OPPOSED SB TEN THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THERE ARE NO LINES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE CONTINUE. I'M
SORRY MARCH THIRTY IT USED TO
THE PAUSE ALL RIGHT SO- LET ME
TURN TO- COMMITTEE AND SEE IF
THERE'S ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. OKAY GO AHEAD-
SENATOR JOE BURKE I JUST HAVE
ONE QUESTION AND THAT'S WITH
REGARDS TO THE CONCERN THAT THE
DA- INCLUDING I THOUGHT IT YOU
SHOULD HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPRESS WHY THAT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT Y. INCLUDED THE DA IN
THAT DECISION SENATOR THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION AND I HOPE FOR
AN OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND I HAVE
SPOKEN WITH MY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
WE'VE WORKED TOGETHER ON MANY
ISSUES IN THE PAST FIRST WE DO
NOT BELIEVE THIS IS A CONFLICT
WE ARE SEEKING ADDITIONAL
COUNCIL TO CONFIRM THAT. SECOND
IT'S IN EXISTING PROTOCOL THAT
THE DA PARTICIPATE THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION MANDATES ALL PARTIES
COME TO THE TABLE. IT IS NOT
ASKING THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY TO
SELECT A PLACE THAT IS NOT THE
EXPERTISE OF THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY THEY DO REPRESENT THE
PEOPLE. AND THEY DO AN
INVESTIGATION TO DETERMINE IS
THE PLACEMENT BEING RECOMMENDED
BY THE CONTRACTOR LIBERTY AND
CON. CONCERT WITH THE OTHER
PARTIES AT THE TABLE THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER- IT IS NOT THEIR
EXPERTISE BUT THEY DO OF THEIR
OWN IN. ASSESSMENT INVESTIGATION
TO DETERMINE DOESN'T MEET THE
EXISTING LAW IN TERMS OF RADIUS
OF LOCATION TO FOR EXAMPLE CHILD
CARE SCHOOLS ECCENTRIC. SO THE
DA DOES THAT- THIS IS NOT ASKING
THEM TO PARTICIPATE IN THAT IN
DEPTH PROCESS OF FINDING A
LOCATION. BUT WHAT WE ARE
FINDING IS THAT PEOPLE DON'T
COME TO THE TABLE. R. WHILE
THERE IS A PROTOCOL THAT
EVERYONE COME TO THE TABLE THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN IT LEAVES THE
JUDGE IN THE POSITION OF HAVING
TO. TAKE THE ADVICE OF LIBERTY
THE CONTRACTOR WITH THE STATE
HOSPITALS AND TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION- WHEN I TALK ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
IT IS HAVING EVERY STAKEHOLDER
AT THE TABLE PLAYING THEIR ROLE.
OUGHT TO DETERMINE THAT THE
ACCOUNTABILITY IS TAKEN AND THAT
THERE IS TRANSPARENCY ON BEHALF
OF THE PUBLIC. AND THE RIVER
TAKE REPRESENTATION IS THERE FOR
THE INDIVIDUAL BEING CONSIDERED
SO. WHILE IT THE ISSUE IS IT
MAYBE IT SHOULD BE MANDATED
BECAUSE PEOPLE NEED TO COME TO
THE TABLE AND THE SECOND PIECE
SO IN RESPONSE WE DON'T THINK
THERE'S A CONFLICT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
WE WANT BETTER OUTCOMES- IN THE
PROCESS AND WE THINK- THIS GETS
TO THAT ISSUE AND I APPRECIATE
THE QUESTION CENTER. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND- A PROVIDES A
LITTLE MORE OF AN INSIGHT INTO
THE BALANCE AND I AM A HUGE
ADVOCATE OF HAVING ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO THE TABLE. TO
MAKE. A BETTER DECISION THANK
YOU- WE HAVE MOTION FROM-
SENATOR COM LONGER- AND- BEFORE
I ASK YOU TO CLOSE I WILL AND I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL AND
I WOULD RAISE. THE CONCERN THAT
THE DA SAID THAT THEY- DO YOU
KNOW DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
VARIOUS INFORMATION WHICH I'M
ASSUMING IS A HIP A RULE. AND
THEIR SUGGESTION THAT IT BE A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT INSTEAD A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WILL HAVE THE SAME
SITUATION AS THE DA'S SO GIVEN
FROM MY POINT OF VIEW IT IS THE
DH ROLE TO ENFORCE THE LAW THIS
IS THE LAW. AND YOUR CHANGE THAT
IS BEING RECOMMENDED HERE. IS
NOT. A OTHER THAN BROADENING THE
PROCESS AND- CLARIFYING SOME
THINGS IT IS STILL. IT IS STILL-
FIVE. IN FACT IT DID IT DID WERE
NOT FUN DOING IN THIS BILL THE
ESSENTIAL- CONRAD PROCESS OR CON
WRAP STATUTE SO I THINK THAT-
THE WELL I THINK THE DA'S OFFICE
THREE ENTITLED TO THEIR OPINION
AND THEIR OBJECTION I DON'T
THINK IT HAS. THE TYPE OF MERIT
THAT THE- PUT FORWARD IN THEIR
TESTIMONY SO ON. CENTER RACK AND
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES I WOULD
JUST SAY WE NEED TO MAKE THIS
PROCESS BETTER I YOU WILL SEE A
NUMBER OF BILLS OUT OF SAN DIEGO
COUNTY BECAUSE THE PROCESS
FAILED THE COMMUNITY. AND THE
SYSTEM- COULD HAVE WORKED BETTER
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS AT THE
TABLE MAKING A DETERMINATION
AND- THE WORST CASE SCENARIO IS
WERE PUT IN A CONSTITUTIONAL
BEHIND AND PEOPLE ARE RELEASED.
AND THAT IS NOT GOOD FOR THE
COMMUNITY IT'S NOT GOOD FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY IS NOT GOOD FOR
THE INDIVIDUAL I THINK WE ARE
WORKING VERY HARD TO MAKE SURE
WE HAVE A BETTER OUTCOME AND
PROCESS. OF FOR THE COMMUNITY
AND FOR THE SYSTEM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ALL RIGHT- GOOD NEWS
CONSULTANT YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE- MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SB TEN THIRTY
FOUR DO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
SKINNER HI SKINNER I INTRO BOGE.
TURBO GUY KAMARG- KAMAGRA BUY.
RIGHT THAT BILL WILL HAVE A PUT
ON- CALL- IT HAS THREE VOTES
WILL PUT ON CALL FOR ABSENT
UNDER MEMBER TO RETURN AND WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO S. B. EIGHT
FORTY ONE. SENATOR JONES. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. ON
THE- SUBJECT IS SEXUALLY VIOLENT
PREDATORS WILL CONTINUE AS A
SENATE BILL EIGHT FORTY ONE
WHICH PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
OVERSIGHT TO THE PROCESS BY
WHICH IS SEXUALLY VIOLENT
PREDATOR GETS PLACED BACK INTO
THE COMMUNITY. A SEXUALLY
VIOLENT PREDATOR AS SVP IS AN
INDIVIDUAL CONVICTED OF A
SEXUALLY VIOLENT OFFENSE AND
DIAGNOSED WITH A MENTAL DISORDER
THAT CAUSES THEM TO BE A DANGER
TO OTHERS. AND WITH A HIGH
LIKELIHOOD TO RE OFFEND. WHEN
STP IS DETERMINED TO BE READY
FOR RELEASED FROM CIVIL
COMMITMENT UNDER THE DEPARTMENT
OF STATE HOSPITALS A PROCESS
KNOWN AS CON REFEREE. BEGINS
WHICH THE SENATE PRO TEM JUST
ELOQUENTLY- EXPLAINED. CURRENTLY
THE DEPARTMENT USES A CONTRACTOR
TO EXECUTE THE ENTIRE CONRAD
PROCESS TAKING LITTLE TO NO
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
OVERSIGHT. THIS BILL MAKES
SEVERAL IMPORTANT UPDATES TO THE
CONRAD PROCESS. FIRST SB EIGHT
FORTY ONE WILL REQUIRE THE
HIGHEST PRIORITY FOR ALL
POTENTIAL AS P. P. COMMUNITY
PLACEMENTS TO BE PUBLIC SAFETY.
ADDITIONALLY EIGHT FORTY ONE
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT TO TAKE
A BIGGER ROLE IN THE CONRAD. BY
REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT TO
APPROVE ANY LEASE- RESIDENTIAL
LEASE THAT THE VENDOR SIGNS
BEFORE IT IS SIGNED. THISWILL
HELP CURB THE ISSUE OF THE
VENDOR BEING COMMITTED TO A
LEASE BEFORE JUDGE HAS APPROVED
THE PLACEMENT AND S. AND US
BEING STUCK WITH THE PAYMENT IF
THE PLACEMENT IS DENIED. FINALLY
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL TRANSPARENCY BY
REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT TO
POLLUTION ANNUAL PUBLIC REPORT
ABOUT PLACEMENTS. AND REQUIRING
SEVERAL STATE AGENCIES TO ACCESS
PUBLIC LANDS IN THEIR CONTROL
THE MAY BE ADEQUATE AND THE
PROPER USE FOR SEP PLACEMENTS.
THESE SMALL CHANGES WILL AFFORD
MORE OVERSIGHT ON THE PLACEMENT
TO PLACEMENT PROCESS AND HELP
ENSURE MORE APPROPRIATE
PLACEMENTS OF S. V. PEAS. ON THE
LINE WITH ME THIS MORNING IS
PATRICK ESPINOSA FROM THE SAN
DIEGO DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
IN AUDREY- RAY TYPE CHECK
RETIRED CHECK ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY OF SACRAMENTO. IF WE CAN
GO TO THE PHONE LINES THAT WOULD
BE GREAT. THANK YOU SENATOR
JONES DO WE HAVE PATRICK
ESPINOSA ON THE LINE. YES TRY
AGAIN PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
I'M PATRICK ESPINOSA THE CHIEF
DEPUTY DA SANYO COUNTY ON BEHALF
OF SAN DIEGO DISTRICT ATTORNEY
SUMMER STEPHAN. JANUARY FIRST
THE SCHOOL SEXUALLY VIOLENT
PREDATORS CONDITIONING RELEASED
FROM THE STATE HOSPITAL IN PLACE
IN THE COMMUNITY UNDER THE
SUPERVISION OF THE DEPARTMENT
STATE HOSPITALS IN LIBERTY STATE
HEALTH CARE THAT SIXTEEN FOR THE
ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO
THIS WHAT NOT A LARGE NUMBER IN
JANUARY WE DON'T SUSPECT THAT
HAS CHANGED MUCH FIVE OF THOSE
SIXTEEN S. B. P.'S WORK
CONDITION RELEASED AND PLACED IN
THE COMMUNITY WERE ACTUALLY
PLACED IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY. FOR
SEVERAL YEARS NOW THE STATE'S
FORENSIC CONDITIONAL EACH
PROGRAM KNOWN AS CONRAD HAS NOT. WORKING AS ORIGINALLY INTENDED
. THE CALIFORNIA TO IT HOSPITAL
AND GIVEN COMPLETE CONTROL COSTS
. TO PRIVATE CONTRACTORS LIBERTY
HELL CARE. RECENTLY TO STATE
HOSPITAL AND HEALTH. HAVE SOUGHT
TO PLAY PLACE AT THE PEACE AND
MORE HEAVILY. AREAS COMPARED TO
THE PREVIOUS. SOME PLACEMENTS
HAVE BEEN RAISED COMMUNITIES AND
SPARK CLOSER EXAMINATION
PROCESS. LOCATING HOUSING IN
SECURING PLACEMENTS FOR
CONDITIONING BELIEVES SEXUALLY
VIOLENT PREDATORS FOR EXAMPLE
WOULD BE HEALTHCARE ALSO
RECENTLY TRIED TO PLACE DOUBLES
BADGER WHO NAY TO RAPING OVER
FIVE HUNDRED YOUNG BOYS AND
GIRLS IT JUST CENTER ACTIONS
DISTRICT. THE RESIDENTIAL AREA
WITH LIBERTY TRIED TO PLACE MR
BADGER WAS CLOSE. TO A HIGH
SCHOOL JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL.
COMMUNITY LEADERS SAY WAS MAY.
PROPOSED THIS MOTION WHICH PLACE
OF. AND ALL THE STP. WAS NOT
PLACED AT THE LOOK. SENATE BILL
EIGHT FORTY ONE WHAT HELP FIX
THIS BROKEN STP PLACEMENT SYSTEM
BRING HIM BACK ACCOUNTABILITY
REQUIRING GREATER COMPLICATION
INSTATING TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOCTORS TAXPAYER DOLLARS. IN
UNSUCCESSFUL PLACEMENT ATTACHED
SB EIGHT FORTY ONE REQUIRED THE
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS TO
PROVIDE AN ANNUAL REPORT THAT
PUBLISHES THE NUMBER OF S. U. P.
STAGE COUNTY. AT EACH SUPERVISOR
DISTRICT WHERE THERE ARE PLACED
ON CONDITIONAL RELEASE. SB SIX
ONE WOULD ALSO MAKE PUBLIC
SAFETY THE HIGHEST PRIORITY
CONSERVING PLACEMENT. THE BILL
WOULD ALSO REQUIRED PART OF THE
STATE HOSPITALS TO APPROVE
PLACEMENTS REPORTER CONTRACTOR
ENTERS INTO LEASE AGREEMENTS AND
BORDERS PLACEMENTS. SAVING
MONEY. AND IT WOULD ALSO REQUIRE
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION STATE
HOSPITALS AND HELP BUYERS JEFF
SESSIONS ALL LAND UNDER THEIR
CONTROL REPORT TO THE GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE ON ANY
INVENTORY THAT COULD BE USED.
HOW CAN. THAT CHANGE K. DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE STRONGLY
SUPPORTS SENATE BILL EIGHT FORTY
ONE WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR.
CONSIDERATION YEAH. THE NORTH.
THANKS. THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
REYES THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR IS
ASSIGNED WE HAVE WE'RE GONNA
MOVE FOR WITH OUR SECOND WITH IN
SUPPORT AUDREY RIGHT CHECK. ARE
YOUR MIND MEMBERS ID YES ARE YOU
RETIRED CHECK FROM CRUISE
STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND ALSO WITH
THE SUPPORT OF OUR SACRAMENTO
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE- WE'RE HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF SB FORTY ONE BY
SENATOR JOHN. THE
THOUGHTLESSNESS OF SEXUALLY
VIOLENT PREDATOR ACCOUNTABILITY
FAIRNESS AND ENFORCEMENT ACT
OVERSEEING THAT WE CAN AFFECT
THE PEACE UPON THERE WILL BE. SB
FORTY ONE REQUIRES THE H. R.
DEPARTMENT THE HOSPITAL TO
VERIFY WITH THE COUNTY EXECUTIVE
OFFICER TO PROVIDE A DISTRICT IN
WHICH AN FTP IF PROPOSED
REPLACEMENT AND TO PREPARE
ANNUAL REPORT OF THE NUMBER OF
THE PEOPLE UNDER THEIR
SUPERVISION IN FACT THE BY WHICH
COUNTY SUPERVISOR DISTRICTS. THE
PREDATORS YOU CAN THE ACT OF
SEXUAL VIOLENCE ARE A DANGER TO
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES THE CURRENT
PROCESS FOR RELEASING SB PEAS
INTO OUR COMMUNITY INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES AT RISK SB EIGHT
FORTY ONE AND HALF OF THE
NOTIFICATION FOR FTP PLACEMENT
INTO A COMMUNITY. SO FOR THESE
REASONS SACRAMENTO COUNTY OR DID. YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
AUDREY WHO WILL MOVE TO. OUR OUR
- WITNESSES- SUPPORT ARE HE- IN
TWENTY TWO DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. S. B.
EIGHT FORTY ONE SCENE NINE. WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE OR VERSUS
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPTLY INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
EIGHT FORTY ONE. WE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU IF YOU'D LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
FORTY ONE PRESS ONE NINE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. IN LINE FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
JOHNSON CLAIRE ABOUT THE COUNTY
SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES IN
SUPPORT PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IF YOU DON'T MIND-
CHECKING THE LINES JUST ONE MORE
TIME TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
LISTENED. FROM ALL OF OUR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
EIGHT FORTY ONE. THANK YOU AGAIN
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT FORTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND THERE ARE NOLINES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR HAVING HER FROM
ALL THE SUPPORTERS WILL NOT
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE
FROM- OUR OPPOSITION. AB AND WE
HAVE ONE LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS
AND THAT IS- EVAN THOMAS. ALVIN
ARE YOU ON THE LINE. YES I AM
PLEASE PROCEED SIR. MEMBERS OF
THE MORNING ON MEMBERS OF THE
BOARD APPRECIATE- GIVE ME THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK MY NAME IS
OFTEN HOW MUCH I AM PUBLIC
DEFENDER AND- OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY- THAT THIS- BUT- B. I. C.
TRY OF THAT CIVIL COMMITMENT YOU
. I DON'T SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC BECAUSE SHE'S
ALL WE ARE OPPOSE- CENTER BILL
EIGHT QUALITY ONE- THIS BILL
WITH TO CURTAIL THE PLACEMENT OF
MIND BAND WITHIN THE VEHICLES.
WELLBEING COMMITTEE ON THE
RESPECTFULLY VIOLENT PREDATOR
ACT AND IT WOULD MAKE YEAH- IT
WOULD CREATE. HURDLES AND MORE
WHO ARE PERCEIVED AND ALLOW ME
TO BE WE NEED INTO THE- WHAT
THING THAT FIFTH. MANY OF US
BECAUSE ARE IN. COOL SUPPORTING
THEIR OUT TO RECORD THAT INCLUDE
. FOR US WHO THINK ANOTHER SO
FIVE PREDATOR HERE IN THE STATE
. WELL TO BE. INTO THE- IF ONLY
I. A INTENSE TREATMENT AT THE
TOP OF A AB STATE FACILITY A
HOSPITAL CURRENTLY IT COMING UP
THE HOSPITAL AND IS. A MAN I'M
IN ON AVERAGE- THEY ARE ASKED
THOSE WHO ARE ON. OUR RELEASED
ARE. AT THE HOSPITAL BETWEEN THE
TWO YEAR TO BE TREAT ABOUT ONCE
THE- ANY NUMBER OF X. AT THE
TIME THAT THE PER IS KNOWN A-
THEN THE ARE. BOOK RELEASE ONLY
A HEARING BEFORE A AGE. AND THE
JUDGE AFTER THE BREAK. WHETHER
IT IN IS NOT WITH TO COMMUNITY
SO IN THAT SENSE THEY ALL KNOW
LONGER A SEXUALLY PREDATOR THEY
ARE IN THE- WHO HAS RECEIVED.
AND HAVE BEEN BEAT THAT THEY
KNOW. MEET THE CRITERIA OF THE
SEXUALLY VIOLENT PREDATOR AND
THAT ARE NO LONGER A DANGER TO
THE COMMUNITY. FILLING A STATE
HOSPITAL DIRECT CURRENTLY NINE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE. AT THE
PEACE HOUSE HERE MISTER THEM
PERMISSION I RECEIVED ON MARCH
TWENTY SECOND BY THE- COMING UP
THEY ARE. WELL DEPARTMENT
HOSPITAL A LEGAL- AND THAT'S ONE
MAN- DO YOU HAVE STATE WIDE
EIGHT OF SIX. IN A BETA RELEASED
FROM RELEASE NOT ONLY IS A.
AND SO ONE PART OF THE BILL THAT
REQUIRES TO BE AVERAGE THERE WAS
NO URGENCY AND THAT. WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT THE BLOOD OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEEN
COMMITTED THAT ACT THE PEACE
BEING RELEASED ON CONDITIONAL
RELEASE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT LESS
THAN TWO PERSPECTIVE. LESS THAN
TWO PERCENT- AND- IN ORDER TO BE
TO ACTUALLY MAKE IT THROUGH THE
PROGRAM TO GET TO THE POINT
WHERE THE HOSPITAL AGREED TO
NEVER EXPERTS AGREE TELL US AT.
THE STATE HOSPITAL AGREED THAT
THE PERSON IS NO LONGER THE
DANGER TO THE COMMUNITY YEAH THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN CIVIL.
COMMITMENT AND I'M IN AND PEOPLE
ALSO UP TERM SUSPENDED NOT
SUPPOSED TO BE AT BUT AGAIN.
WHEN THEY'RE BEING. GIVEN THE
I'M- TO BE WITH INTO COME IN-
THEN THE PUNISHED AGAIN- BE
PLACE ON. TOP PRESIDENT BUSH. I
HAVE A PO TO BEING RELEASED INTO
THE COULD. TO BE IN IN ERA THAT
IS ON- AND HOW. WILL NOT HAVE A
BY GENERAL PUBLIC- IT IS
PUNITIVE BE PLACED IN A FOR
THREE ONE BACK TO ACTUALLY ASK A
- THAT HAVE NO. NO HIS- AND HEY
IT. NO AND PLAY IN THE- TO BE
BECOME THE CURRENT PROVIDER
LIBERTY. HAS INDICATED THAT.
THEY'VE DONE THAT A NUMBER TIMES
YOU KNOW THEY ARE THE SOLE BUT-
THE IMPORTANT THING THAT IS
BEING. OVER THAT THEY HAVE THE
101% RECORD MEANING THAT NOT A
SINGLE. THAT BEEN WE- IN THE ON
THIS RELEASE AS WE HAVE BEEN
DEBT AND A SEXUAL MANNER NOW AC
ONE. AND THEN AND AGAIN HELLO
OVER THEMSELVES EVEN THE BILL
WHO A OF AND HAVE BEEN DOING
THAT FOR SOME TIME NOW THE
THINGS. OF THE LONG THEY
ACTUALLY KNOW WHAT DOING AND
THEY INSTEAD BECAUSE THEY RUN
THEM. I THOUGHT THAT WOULD MEAN
BACK WOULD BE. YOU KNOW THE. IS
THE REMOTE THAT WELL. THE FACT
UP UPON NOTICE WHO. IT MAY THERE
ARE THEY HEARING OF THE ATTORNEY
OFFICE- HAS THE OP TO HEARD- THE
LOWER POLICING A- HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE. L. A. K.
WHILST WE HAVE CLASS. I 2020% OF
THE ACT EXACTLY AS THEY HOW. WE
A ONE PERSON ONE PERSON. OR.
CONDITIONAL ALSO. PROGRAM WOULD
HAVE BEEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WOULD YOU JUST CLICK THE START
TO WRAP UP IN IN CLOSER TO THIS
MORE. RIGHT I WILL AND SO. AT
THAT HEARING- WELL ONE PERSON
WHO WAS RELEASED THE- OKAY
RELEASE I'M NOT ONLY THAT THIS
ATTORNEY HAVE BEYOND TO BE HEARD
BUT THE LOCAL NATURE BECOMING
AND WHICH THEY POINT RENEW AT
THE OPPORTUNITY THE P. HER AND
OF COURSE- TO MY- THEY DID WHAT
CANCELED ACCORDING TO TERMS
WITHIN A- AND SO FOUND ANOTHER
LOW SO THE OF THE COMMUNITY THAT
IS THAT NOT GIVEN ENOUGH. TO BE
HEARD IT'S JUST IT IS IT'S THE
METHOD WHAT HAPPENED AND SO.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF S. B.
EIGHT FORTY ONE HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES. SCENE NINE MADAM
MODERATOR WOULD YOU MIND-
OPENINGTHE LINE TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT FORTY ONE
PLEASE. THANK YOU HERE IN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. OKAY JUST A MOMENT
FOR OUR FIRST. THANK YOU THANK
YOU OUR WATER HEATER. THERE
ARE A AND THEN LET ME ASK A
FOLLOW UP QUESTION
YOUR FROM LINE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
RICHELLE COUNTER I-AM A
RESIDENT OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
AND AYE OPPOSED AT FIFTY EIGHT
FOUR ONE. A LINE SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY FAMILY
WONDER ON BEHALF OF THE YOUNG
WOMEN FREEDOM CENTER AND SISTER
WARRIORS FREEDOM COALITION AND
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. NO FURTHER
LINES IN OPPOSITION MANAGER
PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MATTER MODERATOR WOULD YOU
MIND TAKING THE WIND JUST ONE
MORE TIME SURE THAT WE'VE HEARD
FROM ALL OF OUR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT FORTY ONE
PLEASE. THANK YOU YES ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OF S.
B. EIGHT FORTY ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
THERE ARE NO FURTHER LINES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE CONTINUE TO.
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR AND
WOULD LIKE TO THANK ALL OF OUR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WE WILL NOT BRING THE DISCUSSION
MY APOLOGIES. MY APOLOGIES THERE
IS A LINE THAT IS NOW IN THE
QUEUE HERE ONE MOMENT PERFECT
GLAD WE CHECKED. AND- THE REAL ISSUE IS
THAT THE AUTHOR. IN TAKING THIS
ON WHICH IN SOME WAYS THANK
LINE SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HI MY NAME IS ALAN I LIVE IN
LOS ANGELES AND CRISIS FOR
MAKING HUMAN TRAFFICKING A THREE
FIVE- I DON'T TELL ME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE ARE ACTUALLY NOT ON
THAT BILL RIGHT NOW WE ARE
CURRENTLY ADDRESSING S. B. EIGHT
FORTY ONE BY IN ORDER TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS THANK YOU FOR
CALLING INDIAN ENGAGE CITIZENS.
AND THERE ARE NO FURTHER LINES
IN OPPOSITION. I THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR THANK YOU TO OUR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WILL NOW BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO OUR MEMBERS TO ANY OF
OUR MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM- VOICED HER. OF
A MEMBER MEMBER AT ALL- SO- I'M
NOT QUESTION OF SOME COMMON
PERSONAL IT'S I I'VE BEEN-
LITTLE. IS WONDERING UNDER
THEIR- THREE SEXUALLY VIOLENT
PREDATOR PLACE FROM BILLS- FOR
THIS COMMITTEE THIS MORNING ALL
FROM- THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
DELEGATION SO. NOT SURE WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY
BUT- I CAN I CAN SUSPECT- THESE
ARE SOME OF THE HARDEST ISSUES
AND I WILL TELL YOU WHEN I WAS
A- MEMBER OF THE- SAN FRANCISCO
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
REPRESENTING A VERY. AGGRESSIVE
DISTRICT. THERE WAS A PROPOSAL
TO OPEN UP. THIS NOT FOR SEX
LEVINE PREDATORS OR FOR LOWER
LEVEL SEX OFFENDERS A TREATMENT.
CENTER AGAIN FOR LOW LEVELS NOT
THE BOND PRESSURES- SEX OFFENDER
TREATMENT. FACILITIES WERE VERY
REPUTABLE NONPROFIT IN ONE OF
THE MOST PROGRESSIVE.
NEIGHBORHOODS IN MY PROGRESSIVE.
DISTRICT AND- THE. PITCHFORKS
HIM OUT AND I. IT WAS FOR THE
MOST AND CAN MEET- BUT I EVER
THIS. ABSOLUTE ELECTED OFFICIALS
AND- AND LEFT THE SAN FRANCISCO-
SO I CAN ONLY IMAGINE IN TERMS
OF YOUR PLACEMENT IN ONE WHO HAS
BEEN COMBINED AS- AN ADJUDICATED
AS A SEXUALLY VIOLENT PREDATOR-
WHAT YOU KNOW THAT THE TENSION
RESCUE BECAUSE IN THE COMMUNITY
SO I. COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND THAT
AND I. UNDERSTAND WHY YOU'RE
PEOPLE'S DO YOU KNOW DEEP
CONCERN- AT THE SAME TIME- WHEN
SOMEONE HAS DONE THEIR TIME IN
PRISON AND YOUR PRISON SENTENCES
FOR SEXUALLY VIOLENT PEOPLE ARE
CONVICTED OF THESE. VERY HIGH
LEVEL OFFENSES- ARE NOT. LIGHT
THESE ARE HEAVY SENTENCES. AND
THE PERSON HAS BEEN RELEASED AND
I WAS DONE HOWEVER MANY
ADDITIONAL YEARS AND CAN BE A
LONG PERIOD OF TIME. A COMBINED
POST SENTENCE AS SEXUALLY
VIOLENT PREDATOR AND THAT HAS
GONE THROUGH THE PROCESS AND
THEN DETERMINED BY. MEANT BY
PSYCHIATRISTS OR PSYCHOLOGISTS
IN THE COURT- AS HAVING- ISN'T
NO LONGER BEING DANGEROUS
THEY'VE DONE THEIR PRISON TIME
THEY'VE GONE THROUGH HOWEVER
MANY YEARS OF CONFINED. THREE
MEN AND THEY'VE BEEN JUDICATA- I
WAS NO LONGER BEING A THREAT-
AND THEN BAY YEAR WITH CITIZENS
ARE WITHOUT. HARM ARE GOING INTO
THE COMMUNITY AND THEY'RE
TYPICALLY GOING BACK TO THE-
COUNTY WHERE THEY WERE FROM
BEFORE AND THERE ARE CERTAIN
STANDARDS FOR ONE THEY'RE SENT
TO OTHER COUNTIES- BUT- YOU KNOW
IT AT. SOME POINT BACK TO THE
HOUSE BUTTE- AND IF AND WHEN WE
CREATE ALL THESE. RESTRICTIONS
AND I'M NOT PUTTING THIS ON YOUR
BILL BECAUSE THERE BEEN OTHER
BILLS AND BALLOT MEASURES IT YOU
KNOW MAKING IT IMPOSSIBLE TO
LIVE IN CERTAIN CITIES. YOUR
WITHIN TWO THOUSAND FEET OF A
PARK OR- OUR SCHOOL- IF SOMEONE
THEY JUST BECOME HOMELESS- AND
THEN THEY'RE- MORE LIKELY TO
RESET OF EIGHT- AS OPPOSED TO
MAKING SURE THAT HOUSING. IS TO
EMPLOYMENT. AND SO FORTH SO- I
UNDERSTAND THEM MOTIVATION.
BEHIND THIS BILL I DON'T THINK
IT'S ABOUT MOTIVATION I THINK
YOUR- REPRESENTING YOUR
CONSTITUENTS- BUT I'D BILLS JUST
THERE THERE'S JUST TOO MUCH IN
THIS BILL. ARE PROBLEMATIC FOR
ME AND SO I WON'T BE ABLE TO-
SUPPORTED TODAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FEDERAL INNER AND- I JUST
LIKE TO ADD SOME COMMON- THE
THAT YOU JUST MADE. WITH WEEK
TO. PEOPLE LEFT THEIR TIME SPURS
AT THIS WE JUST HEARD SENATOR I
THIS BILL- ALL READ- TO DO WITH
. SEXUALLY VIOLENT- PRESS RSVP
AND THEIR RELEASE AND HAVING
PEOPLE THINK HOLDERS AT THE
TABLE TO FOLLOW THROUGH BUT WAS
INTERESTING TO NOTE WAS SOME OF
THE COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE- AT
THIS. OR IN HER. STATEMENT WHICH
I THINK VERY ENLIGHTENED. AND IT
SAYS HERE- THIS IS A NEW SPACE
FOR ME SO I APOLOGIZE IF I DON'T
COME ACROSS AS A SPACE FOR A LOT
OF US. ELOQUENT ON HERE BUT I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND TO IN ORDER
TO BE- OBJECTIVE IN AND FAIR IN
IN OUR ANALYSIS BUT THIS YEAR
THAT- A PATIENT. ROOM YOU KNOW
KNOWN AS A CONDITIONAL RELEASE
CONRAD A COURT DETERMINES THAT A
PATIENT CAN BE SAFELY PLACE IN
THE COMMITTEE WITH STRICT
CONDITIONS- STRICT CONDITIONS
OUT THERE EVEN THOUGH THEY HAVE
SERVED THEIR TIME AND HAVE
RECEIVED TREATMENT SENT SOME OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS. STILL HAVE TO
BE SUPERVISED AND- SENATOR I
CAN'T THAT I DON'T HAVE I WAS
JUST TRYING TO FIND THESE THE
LIST REALLY QUICK ON HERE BUT
SOME OF THE- THINGS THAT HAVE TO
BE FOLLOWED IN OVER IN ORDER FOR
THEM TO BE ACTUALLY IT BEAM. I'M
PUBLIC AND I'M NOT SURE IF WE
HAVE SOMEBODY HERE THAT HOUSES
EXPERTISE BUT- SOME OF THEM HAVE
TO BE MONITOR THEY HAVE TO BE
SUPERVISED THEY HAVE TO HAVE-
ANYWAY. WE'RE SAYING IS. THERE'S
CERTAIN THE COMPONENTS THAT COME
INTO PLAY. WHEN SOMEONE IS
RETURN INTO- A COMMUNITY THAT IS
THAT IS THAT. THAT IS NEEDED IN
ORDER TO BE PLACING HIM IN
RESEARCH EVEN THOUGH THEY HAVE
SERVED THEIR TIME THERE STILL
HAS TO BE CERTAIN PHONES OR
ELEMENTS WITHIN WITHIN- WITHIN
THAT RELEASE CONDITIONS THAT
NEED TO BE REALLY SO- I JUST
THOUGHT I'D MENTION IT BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT JUST CURED AND PUT
INTO PLACE THERE'S STILL SOME
THINGS THAT NEED TO BE- IN PLACE
FOR THAT- SO I ACTUALLY
APPRECIATE THIS BILL- S. SENATOR
JONES AND I THINK- AS YOU
MENTIONED EARLIER TO YOUR POINT
CENTER WIENER. IT IS KIND OF
INTERESTING THAT WE HAVE SEVERAL
BILLS- YOU KNOW THE SAME AREA IN
AYE SO THERE'S OBVIOUSLY A NEED-
SAID THAT HE THAT IS TRYING TO
GET BACK HERE SO WITH THAT IN-
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THE BILL
I'M NOT SURE I CAN MAKE A MOTION
. THE BILL RICHARD DO WE WAIT.
WE CAN DO A MOTION WHEN SENATOR
SKINNER COMES BACK OKAY. SO WENT
UP. A GYM A MOVE THE BILL JUST
BECAUSE WE'VE OTHER MEMBERS
ABSENCES- OF. AS A COURTESY AS A
COURTESY I'M GOING TO VOTE
AGAINST THE BILL BUT ALSO ARE
MOVING TO THIS IS A COURTESY OF
THE AUTHOR. THANK YOU. HELLO
CLOSE AT YES SENATOR JOSEPH
WHICH TO CLOSE YES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- YOU KNOW THAT YOU'RE
RIGHT THERE ARE THERE ARE AND I
THINK THERE'S SOME ASSEMBLY
BILLS- FROM SENIOR COUNTY
DEALING WITH THIS ISSUE AS WELL
AND THEN THE REASON. RIGHT NOW
THAT SAN DIEGO COUNTY IS ON HIGH
ALERT ON THIS IS BECAUSE OF TWO
PARTICULAR. REALLY SEES THAT-
THE- THE- STATE CONTRACTOR. I
TRIED THREE DIFFERENT TIMES FOR
DIFFERENT TIMES. IN THREE
DIFFERENT IN FOUR DIFFERENT
NEIGHBORHOODS IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY TO PLACES TO. REALLY SEES
THAT- IT'S CONTRARY TO THE POINT
OF THEM BEING CURED AND
ADJUDICATED THAT THEY'RE SAFE. I
ACTUALLY THE WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL ACTUALLY
TAKES OFFENSE TO SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT HE MADE REGARDING
ABOUT THEM BEING NON DANGEROUS
AND ADJUDICATED TO BE- SAFER
RELEASED BOTH OF THESE.
RELEASEES HAD RE IF BEEN
RELEASED PRIOR AND RE OFFENDED-
THEY HAVE A RECORD OF GOING INTO
PRISON AND COMING OUT OF PRISON
AND GOING BACK INTO PRION UNDER
THE S. V. P. PROGRAM. WHAT A LOT
OF PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THIS S. B.
P. AT THIS IS JUST NOT A MADE UP
TERM THAT THE NEWS MADE UP OR
THE LEGEND YOU KNOW THE- PROCESS
OF. IT'S A IT'S A LEGAL TERM
IT'S A IT'S A LEGAL PROSECUTE
PROSECUTORIAL TERM THAT IS
PLACED ON THESE PARTICULAR
OFFENDERS. BECAUSE THEIR CRIME
IS SO HEINOUS. AND THEIR VICTIMS
ARE SO. IT DAMAGE PHYSICALLY AND
MENTALLY SOME OF THEM MURDERED-
ALL OF THEM RATES TO SOME DEGREE
. THAT THAT THE CALIFORNIA COURT
SYSTEM AND LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
HAVE THESE HAS DETERMINED THE S.
V. P. IS THE WORST OF THE WORST
. AND- THERE IS A LEGITIMATE
SCIENCE AND INTERVIEWS WITH S.
V. PEAS THAT THEM THEY
THEMSELVES SAY. I AM NOT CURABLE
. AND THIS PROBLEM THAT I HAVE
IS PERMANENT AND AT AND IS IT IS
A PROBLEM AND WHAT WHEN YOU GET
SAID SOMEBODY HAD MET THAT- YOU
KNOW THAT THAT'S A PRETTY BIG.
THANK TO ME US SENATOR COUNTY
AND THREE OF THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS
IN MY DISTRICT THAT THEY'VE
TRIED TO PLACE THESE. SB PEAS
AND THE PURPOSE FOR MY BILL
WHICH IS A BIPARTISAN BILLS CO
AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOPER. IN CENTER HUESO AND
SEVERAL OTHER- SINNERS. I. THE
CONTRACTOR ONCE THE STATE TURNS
THE ISRAELI SEES OVER TO THE
CONTRACTOR THIS STATE HAS WASHED
ITS HANDS OF THE OF THE
SITUATION OF THE PROBLEM AND IS
NO LONGER. TAKES RESPONSIBILITY
FOR WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE
NEIGHBORHOODS. FOUR TIMES FOUR
TIMES THIS CONTRACTOR TRIED TO
PLACE BOTH OF THESE REALLY SEES
IN THE SAME HOME. IN A
NEIGHBORHOOD. NOT A RURAL
NEIGHBORHOOD NOT A SECLUDED
NEIGHBORHOOD. A NEIGHBORHOOD
WITH CHILDREN ON THE VERY SAME
STREET THAT THE CONTRACTOR AT
LEAST TO THE HOUSE. A
NEIGHBORHOOD THAT WITHIN WALKING
DISTANCE OF ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS.
M. PRESCHOOLS WHICH AS WAS
STATED BY THE SAN DIEGO DA ONE
OF THE REALLY SEES FIVE HUNDRED
VICTIMS. MINOR VICTIMS FIVE
HUNDRED VICTIMS. FOUR EIGHT.
PROVIDE HE PERFORMED VIOLENT
SEXUAL ACTS ON FIVE HUNDRED.
CHILDREN. LET THAT SINK IN THE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. A
PERSON CAN COMMIT THOSE KIND OF
CRIMES AND STILL BE RELEASED
FROM PRISON. THAT PERSON SHOULD
NEVER BE RELEASED FROM THAT
WOULD BE MY YOU KNOW IF I WAS
WRITING THIS V. P. LOCK- AND HAD
MY ENTIRE WAY IF I WAS KING FOR
A DAY. THESE GUYS WOULD NEVER
GET OUT OF PRISON AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT THE COMMUNITIES
EXPECT. ABOUT WHEN THESE GUYS
FINALLY GET CONVICTED AND SENT
TO PRISON. AND SENT AWAY. THE
URGENCY. ADDRESSING THE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. IS THAT
THESE PLACEMENTS WERE IN AREAS
WHERE THERE'S HUNDREDS OF
CHILDREN. THAT'S THE URGENCY LET
ALONE THAT THERE'S ONLY SIXTEEN
. THE APPROPRIATE PRICE QUESTION
ABSOLUTELY RATHER I'M SORRY NOT
YOUR CLOTHES BUT NO I KNOW I
FISH NO I'M I'M IF SOMEONE IF
SOMEONE COMMITTED VIOLENT SEXUAL
ACTS AND FIVE HUNDRED PEOPLE.
WHY DID YOUR DA NOT SEEK TO SEND
THAT PERSON AWAY FOREVER BECAUSE
THAT TO ME IS NOT ABOUT. THE
SECTION BY A PREDATOR STATUTE IF
SOMEONE TRULY COMMITTED SUCH
VIOLENT SEXUAL ACTS AGAINST FIVE
HUNDRED PEOPLE. I DON'T SEE ANY
COUNTY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. NOT PUTTING THAT
PERSON AWAY FOREVER- AND SAN
DIEGO COUNTY DA IS NOT EXACTLY
PROBABLY A- YOU KNOW. BUT WHEN
YOU'RE AN ATHLETE YOU CAN THE
MOST LEFT WING DA WOULD PUT PUT
PUT THAT PERSON AWAY FOREVER- SO
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT TO ME IS
NOT A SEXUALLY VIOLENT PREDATOR
STATUTE ISSUE. THAT'S AN ISSUE
OF IT THE L. WHY SOMEONE LIKE
THAT WOULD NOT BE PROSECUTED IN
A WAY. TO PUT THEM AWAY FOREVER.
IF I IF YOU'RE- I'M JUST GOT.
MISTRUST AND I WAS JUST ON THE
LINE IF YOU'D LIKE TO ASK HIM
THAT QUESTION MAY BE AS ANSWER
OR I CAN GET BACK TO. I WOULD
HAPPY RESPONDED CENTER LEADERS
QUESTION IN GENERAL WE ARE EACH
ISSUE OF STATUE OF LIMITATIONS
AND DISCLOSURE SO PART OF THE
TREATMENT THAT SEXUAL BUYING
PRINTERS AT WHICH SHE WHY THE
STATE HOSPITAL BECAUSE THEY WILL
COME TO GRIPS WITH WHAT MAKES
THEM BY AND VIOLATE IN THEIR
PAST HISTORY AND SOME OF THE
SCHOOLS WHAT THE HISTORY WAS
WHERE THERE IS NO ABILITY TOGO
BACK AND PROSECUTOR CRIME FROM
THE PAST- THAT IS- IF THEY'RE
STATUTES LIMITATION PROBLEMS
NORTH THERE. WILL DISCLOSURE TO
A PROSECUTING ANTI DEPRESSANTS
MORE TREATMENT YEAH WITH RESPECT
TO GETTING THAT IT SHOULD FROM
THE OFFENDER. THAT ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS WIENER- YEAH I HAVE A
I APPRECIATE THAT CLARK I JUST
THINK IT'S IT THAT'S IF SOMEONE
- TRULY COMMITTED THAT LEVEL OF
OFFENSE THEY THERE ARE THERE ARE
TOOLS TO DEAL WITH THAT AND WE
DID TERM THAT WE REMOVE THE
STATUTE ON READY FOR WE EXTENDED
A- AT. THIS POINT IT'S REMOVING
AB RIGHT BUT WE EXTENDED IT
CHILDREN IT'S BEEN X. IS SOMEONE
THAT HAPPENED WHEN THEY WERE
YOUNG IT'S BEEN EXTENDED TILL.
YOU'RE IN YOUR THIRTIES FOR
YEARS THAT'S THAT WE DID LIKE
TEN OTHER YEARS IS. CURRENTLY IS
NOSE STARTS IT WAS WE REMOVE THE
STATUE LIMITATIONS FOR RAPE WAS
AT THE- YES OKAY THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU AT ZERO NINE
FIVE ACTUALLY APPRECIATE YOU
ASKING THE QUESTION AND
INTERPRETATION I DON'T MIND YOU.
YOU'RE KIND ENOUGH TO MAKE THE
MOTIONS ARE MINE GENERATING I'LL
WRAP UP IN IN THANK YOU AND I
WANT TO SEE THANK YOU TO THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- THEY DID A
GREAT JOB- YOU KNOW I WOULD
WELCOME THE- L. A. PUBLIC
DEFENDERS AND THEIR MEMBERS IN
THEIR STATION THERE SO- IF THEY
BELIEVE IN THEIR COMMENTS SO
MUCH. AND THAT THIS IS NOT A
PROBLEM AND IT'S NOT URGENT. WHY
I WALK IN THE BUILDING EIGHTY
YOU ON ON THEIR PROPERTY AND
WELCOME THESE FOLKS TO MOVE INTO
THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD AND MOVE INTO
THEIR HOME. AND THEY KEEP AN EYE
ON. THE PURPOSE OF MY BILL IS IT
IS RIGHT. NOT IT IS VERY ROBUST
MY BILL IS VERY ROBUST I ADMIT
THAT- THERE'S A LOT IN IT- AND
THAT'S PURPOSELY LISO BECAUSE WE
WANT TO FLUSH OUT A LOT OF THESE
ISSUES. I WOULD LIKE- IF THE
BILL DOESN'T PASS TODAY
RECONSIDERATION. TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RE ENGAGE WITH
THE MEMBERS AND COME UP WITH A
SOLUTION THAT DOES WORK. THE
PURPOSE OF MY BILL TODAY IS TO
PROTECT. RESIDENTS ANDERSON
FAMILIES CHILDREN WOMEN ABOUT
THE ENTIRE STATE YES THIS HAS
BECOME A SAN DIEGO POINTED ISSUE
BUT IT'S A IT'S A STATE ISSUE
AND- I THINK BASED ON THE
ROBUSTNESS OF THE MEMBERS
ENGAGEMENT FROM THE SENATE
DELEGATION AND THE BILLS THAT
ARE BEING PRESENTED. THIS SHOULD
BE IMPORTANT TO ALL OF US AND
HEIGHTEN OUR ATTENTION TO THE
WHOLE THING- ONE OF THE- THINGS
THAT MY BILL DOES SUPPORT A
PROPOSED IS THAT. THE SECTION
ABOUT PREDATORS BE PLACED ON
STATE PROPERTY THAT'S THE
PURPOSE OF THE REPORTS FROM THE
VARIOUS AGENCIES. PRIOR
GOVERNORS HAVE ORDERED THOSE
PLACEMENTS THEY SEEM TO HAVE
WORKED IN THE PAST AND WE THINK
THAT THEY COULD WORK AGAIN AND
WITH THAT I WOULD ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU SENATOR JONES WE HAVE A
MOTION- BY SENATOR WIENER- AND-
TO MOVE THE BELL. AND THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED BUT FIRST RE
REFER. OR THE JONAS SORRY CENTER
MARKET I SO I'M WONDERING HOW.
YES THE WHOLE THING'S BEEN OUT
OF WORK SO IF. I FEEL LIKE LIFE
IS OUT OF ORDER- SO BUT THANK
YOU I'M- THE MOTION IS DUE PATH
- I SEE I SEE- BUT I FEEL LIKE.
YES SO- I FEEL LIKE I WAS ALSO
GOING TO ASK THE SAME QUESTION
THAT SENATOR WIENER ASK BECAUSE
MY CONFUSION WAS THAT- IF
SOMEONE IS. CURRENTLY PRESENTS A
CLEAR AND PRESENT DANGER THEN
THEY ARE NOT RELEASED- BUT THEN
ALSO YOUR AND THEN I JUST HER I
FEEL LIKE I JUST HEARD YOU SAY
THAT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
YOU'RE ALSO RECOMMENDING IS
ESSENTIALLY LIKE A STATE PENAL
COLONY FOR FOLKS TO BE ON. NOT
NEXT NON ARE NOT NECESSARILY
COLONY AT AND- BUT A PLACEMENT
ON STATE PROPERTY. WHERE THEY
CAN BE. DETERMINED THAT THAT'S A
SAFER PLACE FOR THEM TO BE
PLACED I'M NOT. POSING THAT WE
PUT THEM ALL IN THE SAME PLACE-
LIKE A CALLING KNOW THAT. THAT'S
NOT MY INTENT. OKAY THE OTHER
THING THAT I WHEN I WHEN READING
IT. IT SAYS THAT THE VIOLENT
PREDATORS HAVE. HISTORICALLY
BEEN DONE IT PLACE PLACE HAS
BEEN HISTORICALLY DONE IN SECRET
AND DECEPTIVE WAYS BY THE STATE
- AND SO I WAS SOMEWHAT
INTRIGUED. AND CONFUSED BY THAT
BECAUSE IT. SUGGESTS THAT THE
STATE IS INTENTIONALLY TRYING TO
PLACE PEOPLE- IN AREAS THAT
PRESENT A DANGER PROBABLY TO
THEM BUT ALSO TO NEIGHBORHOODS
WHERE THEY ARE RESIDING. AND
THERE WAS AN INTENTION OUT THERE
DID THERE'S A AND AN INFERRED
INTENTIONALITY TO THAT
STATEMENT. AND I DON'T FEEL LIKE
THAT IS. THE CASE ARM. AND I
DIDN'T KNOW IF MAYBE SOMEONE
COULD EXPLAIN WHY THAT. IN THERE
AND THE ASSUMPTION BEHIND THEM-
AND THEN ALSO BASED ON WHAT I
WAS READING IN THE ANALYSIS. THE
IT SEEMS TO ME AND MAYBE I'M
WRONG. BUT IF THIS IS ABOUT
COUNTIES. AND IF YOU HAVE A
BOARD THAT IS AGAINST PLACEMENTS
OR MIGHT BE AGAINST A PARTICULAR
PERSON THEY COULD CONCEIVABLY
DRAG THIS WHOLE PROCESS OUT IN
THE PEOPLE WOULD NEVER GET PLACE
. OR IS THAT NOT TRUE YEAH I CAN
I THINK I CAN ADDRESS BOTH
QUESTIONS OKAY WITH ONE
EXPLANATION I LITERALLY. WHEN
THE STATE TURNS THE RELEASE SEE
OVER TO THE CONTRACTOR. THE
STATE AT THAT POINT TIME
BRAUNTON SUPPORTS IT PURPOSES
QUITS PAYING ATTENTION TO WHAT'S
GOING ON SO THEY- WASH THEIR
HANDS OF THE SITUATION. THE
CONTRACTOR THEN GOES OUT AND
LEASES A HOME. AND THEN-
ANNOUNCES OR WHATEVER THAT
THEY'RE GONNA PLACE THIS
SEXUALLY VIOLENT PREDATOR IN
THIS PARTICULAR HOME AT THAT
POINT TIME THAT'S WIN THE COUNTY
. HERE'S ABOUT IT THAT'S WHEN
THEY COMMUNITY HEARS ABOUT IT
THAT'S WHEN THE NEIGHBORS HERE
ABOUT IT THAT'S WHEN YOU AND I
HEAR ABOUT IT FROM OUR
CONSTITUENTS THAT ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT IT AND OUR PHONES LIGHT
UP. AND OUR DISTRICT STAFF ARE
YOU KNOW TAKING THE TASK AT
EVERY EVENT THAT THEY GO TO AS
TO WHY THIS IS HAPPENING. AND
WHAT WE WANT TO CHANGE IS THAT
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THE BILL
PROPOSES TO DO TO FIX THAT IS
BEFORE THE CONTRACTOR CAN SIGN
THE LEASE. THE DIRECTOR OF STATE
HOSPITALS HAS TO APPROVE IT.
WHICH THAT IS NOT A STEP
CURRENTLY TODAY. IS THAT YOUR
CLOSING STATEMENT SENATOR JONES
I'M WELL. YES AND NO. I MEAN I'M
TRYING TO ANSWER LISTENER CALM
WATERS QUESTIONS YES. THE APOLLO
. FIVE CLOSE TWICE PREGUNTAS
MORE TIMES IF WE NEED TO. I WANT
TO YES QUESTIONS. THANK YOU FOR
THAT ANSWER THE QUESTION. YES
THEY DO IT DID IT OKAY AND AGAIN
I WILL THIS MY FINAL. CLOSING
STATEMENT IS IF IT FAILS TODAY
AND I'M ALLOWED RECONSIDERATION
I WOULD LOVE TO RE ENGAGE WITH
THE MEMBERS I AM FIND OUT. WHAT
ROBUST SOLUTION WE CAN COME UP
WITH TOGETHER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CENTERS JONES- COUNCIL WILL
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON SB
EIGHT FORTY ONE SB EIGHT FORTY
ONE DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CHAU BOGUE I TROUBLE GUY COME
LONGER. COM LONGER KNOWS SKINNER
WINNER WINNER NOW. ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE A ONE VOTE WE WILL PUT THAT
BILL AND CALL FOR MISSING
MEMBERS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR JONES. WE HAVE CENTER
BATES- PRESENTING S. B. THIRTEEN
THIRTY THREE. WELCOME SENATOR
BASE YOU MAY PRESENT S. B.
NUMBER. THIRTEEN THIRTY THREE
THIRTEEN THIRTY THREE WHICH IS
ANOTHER SEXUALLY VIOLENT
PREDATOR- PROBLEM PROPOSAL- SO
GOOD MORNING ARE MISSED HEARING
MEMBERS LA I'M CERTAINLY PLEASED
TO PRESENT SB THIRTEEN THIRTY
THREE WHICH THIS IS A BILL THAT
LOOKS TO PROVIDE MORE
TRANSPARENCY FAIRNESS AND SAFETY
TO THE RELEASE OF S. B. S.
SEXUALLY VIOLENT PREDATORS INTO
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE MOST AND
YOU'VE HEARD A BIT OF DISCUSSION
ABOUT SAN DIEGO CERTAINLY I
REPRESENT- THE NORTH COUNTY PART
OF SAN DIEGO AND MORE S. V. PEAS
ARE PENDING RELEASE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND THEY CURRENTLY
RESIDE THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
RELEASED RESIDE IN SAN DIEGO.
FINDING PLACEMENT FOR THEM HAS
BECOME INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT
AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS VOTED UNANIMOUSLY TO
OPPOSE FURTHER PLACEMENTS OF
THEM UNDER THE CURRENT PROCESS
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS
FOCUSING ON IS THE PROCESS THE
ACTION WAS IN RESPONSE TO
PLACEMENT OF TWO DIFFERENT S. V.
PEAS AND I BELIEVE THOSE WERE
THE ONES THAT SENATOR JOHNSON
SPEAKING OF IN RANCHO BERNARDO
AND MOUNT HELIX AND WE'RE
CONSTRUED CONSIDERED A THREAT TO
PUBLIC SAFETY. CERTAINLY
OUTCRIES FROM THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY SAN DIEGO COUNTY AWFUL
ALSO RECENTLY EXPERIENCED
ATTEMPTS TO PLACE S. V. PEAS
FROM OTHER ANOTHER JURISDICTION
WITHIN ITS JURISDICTION ENOUGH
ANOTHER POINT I IN TERMS OF
FAIRNESS TRANSPARENCY IN TERMS
OF ARE REVIEWING ALL WHERE THE
PLACEMENTS WILL BE MADE THE
JUDGES DENIED THOSE PLACEMENTS
AFTER IMMENSE PUBLIC OUT CREE
OUTCRY AND EFFORTS TO RELEASE.
S. V. PEAS WILL CONTINUE TO FACE
PUBLIC SCRUTINY UNLESS OF THE
CURRENT LAW IS REFORM THERE IS
CURRENTLY NO STATUTORY
REQUIREMENT IN THE WELFARE AND
INSTITUTIONS CODE FOR THE
RECORDS FROM SUPPORTING A
FINDING AND EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES WHICH IS THE
FINDING THAT IS MADE WHEN
SOMEONE WHO IS AN S. V. P. IS-
REFUSED TO A COUNTY DIFFERENT
FROM THE ONE IN WHICH- THEY WERE. SENTENCED IT SEEKS TO PROVIDE
I. AND VERY TO THE PLAY PRICE
BY. FULL DISK. WHEN A ACCOUNT
ATTEMPTS TO. AN S. B. P. INTO
ANOTHER COUNTY IT ALSO ALLOWS
THE COUNTY TO SEEK AN APPELLATE
COURT'S REVIEW IF THEY ARE
ORDERED TO FIND PLACEMENT. THAT
COMES FROM ANOTHER COUNTY. THAT
BEING SAID THE OPPOSITION DID
HAVE GREAT CONCERNS WITH
PROVISIONS IN THE BILL THAT
RESTRICTED WHERE IN SB PEAK
PLACE. FOLLOWING UP THEIR
RELEASE SO IN RESPONSE I'VE
INTRODUCED AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
THAT WOULD REMOVE ANY MENTION OF
GEOGRAPHICAL RESTRICTIONS UPON
THE RELEASE FOR. ODD AND THAT'S
INCLUDED IN THE BILL IT WILL
FOCUS SIMPLY BE ON ABILITY TO
PROVIDE PROPER TRANSPARENCY AND
NOTICE FOR SVB PLACEMENTS. THE
SAN DIEGO COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IS A SPONSOR
OF THIS MEASURE AND WE HAVE
CHIEF DEPUTY PATRICK ESPINOSA
WITH THE COUNTY'S DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE HE'S HERE. TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
AND HE IS A PRIMARY WITNESS.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES WILL NOT
MOVE ON TO OUR WITNESSES- IN
SUPPORT WITH THEIR LEAD AND WILL
BEGIN WITH THEIR LEAD. WITNESS
PAT ESPINOSA DISTRICT ATTORNEY.
GOOD MORNING TO THE CHAIR AND
LOOKED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE I'M PATRICK
ESPINOSA CHIEF DEPUTY APES
ANNUAL COUNTING ON BEHALF OF.
DISTRICT ATTORNEY SUMMER STEPHAN
MANY OF CALIFORNIA'S SIXTEEN
ESCAPEES WHO ON SUPERVISED
RELEASE FROM THE STATE HOSPITAL.
ARE PLACED CURRENTLY USING A
COUNTY MORE STPS ARE PENDING
RELEASE THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. FINDING PLACE FOR
ASKING S. B. S. BECAUSE- ONE
MORE DIFFICULT THE CONTRACT THIS
DEPARTMENT AT HOSPITALS IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR NOTIFYING THE
COUNTY OF DOMICILE WHERE THE S.
B. P. RESIDES PRIOR TO
INCARCERATION. ACCORDING TO THE
RELEASE PLACEMENT AND
CONTRACTING WITH LIBERTY TO
OVERSEE THEIR TREATMENT
RECENTLY. DECENNIAL COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS VOTED UNANIMOUSLY
TO OPPOSE ANY FURTHER PLACEMENTS
AFFECTED BY ACCREDITORS UNDER
THE CURRENT PROCESS THIS ACTION
WAS IN RESPONSE TO THE PLACEMENT
OF TWO DIFFERENT SB PEAS IN
RANCHO BERNARDO AD NOT HELIX.
WHICH WAS PERCEIVED AS A THREAT
TO PUBLIC SAFETY. SAN DIEGO
COUNTY ALSO RECENTLY EXPERIENCED
ATTEMPTS TO PLACE AN STP FROM
ANOTHER COUNTY ANOTHER
JURISDICTION WITHIN OUR COUNTY
SANTA COUNTY- JUDGES DENIED
PREVIOUS PLACEMENTS AFTER A
MATCH PUBLIC OUTCRY. AND THAT'S
ONE PROVISION OF THIS BILL SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY THREE AND THAT'S
THE PROVISION ABOUT
EXTRAORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCES AND
THE WAY THAT WORKS IS IF EIGHT.
FINDS EXTRAORDINARY EXTRA
CIRCUMVENT EXIST THAT COUNTY
DOES NOT HAVE TO PLACE YEAH SB
P. IN THEIR OWN COUNTY INSTEAD
THEY CAN REQUIRED THAT ACTUALLY
P. ET TO BE HONEST PROVIDES
RELEASED ANY OTHER COUNTY IN
ACTUALLY EIGHT AREA. WILL REPORT
AN EARLIER THE SBI. TWENTY THREE
THREE SIXTY. TO FIX IT OR NOT
WAY. BECAUSE ONE EIGHT. FINDS
WHICH YOU'RE LOOKING. SO THAT
THEY WILL PLACE YEAH TO BE IN
THEIR OWN- THE COUNTY ULTIMATELY
ASKED BY THAT ACTUALLY BE GIVEN
AFTER TABLE NOT IN THE- IT'S NOT
HARD TO. THAT TO SEE IS MADE. SB
THREE THIRTY WHICH TO FIX THAT.
SO THAT THOSE RECORDS- THE
EVIDENCE THAT. THE JUDGES. THAT
EXPORTER CERTAIN. WOULD BE
PREVENTED PRESENTED TO AND CLOSE
TO THE COUNTY THIS ASPECT
ACTUALLY P. SHORTEN. TIME AFTER
. DECISIONS WERE MADE AND THE
SECOND HALF IT WOULD GIVE THAT.
THAT COUNTY THAT TO FIND OUT FOR
THAT BE A BILL TO GO TO THEIR
COURT EVICTING IT'S A PRO. FIFTY
THREE THAT DOES THAT THAT FIND-
EXTRA SIX. WHAT DO.
ALL PLACES IN THAT COUNTY TO
FIND A PLACEMENT FOR ACTUALLY
DECOMMITTED FROM THEIR
JURISDICTIONS SO THAT'S ONE AREA
OF PERFORMANCE IN SB THIRTEEN
THIRTY THREE. ANOTHER EARLY A
PERFORM IS THE CONCEPT OF WHAT
YOU DO WITH A NASTY P. WHO'S
PLACE TO SUPERVISE BUT IT'S
INSTALLING THE TERMS AND
CONDITIONS. ORDERED BE GRANTED
AND PLACED. ON S. B. I WAS
RELEASED YES THE PEOPLE TO AGREE
TO TURN YOU CAN WITH THE OFFENSE
STAYED HOT AND LET ME HEALTHCARE
PROVIDE THOSE TERMS CONDITIONS.
OFTEN THE PROSECUTOR IT HAS NO
ACCESS TO INFORMATION TO HOW
THEY ARE PERFORMING ON WITH
RESPECT TO THE TERMS AND
CONDITIONS BECAUSE ALL THE
PEOPLE IN A POSITION TO MONITOR
THEM IT IS LIBERTY HEALTH CARE
FOR STATE HOSPITALS BUT IN THOSE
INSTANCES. WHERE STATE HOSPITAL
DELIVERY HEALTH KERR SAID
THERE'S A PROBLEM WITH THIS S.
C. P. HE OR SHE WORKS WITH YOU
MOST OF OUR MALES- IF THEY'RE
NOT ON THE TERMS CONDITIONS.
STATE HOSPITALS- LIBERTY CAN ASK
THE LOCAL PROSECUTOR VIOLATE
THIS OFFENDER TAKE AWAY THEIR
TRADITIONAL BELIEFS BECAUSE THEY
NEED TO BE BACK IN STATE
HOSPITAL FOR THEIR OWN TREATMENT
AND FOR THE SAFETY OF THE
COMMUNITY WHEN THAT IS DONE THEN
THE S. B. B. HAD BILITY TO HIDE
BEHIND. THE PROTECTION OF
CONFIDENTIAL CONFIDENTIALITY OF
MEDICAL RECORDS AND PREVENT
THOSE RECORDS WERE BEING
PROVIDED TO THE PROSECUTOR WHO'S
ASKED TO BRING. EIGHT WHEN
REGULATION COURT TO REVOKE THE-
THEIR- BASEMENT STATUS AND
THAT'S VERY GOOD PROCESS WITH
THIS LOSS IS BEING TO SIX TO
DEAL WITH THIS BILL SEEKS TO DO
IS BRING SENSE OF THAT PROCESS
SO AND IN WE- THIS. EVERY PERSON
PROVIDING STP THE END OF
ENTITIES LIKE THE ACTUAL R.
LIBERTY HEALTH CARE RECOGNIZE A
RED. AND THEY BELIEVE TO BE WITH
VOTE THAT THERE IS NO IMPEDIMENT
AND THE LOSS OF THE BACON FROM
THOSERECORDS MADE TREATMENT
WHATEVER WRECKED YOU SHOULD THE
RATHER. THIS IS A FINING IT
VIOLATES IN TERMS CONDITIONS.
YOUR CONTENT DON'T AND BRING
THAT INTO TO THE CATCHER THE
COURT THEY CAN ABOUT THE SERIES
OF THE VIA JUDGE CONFIRMING IT
DOESN'T MERIT WE'RE LOOKING TO
STAY OR NOT TO BE TO THE TYPE OF
ROOM THAT THERE ARE NO THAT WE
THREE TO ARTS. AND WE THINK GOT. MAKE GOOD COM SENSE BILL WAS
OFF THE- WE- THAT WE READ. THE
BILL A CONCERN. THAT YOU WILL
VERSION OF. SIX IN PUBLIC
LIMITATION ON I'M AT IF YOU
COULD BE QUITE. THAT WAS LEARN
TO WHICH- WILL HAD. BOTH THE
OUTCRY WHEN COMMUNITY CAN. POST
OBJECTIONS WE LIVE TO THE
COMMUNITY WHICH TO. PUT SOME OF
RESTRICTIONS AND BILLS WE GET.
ELIMINATE THOSE. THAT WORKED OF
SUCCESS BECAUSE OF THE- BAKER
KNOWS OF THE- PLACE LIKE
LOCATIONS WE HAVE. DAYCARE
SCHOOL BUS STOPS CARE BUT THE
PRESIDENT ALSOTALK TO YOU WE
WILL BACK TO THAT THOSE WHICH-
ARE NO. IN THE BILL. AND YOU
KNOW WE ARE STILL OPEN TO
DISCUSS SUPPOSED TO TIME TO
ADDRESS AND CONCERNS ABOUT THE
LATE IN PLACE NOW- CERTAINLY DO
NOT WANT TO. BILL OR CHANGE LOT
OF WILL BE. EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT BY
WHICH- AND CAN DRAG THEIR FEET
SO PERFECT PLACE WE WERE. YOU
SUMMONED WHO GOT THROUGH THE
TREATMENT WHO DESERVE TO BE
RELEASED TO THE COURT DETERMINE
OUR ELIGIBLE. SPOKESMAN CAPT
FOUND AND SO WE HAVE TO ALLOW
OPPORTUNITY FOR INTEGRATION
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY FOR THE
REASONS ARE WE WOULD ASK SUPPORT
FOR S. THIRTEEN THREE THANK YOU
. THANK U. S. HAS BEEN A FOR
YOUR TODAY.
HI GOOD MORNING TO SHOW MUCH- ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. WHERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. THIRTEEN THIRTY THREE. SEEING
NONE. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WILLING TO TESTIFY VIA
THE TELECONFERENCE OR VERSUS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
THIRTEEN THIRTY THREE WILL BEGIN
. THANK YOU MA'AM CARE IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
COOL WATER LINE SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CAN
PHONE STONE ADVOCACY ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL LINES IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THERE ARE NO FURTHER LINES
IN SUPPORT PLEASE CONTINUE MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU MATTER
MODERATOR HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
THE SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE FROM
ANY OPPOSITION AND WE DO HAVE
ONE- ONE LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS
SOLOMON CHIANG. ARE YOU ON THE
LINE MISTER CHANG. YES I AM CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES ABSOLUTELY
PLEASE PROCEED SIR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THIRTEEN THIRTY THREE
WHILE WELL INTENDED WILL OPEN
CAUSE MORE HARM THAN GOOD BY
CREATING A CHILLING EFFECT ON
TREATMENT PROCESS AND MAKING THE
ALREADY ARGUE WITH PROCESS THE
COMMUNITY EVEN MORE GET. MY NAME
IS FALLING CHIANG AND I HERE ON
BEHALF OF HEALTH PUBLIC DEFENDER
OF SO. IN AT THIRTEEN THIRTY
THREE. I AM THE SUPERVISING AT
THE SAME DIEGO DEFENDERS
COMMITMENT. IN MY ROLE I ALL. OF
FEET HEARING FROM INITIAL
COMMITMENT PETITION. PETITION
FOR KIND. AND UNDER RELEASE. I
BEFORE YOU TODAY AN OPPOSITE OF
THIS BILL PAGE NOT ONLY ON MY
REAL WORLD EXPERIENCE AND
HANDLING THESE CASES. ALSO
THROUGH MY DISCUSSIONS WITH
TREATMENT PROVIDERS THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY. HE THIRTEEN THIRTY
THREE'S RECORD SHARING
PROVISIONS RUN AFOUL OF PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS AND WOULDN'T DANGER
THE SAFETY HE AND MEDICAL
PROGRESS CONDITIONALLY RELEASED
PATIENTS. DIFFICULT THIS BILL
WOULD- AT THE STATE AREAS OF
THIS. THAT WOULD RUN AFOUL OF.
AND FOR THERAPIST PATIENT
PRIVILEGE. FIRST IT WOULD
PROVIDE- IT WOULD REQUIRE A
PROVISION OF THE PATIENT'S
TREATMENT RECORDS TO PARTY THEN
QUOTED THE DESIGNATED COUNTY A
PLACEMENT IN QUOTE BEFORE OUT OF
DOMICILE PLACE MAKING GRANTED.
AND SOCKET THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE DISCLOSURE OF
CONFIDENTIALLY PROTECTED
MATERIAL TO THE COUNTY OF
PLACEMENT OF CONGRESS CORRECT
MIGHT BE AT AGE CORRECT OF
OUTPACE TREATMENT. BOTH OF THE
INFORMATION JEFF THE COMP. OF
THE PAST ACT BY NOT ONLY. THE
PER PSYCHOTHERAPY PATIENT
PRIVILEGE BUT MORE AND- THREE H.
IF ON. WHICH IN TURN CREATING
GREATER. TOWARDS SYSTEM AND
AFFECTED TREATMENT TOO SO WE
COMMITTED PATIENTS. THE MORE
DIFFICULT. MADE IT TO BRIDGE THE
FACT THAT TREATMENT THE MORAL.
AT ACT BECAUSE- SHIFTING THE
FROM TRIPLE FOCUS TO PUNITIVE
AND NATURE AND NOT IN. THE CON
FRAMEWORK OF THE F. T. P. SO HOW
DID THAT LET ME ASK. CONDITIONAL
RELEASE KERR OUT IN THE CRIMINAL
HAS BEEN CA. AND AFTER. IF NOT
LITERAL DECADE OF TREATMENT
COLEGAS THE HOT. SIX TREATMENT
OR PATIENCE SOLVE RIDDLE OF THEY
AFFECT THE TO BEGIN WITH. AND
FADLI THE ANSWER ANSWER TO SUCH
FOR. A PIECE TO TERMS WITH THEIR
BIG. WE THEY WERE MINORS. IT
REQUIRES THEM TO DISCLOSE THE
DEEP MOST FROM OUT AND HER
PORTION OF THE PERSON I THINK.
EVEN THOUGHT. ALL THROUGH H.
THERAPEUTIC ROCESS. DO THESE
PATIENTS STILL CALL ME UNCLE
DURING THOSE LOANS TO WORK ON
THEMSELVES. INTO A SHORT ARE NOT
READ. AND MOST OF. TO ENSURE THE
THERE ARE NO NEW. PRACTICAL
EXAMPLES OF THE DANGERS OF FAITH
TO ME THE CYCLE PATIENT PRO.
WITHIN THE CAR OF THE CONDITION
RELEASE ME AND PUT RABBIT
BECAUSE. NOW IMAGINE PERSONS
RELEASED A THE COMMUNITY UNDER-
AND THERE THERE ARE IN THE CAN.
NOW I SOME POINT PERHAPS THEY
BEGIN TO STRUGGLE WITH I JUST
WANT TO GIVE A ONE ONE JUST SAY
THAT YOU'RE PART AND IN CLOSE.
THANK YOU. IMAGINE IS THE FIRST
IS SHORT. WITH THEM IN A- BY
THIS PERSON GO TO THEIRS THEIR
LIKE WE WANT THEM TO DO. THE
DISCLOSURE BEACON IN TO FIND
WORK THE ISSUE. THAT THEIR PETS
MIGHT HELP. HIM OR HER. AND THEN
GO TO- GO TO LIBERTY HEALTH CARE
AND TO LOOK AND FOR YOU KNOW
WHAT I THINK THE PERSON THE TO
MORE. AT THE HOSPITAL THAT IS
THE THING. WE WANT TO CALL
DISCLOSING THAT.
THIS IS THE REASON LIBERTY
HAVING 0% RECIDIVISM RATE
BECAUSE THIS SYSTEM WORKS. I'M
IMPLORING THIS BODY TO USE LOGIC
AND REASON THIS IS NOT A PROCESS
THAT IS HEADED AND SECRECY. THIS
IS NOT A PROCESS IN WHICH THE
STATE WASHES THEIR HANDS. QUITE
LITERALLY EVERY SINGLE MONTH.
THE EIGHT. LIBERTY HEALTH CARE
THE DA'S OFFICE THEY SHOULD BE-
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE AND LIBERTY
HEALTH CARE. CALLIGRAPHER AND
THE THERAPIST LITERALLY MEET
EVERY SINGLE MONTH TO TALK ABOUT
HOW THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE DOING.
THIS IS NOT. A HIDDEN. AND FOR
THOSE THREE THAT MUCH I FLOORED
THIS BODY. TO DON'T LEAVE ME.
THIS MORNING THANK YOU VERY MR
CHIU FOR YEAR TWO THIS MORE WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO IN WITNESSES
IN TWENTY HIGH IN OPPOSITION TO
S. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY THREE DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES. SEEN
UNDER NOW WE'RE- WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
ARVEST. A MODERATE HE WOULD
PLEASE FROM THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF S. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY THREE
AND WE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT. NINE
SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AMYLIN WONDER ON BEHALF OF THE
ON WOMEN'S FREEDOM CENTER AND
SISTER WARRIORS FREEDOM
COALITION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. IF ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN THIRTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. OKAY JUST A MOMENT
FOR OUR NEXT CALLER. THANK
YOU SO FOLKS NAME WHERE YOU'RE
FROM AND YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILL NEXT. ONE FIFTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS
BY FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS KIMBERLY FOSTER
AND I'M IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO FURTHER LINES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE CONTINUE
READING CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM MODERATOR AND THANK
YOU TO ALL OUR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION JUSTICE WILL NOT
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO OUR
MEMBERS DO ANY OF OUR MEMBERS TO
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS WITH
REGARD TO S. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY
THREE. YEAH YOU KNOW I HAD I HAD
A QUESTION THIS IS THE THIRD
BILL ON THIS AND YOU KNOW WHEN I
GOT THAT. AND NOW IT SAYS THE
OTHER DAY. I THOUGHT WELL
THERE'S A LOT GOING ON IN SAN
DIEGO. BUT WAS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION TO CONSOLIDATE THE
BILLS OR TO KIND OF. BECAUSE IT
SEEMS LIKE THERE'S A COMPACTED.
AND YET PROTRACTED ISSUE GOING
ON. IN THIS PARTICULAR REGION
BUT WHERE THEIR WORK WAS SO.
BECAUSE THAT IS THE GOAL HAVE TO
ASK OUR CONSULTANT- ERIC WOULD
YOU LIKE TO RESPOND TO THAT WE-
WE ANALYZE THREE BILLS ON IN
PUBLIC SAFETY ON THE S. AND P.
AND THE QUESTION IS WAS THERE A
THOUGHT. ABOUT CONSOLIDATING
BILLS. AND THAT WAS NOT PROVIDED
TO ME BECAUSE MINE TAKES A
DIFFERENT TACT OF SPECIFICALLY I
KNOW I GET THAT AND I NOTICED
THAT EACH OF THE KIND OF HAVE A
DIFFERENT. PATH AND YET I FEEL
LIKE EVERYONE IS TALKING ABOUT-
AND HOW TO ADDRESS THE SAME
ISSUE WHICH IS HOW DO YOU. YOU
KNOW LEGALLY CONSTITUTIONALLY
MANAGE THE PLACEMENT OF S. V.
PEAS BACK INTO A COMMUNITY- IN A
WAY THAT IS TRANSPARENT IN A WAY
THAT IS LAWFUL IN A WAY THAT
PROTECTS COMMUNITIES AND IN A
WAY THAT IS- PLAN. RECOGNIZING
THAT THERE ARE ETHICAL
CONSTITUTIONAL AND LEGAL
CONCERNS RECOGNIZING THAT THERE
ARE FIXES THAT NEED TO BE MADE
BUT IT ALSO SEEMS. JUST ARM I
WAS JUST CURIOUS BECAUSE OFTEN
TIMES. WE DON'T HAVE- THESE
KINDS OF BILLS COME BEFORE A
PUBLIC SAFETY AND THEN TO HAVE
THREE OF THEM FROM AUTHORED BY
FOLKS IN THE SAME GENERAL AREA
IT JUST STRUCK ME AS IF THERE
WAS A WAY TO SORT OF. CONJOIN OR
YOU KNOW JUST SORT OF CREATE
SOMETHING THAT'S MORE HOLISTIC.
OR AT LEAST JUST ADDRESSES IT SO
THAT WAS MY OWN MY OWN QUESTION
YOU KNOW I APPRECIATE THAT
SENATOR CALL LOGGER AND I
WOULDN'T DISAGREE I THINK YOU
HAVE TO LOOK AT WHAT THE FOCUS
OF EACH BILL IS AND I'M A LITTLE
ODD. UNINFORMED I DIDN'T I
WASN'T ABLE TO WATCH THE
DISCUSSION ON NOW SENATOR- PRO
TEM'S BILL THIS MORNING BUT HERS
AS I UNDERSTAND IT IT ADDS THE
DA TWO ONE OF THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT CAN BE AT THE TABLE LONGER
DISCUSSING PLACEMENT WHAT I'D
LIKE TO FOCUS ON WITH MY BILL
WE'RE NOT CHANGING THE LAW AS IT
CURRENTLY STANDS AND WHERE THEY
MIGHT BE PLAY STARS OF FOCUSING
ON. OF THE ABILITY TO PLACE AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO WAS CONVICTED IN
ONE COUNTY AND HAVE SERVED THEIR
TIME BOB SUPPOSEDLY ARE NO
LONGER A THREAT TO PUBLIC SAFETY
YET THEY'RE NOT PLACE BACK IN
THAT COUNTY WHICH IS PART OF A
CURRENTLY PART OF THE PROCESS SO
WHY IS THAT IS BECAUSE QUOTE
UNQUOTE THERE'S EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES MY BILL IS ASKING
FOR A DISCUSSION OF OUT. NOW I
KNOW THE PUBLIC DEFENDERS ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT PRIVACY BUT I
CONSIDER EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES TO BE SOMETHING
ABOUT WHATEVER HAPPENED IN THAT
OTHER COUNTY NOT WHAT'S
HAPPENING NOW IS THAT INDIVIDUAL
WHO MIGHT BE STRUGGLING WITH
CONCERNS BY HAVING YOU KNOW
IMPROPER THOUGHTS ARE IT IS
ABOUT WHETHER THEY WERE-
RECOMMITTED FROM THAT OTHER
COUNTY THEY CAME IN. CONTACT
WITH YOU KNOW THERE'S THEIR PEER
GROUP AGAIN WHATEVER THOSE ARE
NOT THINGS THAT GO TO THE HEART
OF THAT DISCUSSION BETWEEN A
PSYCHOTHERAPIST IN THE
INDIVIDUAL SO I DO BELIEVE IT'S
LEGITIMATE TO PROVIDE TO A
COUNTY IN A PRIVACY SETTING THE
JUDGE AND THE PROSECUTOR AND THE
DEFENSE ATTORNEY ON WHAT WERE
THE EXTRAORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCES
OTHER DOWN THE BEHAVIORAL
MODIFICATION ISSUES WITH THE
INDIVIDUAL SO IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT THIS PARTICULAR COMPONENT
OF MY BILL. SHOULD BE INCLUDED
RECEIVING COUNTY BECAUSE WHEN
YOU HAVE ONE COUNTY SAN DIEGO
THAT CURRENTLY HAS SIXTEEN OF
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN RELEASED
PACIFIC LEE IN THEIR COUNTY.
THEY HAVE A REASON TO SAY HEY
WAIT A MINUTE OUR WHY AREN'T WE
HAVING OFF. TO WHY THEY WERE
COMMITTED OUT ORANGE COUNTY
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SAN MATTEO AND
NOW THEY'RE BEING PLACED IN SAN
DIEGO WHICH MIGHT BE QUITE A
DISTANCE FROM THEIR ORIGINAL
DOMICILE. THAT'S THAT'S A SIMPLE
QUESTION. THAT COULD BE PROVIDED
PRIVACY CLEARLY IN THE
DISCUSSION AS THE PERSON IS
BEING PLACED NOW WHEN THEY GET
TO THAT PARTICULAR HOME. AND THE
THINGS THAT HAPPEN IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT WELL THOSE
ARE. THOSE ARE THE RIGHT OF THE
PUBLIC- TO RESIST IN HAVE. THEIR
THEIR DAY IN THE IN THE PUBLIC
ARENA IT DOESN'T MEAN AUDIT YET
TARA IS GRANTED DOWN BUT
CERTAINLY A DISCUSSION ABOUT
BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T HAVE THIS
INFORMATION. VERY DIFFICULT TO
SENATOR WIENER. TO TALK TO
PEOPLE WITH PITCHFORKS IF YOU
PUT THIS PERSON IN MY COMMUNITY.
AND HE DID A VERY GOOD
DESCRIPTION OF WHAT HAPPENED TO
HIM WHEN HE WAS A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL. SO WE NEED
THAT INFORMATION WHEN WE ARE
THERE. ON THE DÍAS TRYING TO
EXPLAIN WHY YOU KNOW. ALL WE
WENT THROUGH ALL THE PROCESS
FOUND OUT WHY THEY HAD TO COME
TO SAN DIEGO OR ORANGE COUNTY
INSTEAD OF RIVERSIDE. AND I
THINK THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT
PEOPLE NEED TO HEAR AND I DON'T
SEE THAT THAT'S A VIOLATION. OF
PRIVACY OF THIS PARTICULAR
INDIVIDUAL NOT GOING INTO. YOU
KNOW THE THAT HE STILL FEELS
THAT HE NEEDS TO DO X. Y. NZ
THAT SAW CERTAINLY- YOU KNOW
CRIME AGAINST SOMEONE ELSE.
THOSE ARE MY- HE WITHOUT MY
CLOTHES SO I ASKED. FOR YOU TO
CONSIDER THAT. AND MAYBE LET
THIS ONE GO FORWARD WE CERTAINLY
CAN CONTINUE TO WORK. WITH THE
OPPOSITION WE DID A LOT OF WORK
WE REMOVED ALL OF THE OLD. THE
GEOGRAPHICAL RESTRICTIONS WERE
TALKING ABOUT TAKING THE TIME
LIMITS OUT MAYBE THOSE NEED TO
BE THE SAME WITH EXTENDED IT WE
DOUBLE THAT ACTUALLY. BUT THOSE
ARE THINGS THAT CAN CERTAINLY BE
DONE IN A FASTER- SETTING-
THAT'S DICTATED BY THE JUDGE IN
THE COURTS. ALL WITH PUBLIC
DEFENDER PROSECUTOR AND THE
JUDGE TALKING ABOUT THIS. BUT TO
ME IT IT STARS. IT'S JUST
ANOTHER STEP SENATOR PRO TEM'S
BILL WAS A GOOD STEP FORWARD
INCLUDING THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY.
I DO BELIEVE THE EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES IF THEY ARE
SITUATIONAL. ARE SHOULD BE
DISCUSSED AND I WOULD LIKE. OF
THAT PART OF THE BILL- TO BE.
HONORED TODAY AND THEN WE ARE
CERTAINLY COMMITTED. CLEARLY
OUGHT TO DO MORE WORK ON IT. IN
MAYBE CONSOLIDATE AS IT GOES
FORWARD. WITH THE OTHER BILL.
BUT IF IT DOEN'T STAND. TODAY
WE DON'T HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
DO THAT. IT IS THERE A I NOTICED
DOES RIGHTS. HAD A LETTER AND
THEY'RE LISTED AND SO CAN YOU
SPEAK TO WHY THEY ARE IN SUPPORT
IS THERE AN IMPACT ON FOLKS
WITH- DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
OR PHYSICAL DISABILITIES. ARMS
FOR WELL I THINK BECAUSE WE
ORIGINALLY HAD A CONGREGATE CARE
FOR. THE ON THOSE OF. GILTS
INCOME. FOR WHICH WE DID REMOVE
FILES THE SENATE TO THE REQUEST
FOR THAT. WHAT ALL OF THE BILL
HURT THREE WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR JOE BURKE APOLOGIES THAT
I WASN'T ABLE TO HEAR THE- HAD
TO PRESENT IN ANOTHER COMMITTEE
SO I DIDN'T NECESSARILY HERE-
EITHER THE VARIOUS TESTIMONY OF
THE DIFFERENT DIALOGUE BUT- I-
FROM MY FOR ME THIS HAS A NUMBER
OF PROBLEMATIC- A PROVISIONS AND
SINCE THERE WERE NOT- AND THEN
THE- THIRD SEEDED. IN ADVANCE.
WITH THE COMMITTEE I'M NOT
COMFORTABLE SUPPORTING THE BILL
IN ITS CURRENT FORM AND- YOU
KNOW I'VE ONLY LEARNED THAT I
WOULD BE CHAIRING THE COMMITTEE
HEARD VERY RECENTLY SO IT'S NOT
LIKE I WAS IN A POSITION TO BE
ABLE TO INITIATE A SUCH ON
NEGOTIATIONS SO. ON I WILL NOT
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY- WE
DO HAVE A MOTION AND- YOU MAY
CLOSE CENTER BATES MAJORITY
APOLOGIES. WELL I KIND OF WENT
OVER MY CLOTHES ARE THAT AB WHAT
I WOULD ASK IS IF YOU WOULDN'T
TAKE A VOTE TODAY I HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY LITTLE MORE
DISCUSSION ON WHAT SENATOR COM
LONGER HAS. DISCUSSED AND MAYBE
WE CAN HAVE. A RESOLUTION IN ONE
BILL BUT IN PARTICULAR TO
ADDRESS I THINK THIS
EXTRAORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCES
CERTAINLY GOES A LONG WAY AND IN
RELIEVING A COUNTY IS CONCERNED
WHICH IS WHY. THIS BILL AND THE
OTHER TWO ARE ARE BEFORE YOU
FROM THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO I
THINK THERE'S A CRY HUE AND CRY
THERE THAT SHOULD AT LEAST BE
RECOGNIZE AND SEE IF WE CAN WORK
THROUGH IT- APPRECIATE. THAT
CLOSE AND OBVIOUSLY WE DID- ACT
ON ONE BILL IN THIS REGARD THAT-
FROM A SAN DIEGO REPRESENTATIVE-
THAT- APPEARS. TO BE IN GOOD
SHAPE FOR PASSAGE FIVE- BUT WHAT
I THINK IS THE APPROPRIATE THING
TO DO IS TO VOTE ON THE BILL NOW
. BECAUSE THEY CAN'T SPEAK FOR
OUR CHAIR BUT THEN WE COULD YOU
COULD REQUEST RECONSIDERATION
WICKED GRANT RECONSIDERATION
SUCH DISCUSSIONS COULD BE
INITIATED WITH THE CHAIR. ALL
RIGHT WITH THAT- LET'S- THE
MOTION WOULD BE DO PASSAGE AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND- I
GUESS THOSE ARE THE MOMENTS THAT
YOU HAD AGREED TO TAKE. YEAH
RIGHT RIGHT AND- AS ODD TO
APPROACH SO- WITHOUT WILL HAVE A
ROLL CALL SB THIRTEEN THIRTY
THREE DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER. NOT
VOTING SKINNER NOT VOTING-
PHOTOBOOK I TROUBLE GUY COM
AUGER. KAMLAGER NOT VOTING.
RIGHT WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL FOR
A THE COMMITTEE MEMBER BUT IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST NOW
RECONSIDERING RECONSIDERATION.
YEAH AFTER THAT. ALL RIGHT. SO
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO- REVENUE A
SECOND WOULD BE NINE TWENTY FIVE
CORRECT. WELL I'D LIKE TO SAY
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT SB NINE TWENTY FIVE-
WHICH IS ANA. WHICH WILL HELP
LAW ENFORCEMENT UNDERSTAND AND
QUANTIFY THE CAUSES BEHIND FATAL
COLLISIONS ON AVERAGECALIFORNIA
EXPERIENCES NEARLY THREE
THOUSAND DEATHS ANNUALLY DUE TO
CAR ACCIDENTS UNFORTUNATELY MANY
OF THE DRIVERS INVOLVED IN THESE
ACCIDENTS ARE DRIVING IMPAIRED.
DUE TO ALCOHOL AND OR DRUG
CONSUMPTION FOR INSTANCE IN
202154% OF FATALLY INJURED
DRIVERS IN ORANGE COUNTY HAD AT
LEAST ONE SUBSTANCE DRUGS AND-
AND OR ALCOHOL IN THEIR SYSTEM.
CURRENTLY LOCAL CORONERS AND
MEDICAL EXAMINERS ARE REQUIRED
TO TEST DECEASED DRIVERS AND
PASSENGERS FOR ALCOHOL CONTENT
BUT NOT FOR DRUG CONTENT WITH
THE LEGALIZATION OF RECREATIONAL
MARIJUANA THEN THE RISE OF
OPIOID ABUSE MANY NEW DRIVING
UNDER THE INFLUENCE CASES ARE
DUE TO DRUG USE NOT JUST
ALCOHOL. FOR INSTANCE FROM
AUGUST FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO
JULY THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
ONE IMPAIRING DRUGS WERE
DETECTED IN 41% OF SAMPLES
ANALYZED WITH THE ORANGE COUNTY
CRIME LAB WHERE THE BLOOD
ALCOHOL CONTENT WAS. POINT 008%
OR GREATER SOME LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS LIKE ORANGE AND SAN
FRANCISCO COUNTIES HAVE
VOLUNTARILY BEGUN TESTING FOR
DRUG CONTENT AFTER A FATAL
COLLISIONS HOWEVER MANY OF THESE
CASES ARE GOING UNDETECTED
STATEWIDE BECAUSE THERE IS NO
REQUIREMENT TO TEST FOR A
DRIVER'S OF DRUG CONTENT AFTER A
FATAL COLLISION. WE HAVE THE
LEGISLATURE NEED ACCURATE DATA
ON THE CAUSES OF FATAL
COLLISIONS ACROSS THE STATE SO
WE CAN MAKE SOUND EVIDENCE BASED
POLICIES SB NINE TWENTY FIVE
WILL UPDATE CURRENT LAW TO
REQUIRE DRUG TESTING AFTER FATAL
COLLISIONS. IN ADDITION TO
ALCOHOL TESTING REFLECTING
ACCURATELY THE MODERN USE OF
PRESCRIPTION AND RECREATIONAL
DRUGS ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL
WILL REQUIRE TESTING IN CASES OF
DEATHS THAT OCCUR WITHIN FORTY
EIGHT HOURS OF THE COLLISION
INSTEAD OF JUST TWENTY FOUR
HOURS. CAPTURING SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE DATA ON FATAL COLLISIONS
THE BILL IS THE REINTRODUCTION
OF SB TWO EIGHTY THREE FROM
TWENTY NINETEEN WHICH DID PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND ON. TO THE SENATE
FLOOR THE BILL WAS LATER HELD IN
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY DUE TO
CONCERNS FROM THE OPPOSITION.
BUT THOSE CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSED AND THAT OPPOSITION
HAS MOVED RECOMMENDATION IN THIS
BILL ARE DIRECTLY REFERENCED IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE. FROM THE
CALIFORNIA IMPAIRED DRIVING TASK
FORCE COMMISSION FROM THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SB NINETY FOR A
DOCUMENT THAT WAS DERIVED FROM
DIVERSE COLLABORATION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TO GIVE OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT EVERY TOOL POSSIBLE
TO UNDERSTAND AND PREVENT FUTURE
FATAL COLLISIONS. BY WITNESS
WILL BE ORANGE COUNTY SHERIFF
DON BARNES AND I ALSO HAVE
JENNIFER HARMAN THE CRIME
LABORATORY DIRECTOR AT THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT REGIONAL CRIME
LABORATORY. AVAILABLE TO HELP
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU LET'S START WITH OUR-
LEAD WITNESS THEN- I'M NOT SURE
IF THEY'RE BOTH ON THE PHONE OR
IN THE ROOM. I THNK THEY'RE ON
THE PHONE SO MODERATOR GO AHEAD. THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SB NINE TO FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. IT'S NOT OPPOSITION
NOIT IS SUPPORT AND IT IS THE
LEAD WITNESS SUPPORT FOR NINE TO
FIVE. THANK YOU. THIS IS A SURE
FARMS HERE ME YES WE CAN'T.
THANK YOU CHAIR SKINNER AND
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
TWENTY FIVE AND ALSO WANT TO
THANK CENTER PAGE FOR OFFERING
THIS. LEGISLATION ONCE AGAIN.
EACH YEAR THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS DIED AS THE RESULT
OF AUTOMOBILE COLLISIONS.
UNFORTUNATELY MANY OF THE
DRIVERS INVOLVED IN EXPLOSIONS
ARE DRIVING IMPAIRED ALCOHOL AND
OR DRUG CONSUMPTION. IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE IS
REFERENCED BY SENATOR BATES
FIFTY FOUR POINT 5% OF FATAL.
INJURED FATALLY INJURED DRIVERS
IN ORANGE COUNTY AT LEAST ONE
SUBSTANCE DRUGS AND OR ALCOHOL
IN THEIR SYSTEM SURPRISINGLY
IT'S REFERENCED FOUR IN TEN. OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH WITH A BLOOD
ALCOHOL ALCOHOL CONCENTRATION OF
POINT 008% THAT THE PER SE LIMIT
WHERE YOU CANNOT SAFELY OPERATE
A MOTOR VEHICLE. HAD IN ADDITION
TO THAT ALCOHOL CONCENTRATION
ANOTHER SUBSTANCE SUCH AS
MARIJUANA AND OR DRUGS. AS
MENTIONED LOCAL GOVERNMENTS LIKE
ORANGE COUNTY AND SAN FRANCISCO
VOLUNTARILY BEGUN TESTING PER
DRUG CONTENT AFTER FATAL
COLLISIONS. HOWEVER MANY OF
THESE CASES ARE GOING UNDETECTED
STATEWIDE BECAUSE THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT TO TEST FOR DRIVERS
DRUG CONTENT AFTER A FATAL
COLLISION AND WITH THIS BECOMES
PROBLEMATIC FOR US- TRYING TO
LEAD. IN GOOD LEGISLATION TO
IDENTIFY PROBLEMS AND BRING
ABOUT SOLUTIONS IS IN PREVIOUS
FORMS OF THIS LEGISLATION-
ORANGE COUNTY WAS SEEN AS AN OUT
LIAR STATEWIDE COMPARED TO OTHER
COUNTIES. WHERE IN FACT WE WERE
TESTING FOR EVERY SUBSTANCE AND
WAS GETTING MORE ACCURATE DATA
BRING IT BACK TO- THE-
LEGISLATURE FOR CONSIDERATION IN
THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES WE HAVE
THERE'S DIFFERENT WAYS COUNTING
REPORTING THE DATA ACCURATE DATA
ON THE CAUSE OF THE FATAL
COLLISIONS ACROSS THE STATE
WITHOUT THAT INFORMATION
LEGISLATURE CANNOT IMPLEMENT
SOUND EVIDENCE BASED POLICIES TO
DROP THE PRIMARY CAUSES OF THESE
COLLISIONS. THIS PROBLEM WAS
RECENTLY HIGHLIGHTED IN A MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO REPORT BY THE
NATIONAL HIGHWAY TRAFFIC AND
SAFETY ADMINISTRATION KNOWN BY
THE ACRONYM AND THAT'S ON. THE
REPORT NOTES FIFTY QUOTE
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES MAKE THEIR OWN
DECISIONS ABOUT DRUG TESTING
WITH PENALTIES IN DRUG PANELS
DIFFERENT ACROSS EACH COUNTY END
QUOTE. MISTER HIGHLIGHTED A
VERSION OF THIS LEGISLATION AS
QUOTE AN EXAMPLE OF HOW THE
STATE CAN DEFINE ITS NEED AND
SEEK IMPROVEMENTS AND QUOTE. IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE CALIFORNIA'S
IMPAIRED DRIVING TASK FORCE
INCLUDED RECOMMENDATIONS IN ITS
REPORT. TO THE LEGISLATURE WHICH
NO CONCORDANCE OF ALL
LABORATORIES TESTING FOR ALL
SUBSTANCES. IN THEIR TESTING
PROCEDURES SB NINE TWENTY FIVE
WILL PUT THIS BEST PRACTICE IN
PLACE BY UPDATING CURRENT LAW TO
REQUIRE DRUG TESTING IN ADDITION
TO ALCOHOL TESTING AFTER FATAL
COLLISIONS. THE CALIFORNIA JOBS
TO LEGISLATIVE LEGALIZATION. OF
RECREATIONAL MARIJUANA GRAPPLES
WITH THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC THIS
THE LEGISLATURE MUST GIVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND IN PROTECTION
OF THE PUBLIC EVERY TOOL
POSSIBLE TO UNDERSTAND AND
PREVENT FUTURE FATAL COLLISIONS
. I'M ASKING THAT YOU JOIN LAW
ENFORCEMENT FORENSIC SCIENTISTS
AND ALL WILL BE ABLE TO
ASSOCIATIONS IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE TWENTY FIVE. THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERATION OFF DOWN THE LINE
IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OF ME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. I'M DID WE
HAVE A SECOND TO WITH A PRIMARY
WITNESS- SENATOR WE HAVE-
JENNIFER HARMAN THE CRIME
LABORATORY DIRECTORS WHOSE.
CANCERTECHNICAL OKAY SO LET'S
JUST LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY-
FOLKS IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL WHO
ARE HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM. IN
WHICH TO TESTIFY. GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING AND THIS CHAIR MEMBERS
WHO SHALL MUTCHLER HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CRIME LABORATORY
DIRECTORS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. YEAH MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE TIM CHANG WITH
THE AUTO CLUB OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT THE BILL.
GREAT ANY OTHER- WITNESSES
PRESENT IN THE HEARING ROOM.
RIGHT SEEING NONE WE WILL GET
MODERATOR PLEASE ANY- WITNESSES
WHO'VE CALLED IN THAT ONE WENT
TESTIFYING SUPPORT- ON THE
SCHEMA. IF I COULD TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO.
IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT FOR FIRST
PERSON. VOTED. AND WHO GETS
HURT. THE GENERATIONS GET HURT
THIS IS A DELICATE AREA FOLKS
TO BE JUST ONE MORE MOMENT. NINE
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS CASSANDRA CONNOR I
LIVE IN MODESTO CALIFORNIA AND I
AM IN SUPPORT OF THE NINETEEN.
THANK YOU VERY NEED ADDITIONAL
PEOPLE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THERE ARE NO
FURTHER LINES IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE CONTINUE
READING CHAIR THANKS SO MUCH- I
THERE'S NO LEAD OPPOSITION
REFERENCE BUT I WILL ASK IF
THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO WANTS TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. MRS SB NINE TWENTY FIVE
SEEING NINE MODERATOR COULD YOU
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE ON THE
LINE WHO WANTS TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE TWENTY
FIVE. THANK YOU MA'AM CARE IF
ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE TWENTY
FIVE THIS PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THERE ARE NO LINES IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE CONTINUE MADAM
CHAIR. EXCELLENT WILL GO BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. MEMBERS THE NEW
YORK GO AHEAD SENATOR- CONNOR
AND MOVE THE BILL AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME RIGHT WE'LL
TAKE THAT MOTION SENATOR TO BOTH
THE OF ANYTHING- THIS IS A BILL
VERY SIMILAR TO THE ONE WE'VE
HEARD BEFORE WHICH I SUPPORTED
I'LL BE SUPPORTING TODAY AND
SENATOR BUT YOU MAY CLOSE- JUST
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
WHEN WE ARE. IMPLEMENTED STUDY
GROUP AND THEY COME BACK WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS SAW HIS
IMPORTANT GUY IF WE CAN- TO GO
AHEAD AND MOVE FORWARD AND HOPE
THAT THAT WILL PROVIDE THE DATA
THAT WILL BE SO VERY NECESSARY
AS WE RAINY AND- ALL SOME OF THE
HORRIBLE CLIP CRASHES THAT
HAPPENED LATELY IF WE HAVE. THAT
INFORMATION MAYBE WE FIND A
SOLUTION TO THAT SO THANK YOU
AND ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. GREAT
WITH THAT WE WILL- VOTED AND THE
MOTION IS WHO HE- FOR BACK TO
LITTLE FORM TO PASS BUT FIRST RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AND- AND CONSULT
WITH YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB NINE TWENTY FIVE SKINNER AYE
SKINNER AYE. THE TROUBLE OAK I
PROVOKE I COM LONGER COME
LIGHTER I'D WRITE WE'VE GOT
THREE VOTES BUT WE'LL HOLD IT
OPEN FOR A MISSING MEMBER AND-
THINK SO MUCH- CENTER BATES.
THANK YOU. FOR IT WILL NOW GO TO
SENATOR PORTANTINO. WHO IS NOT
HERE. YOU CAN WALK IN AND OKAY. LEADER'S BILL-
AS AN
OKAY LET'S LOOK THE CALL ON S.
B. EIGHT FORTY ONE AM SENATOR
JONES GO AHEAD. SKINNER NOPE
SKINNER KNOWS VOTES TO HE
REQUESTED RECONSIDERATION OKAY.
ON. OKAY THAT- CENTERED JONES S.
B. H. FORTY ONE FAILED BUT WE
ARE GRANTING RECONSIDERATION.
WIENER. IT RIGHT NOW IT SAYS
THIS MEASURE SHALL ONLY TAKE
EFFECT IF BOTH THIS MEASURE AND
PROPOSITION BLANK- ARE APPROVED
BY THE VOTERS AT THE BLANK
STATEWIDE GENERAL ELECTION.
BECAUSE THAT IS SORT OF A
HYPOTHETICAL AT THIS POINT AND
MAYBE YOU COULD ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS OF THE FIREFIGHTERS
WELL WE SORT OF WORK THROUGH
SOME OF THESE OTHER MECHANICS
AND MAYBE FIND A WAY TO BACK
FILL THIS INTERGENERATIONAL TAX
ISSUE IN A MORE SORT OF TAILORED
WAY- WHETHER IT MIGHT MAKE
SENSE. TO STRIKE SECTION TO- AND
THEN THE MOVIE. SECTION ONE AND
SECTION THREE. FORWARD I KNOW WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE CURRENT
BILLS AMENDED FROM CENTER GROVE
BUT- BUT I WOULD BE OPEN TO A-
TO A MOTION ON ON THAT MAYBE
I'M I'M IN THE RENOUNCE THE VOTE
ON A SENATOR JONES THIS BILL
WHICH WAS SB EIGHT FORTY ONE. IT
WAS ACTUALLY ONE TWO THREE SO-
ONE OF JUST BE SURE TO PLACE
THAT ON THE RECORD. THAT THE
VOTE HAD TO- ONE ON A THREE
KNOWS BUT IS GRANTED
RECONSIDERATION THANK YOU. AND THEN FOCUSING
SPECIFICALLY ON TAILORING THE
MECHANICS YEAH THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR DOUG TO RESUME HAVE A
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS WE HAVE TO TAKE
THAT CHANGE IN THE MEASURE BACK
TO OUR LEADERSHIP AND HAVE A
DISCUSSION ABOUT IT. I DIDN'T-
NOT TO GET INTO ALL THE NUANCES
OF THE TAX POLICY BUT THE
IMPLICATIONS OF. REPEALING THE
INTERGENERATIONALTRANSFER
ELEMENTS OF PROPOSITION NINETEEN
WILL NOT ONLY HAVE AN IMPACT ON
THE FIRE FUNDS AS ITS STRUCTURED
IN THIS MEASURE BUT ALSO HAVE AN
IMPACT ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT
REVENUES. IN A IN A SENSE. THE
FIRE FUND WILL BE FUNDED BECAUSE
THERE WILL BE INCREASES IN LOCAL
PROPERTY TAX REVENUES THAT ARE
IMPORTANT FOR A SUITE OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SERVICES INCLUDING-
LOCAL FIRE DEPARTMENTS AND THE
SAVINGS. RELATED TO PROP NINETY
EIGHT THAT ARE GENERATED LOCALLY
IS WHAT WILL HELP SUPPORT THE
FIRE FUND SO THERE ARE SOME.
TECHNICAL IMPLICATIONS OF.
TRYING TO WORK THROUGH
STRUCTURING- PROPOSAL TO.
BACKFILL THE LOSSES AND THE
LOCAL REVENUES. THE WELL OUR
MEMBERS- HAVE A SEPARATE
COLLOQUY- APPRECIATE THAT
FEEDBACK- THERE'S NO MOTION ON
THAT BY THE WAY SO IN MAY- BUT
BUT I AM. LOOKING CENTER LAYERED
PERHAPS FOR SOME. I DON'T KNOW
IF I CAN OFFER IMPROVEMENT
BECAUSE I THINK THE DIFFICULTY
OF THIS IS ALL THE CONFLICTING
THINGS THE LINK. TO THE BALLOT
MEASURE AND THE LOSS OF FUNDS
DELAYED OPPOSITION AND I ALWAYS
WANT TO RESPECT THE SENATOR DEBT
IS TRYING TO WORK THINGS OUT AND
GET
THANK SENATOR PORTANTINO EUROPE. AT A CERTAIN MEMBERS FOR YOUR
PATIENCE I REALLY APPRECIATE IT-
TODAY I'M PRESENTING. S. B.
EIGHT TWENTY NINE WHICH WOULD
ESTABLISH MUCH NEEDED SAFETY
PROTOCOLS FOR THE USE OF
FIREARMS ON PRODUCTION SETS AS
I'M SURE YOU'RE ALL AWARE IN
OCTOBER OF LAST YEAR IN NEW YORK
NEW MEXICO CINEMATOGRAPHER WAS
TRAGICALLY FATALLY SHOT AND A
DOCTOR WAS BADLY INJURED ON THE
SET OF A FILM. IT IS POSSIBLE
THAT THIS TRAGEDY COULD HAVE A
COULD HAVE BEEN AVOIDED IF
SAFETY PROTOCOLS WERE
STANDARDIZED AND PRESCRIBED INTO
CALIFORNIA HAS SOME OF THE
STRONGEST LAWS BUT WE CAN STILL
IMPROVE WHAT'S GOING ON HERE IN
WHICH I'M TRYING TO DO TODAY
MOTION PICTURE AND TELEVISION
PRODUCTION IS A LARGE AND VITAL
COMPONENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY. AS OUR- CHAIR KNOWS-
THROUGH THE BUDGET WE'VE DONE A
LOT OF GOOD WORK TO PRESERVE AND
PROTECT OUR ENTERTAINMENT-
PRODUCTION THROUGHOUT THE STATE-
WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE STATE'S SETS ARE SAFE AND
CURRENTLY PRODUCERS AND OUR
LABOR- FRIENDS ARE TRYING TO
ADDRESS A PRODUCTION ON SUCH
THROUGH THE INDUSTRY WIDE LABOR
MANAGEMENT SAFETY COMMITTEE
WHICH ESTABLISHES A VOLUNTARY
SAFETY BULLETINS TO PROVIDE
SAFETY COURSES FOR WORKERS
HOWEVER THESE OPERATE AS BEST
PRACTICE GUIDES AS OPPOSED TO
ESTABLISH SAFETY PROTOCOLS.
GIVEN THE IMMENSITY OF THE FILM
INDUSTRY YOU'RE IN CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATION THAT'S OFFICE
SOLIDIFIES THESE VOLUNTARY
STANDARDS PERTAINING TO FIREARMS
IS NEEDED SB EIGHT TWENTY NINE
REQUIRE THAT THOSE WHO HANDLE
FIREARMS ARE PROPERLY TRAINED
THIS BILL WILL MAKE CALIFORNIA
PRODUCTION SAID SAFER AND HELP
ENSURE THAT ANOTHER TRAGIC
INCIDENT DOES NOT OCCUR TODAY I
HAVE WITH ME FELIPE A FIVE DAYS
FROM THE MOTION PICTURE
ASSOCIATION AND ACT
APPROPRIATELY WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER PORTANTINO AND LEAD
WITNESS MISTER FORTIES YOU CAN
BEGIN. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR-
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS PHILIP IF WENT THIS AND I AM
REPRESENTING THE MOTION PICTURE
ASSOCIATION. IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL EIGHT TO NINE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TODAY. MPAS A TRADE ASSOCIATION
FOR THE LEADING PRODUCERS AND
DISTRIBUTORS OF MOTION PICTURES
TELEVISION AND STREAMING SERIES
ACROSS ALL EXHIBITION PLATFORMS.
FOR MOVIE THEATERS TO BROADCAST
AND CABLE TELEVISION TO THE
INTERNET AND STREAMING SERVICES.
IT'S MEMBERS ARE DISNEY NBC
UNIVERSAL NETFLIX PARAMOUNT SONY
PICTURES AND WARNER BROTHERS.
MPA SUPPORTS SENATOR
PORTANTINO'S BILL TO ENHANCE
FIREARM SAFETY IN MOTION PICTURE
PRODUCTION. EACH STUDIO HAS THE
DEPARTMENT OF ENVIRONMENT HEALTH
AND SAFETY DEDICATED TO ENSURING
THE WORKPLACE SAFETY FOR THEIR
EMPLOYEES. AND ALL THE STUDIOS
PARTICIPATE IN THE INDUSTRY WIDE
A LABOR MANAGEMENT SAFETY
COMMITTEE. WITH THEIR UNION AND
GIL PARKER'S THIS COMMITTEE WAS
CREATED THROUGH THE PROCESS OF
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING BETWEEN
THE PRODUCERS AND THE UNIONS AND
GUILDS. UNDER THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT THE
COMMITTEE'S REQUIRE TO MEET
MONTHLY TO ADDRESS A VARIETY OF
SAFETY ISSUES. TOGETHER THE
STUDIO AND UNION REPRESENTATIVES
HAVE DEVELOPED OVER FORTY SAFETY
BULLETINS WHICH ARE DESIGNED TO
BE BEST PRACTICE GUIDES. FOR
VARIOUS ELEMENTS OF PRODUCTION
THE SAFETY COMMITTEE HAS SAFETY
BULLETINS THAT ADDRESS THE USE
OF FIREARMS AND PRODUCTIONS AND
THOSE BULLETINS ARE FOLLOWED BY
MPA'S MEMBER COMPANIES
PRODUCTIONS. END THE SAFETY
COMMITTEE HAS A SAFETY CLASS
ATTENDED BY THE ARMORS TO HANDLE
FIREARMS THAT PROVIDES TRAINING
FOR ALL THE SAFE HANDLING OF
FIREARMS. CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA
LAW DOES NOT REQUIRE SAFETY
TRAINING FOR THOSE WHO SEEK TO
OVERSEE THE USE OF FIREARMS AND
PRODUCTION MPA'S MEMBER SEEK TO
ENSURE THAT ON ALL PRODUCTIONS
THOSE WHO MANAGE THE USE OF
FIREARMS ARE PRODUCTIONS. THOSE
WHO WERE CLOSE TO THE FIRE ARMS
IN THOSE FIRE THOSE PERFORMERS
TO UTILIZE THE FIREARMS HAVE
APPROPRIATE SAFETY TRAINING AND
THAT'S WHAT SENATE BILL EIGHT TO
NINE DOES THE BILL REQUIRES
PROPER SAFETY TRAINING. FOR THE
ARMORS OTHER CREW AND THE
PERFORMERS WHO USE FIREARMS THE
BILL REQUIRES FARMERS TO
COMPLETE A SAFETY COURSE.
DEVELOPED BY THE SAFETY
COMMITTEE IN CONSULTATION WITH
THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL WOULD APPROVE
VENDORS TO OFFER THE CLASS. THE
SAFETY CLASS WILL OFFER HANDS ON
TRAINING AND DETAILED SAFETY
PRODUCTION PROCEDURES AS
SPECIFIED IN THE BILL IN
ADDITION SENATE BILL EIGHTY NINE
REQUIRES THOSE CREW MEMBERS WHO
WORK NEARBY TO THE FIREARMS. AS
WELL AS THOSE PERFORMERS USING A
GUN AS PART OF THE PERFORMANCE
THIS TAKE A SAFETY CLASS END OF
THE BILL PROVIDES THAT WHEN FIRE
ARMS A USE. THE PRODUCER MUST
HIRE A LOCAL FIRE OFFICIAL TO
SUPERVISE THE HANDLING OF
FIREARMS FINALLY THE BILL
PROHIBITS THE USE OF AMMUNITION
EXCEPT IN MOST LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCES. SB EIGHT TO NINE
WILL ELEVATE AND ENHANCE FIREARM
SAFETY AND PRODUCTION AND MPA IS
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE BILL MPA
LOOKS FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE SENATOR ON THIS.
IMPORTANT BILL AND WE WANT TO
THANK HIM FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. NOW I DO
HAVE A SHORT LETTER ON BEHALF
OF- THE INDEPENDENT STUDIO
SERVICES THEY COULDN'T BE HERE
TODAY IF I MAY READ INTO THE
RECORD IF THEY ARE NOT PART OF
THE LISTED LEAD OPPOSITION YOU
CAN INDICATE THAT THEY ARE. IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE IN YOU CAN
DISTRIBUTE THE LETTER THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR WE WILL SUBMIT THE
LETTER THEY. ARE IN SUPPORT.
EXCELLENT OUR LET'S. IF THERE'S
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL IN THE HEARING ROOM. MADAM CHAIR CHAIR TRENT SMITH
ON BEHALF OF THE WALT DISNEY
COMPANY IN SUPPORT. MADAM CHAIR
REALLY LAREDO WITH BROWN STEEN
ON BEHALF OF WARNER BROTHERS IN
SPORTS THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT THEN
MODERATOR CAN YOU- THAT WAS IN
THIS HEARING ROOM BUT SEEING TO
AND MODERATOR POLICE QUEUE UP
THE PHONE- TESTIMONY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF- S. B. EIGHT
TWENTY NINE AND THOSE ON THE
PHONE YOU'LL STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND THAT YOUR IN
SUPPORT THAT'S ALL THAT WE WILL
BE TAKING US TESTIMONY FROM NOW.
GO AHEAD MODERATOR. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
TWENTY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
BORDERLINES SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING IF THEY CAN
ONLY HAPPEN IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR TRACY STEVENS IN
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF NETFLIX.
THANK YOU IN LINE NINETY THREE
IS GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS PRO CHOICE ON BEHALF OF NBC
UNIVERSAL AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. IF THERE ARE ANY OTHER LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT TWENTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
LINES IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
TWENTY NINE PLEASE CONTINUE
MADAM CHAIR. THE- SORRY
DID NOT SEE CENTER COVER EUROPE
APOLOGIES. SO WE'LL GO WITH
STAND FILE ORDER HERE WE'RE
GONNA FILE ITEM FOR. SB
HOCKEY'S. IT'S THAT TIME YES AND
I'M A LAST MINUTE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE SO I'VE GOT MULTIPLE
THINKS I'M TRYING TO JUGGLE
PATHOLOGIES- LET US SEE IF THERE
ARE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I
DON'T HAVE ANY FORMAL. WITNESSES
LISTED IN OPPOSITION BUT LET ME
SEE IF THERE ARE ANY IN THEIR
ROOM WHO WANT TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. SEEING
NINE MODERATOR WOULD YOU SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINES WANT TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT TWENTY
NINE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IF
YOU WISH WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT TO NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THERE ARE NO LINES IN
OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT TWENTY
NINE PLEASE CONTINUE MANAGE HERE
. THANK YOU SO WE'LL COME BACK
TO US THE DALLAS AND SEE FOR
COMMITTEE MEMBER SEVENTY-
COMMENTS. GO AHEAD SENATOR JOE
BURKE ARTIST I'M JUST A
CURIOSITY- I NOTICED HERE THAT
YOU HAD THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL
IN CHARGE OF THE- SAFETY WHY. IN
PARTICULAR THE THIS STATE FIRE
MARSHAL FISH TRYING TO CREATE A
STATEWIDE STANDARDS. YOU KNOW
SEEM LIKE THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL
WAS THE APPROPRIATE PLACE. OKAY
I'M NOT SURE WHAT. I WOULD JUST
NAIVE ME I WOULD HAVE THOUGHT TO
BE IN IN PUBLIC SAFETY- HAVE
BEEN. SOMEONE TO OVERSEE IT. THE
BACK MY WITNESS ADDRESS THAT IT
. IF THE CHAIRS OKAY WITH YES
PLEASE IF I AM THE REASON THAT
WE USE IN THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL
IS THAT WE ALREADY HAVE A ROLE
RATHER THEY PLAY A ROLE FIRE
DEPARTMENTS PLAY A ROLE ON SETS
WHEN WE DEAL WITH PYROTECHNICS
WE ALREADY HAVE THAT BADGE. ON
SET FOR A LOT OF THE THINGS THAT
WE DO THAT REQUIRE SOME SPECIAL
ATTENTION SO IT JUST MADE SENSE
TO US TO PROCEED ALONG THOSE
LINES. I'M OF THE BILL. ALL
RIGHT SO WE HAVE A MOTION AND-
CENTREBOARD NEED PORTANTINO'S OR
HURT YOU I WILL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL TODAY. AND IT'S- I
THINK- ALL OF US. WHO HAVE BEEN.
WATCHING MEDIA REPORTS ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE SAFETY ON
SETS WE HAVE THAT VERY
UNFORTUNATE INCIDENT. WITH THE-
WOMAN DIRECTOR WHO- DIED. DUE TO
A AN MISFIRE OF A GUN. AND WE'VE
RECENTLY READ THERE'S ANOTHER
VERY PROMINENT ACTOR. WHO FILE
FORTUNATELY AT LEAST ACCORDING
TO THE REPORTS I'VE READ DID NOT
CAUSE ANY HARM HAS ALSO. ON SET-
UTILIZED A FIREARM BEFORE IT
WAS. SUPPOSED TO BE UTILIZED ON
THE SET. AND IN IN THOSE CASES-
AT LEAST. YOU KNOW THERE CAN BE
A CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE SOME. AT
THE DANGER OCCURS. SO IT'S CLEAR
THAT- THE PROTOCOLS ON SET
WHILE. WHILE DEVELOPED FOR
SAFETY HAVE NOT. LIKE SO MANY
THINGS ARE NOT FEEL SAFE SO.
THIS ADDITIONAL ON- SAFEGUARD
WILL I THINK HELP SO I'M YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU INCLUDED AN
ELOQUENT JOB WITH YOUR WRAP UP
IN THE HOUSE WILL TAKE YOUR
STATEMENT HAS MY CLOTHES AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND HAVE A-
ALL RIGHT SO- NOW I'M CONSULTANT
WILL YOU PLEASE- CALL THE ROLL
ON SB EIGHT TO NINE AND THE BILL
IS- YOU PASSED REFERRED TO AT
THE GEO COMMITTEE. SB EIGHT TO
NINE SKINNER HI SKINNER I
PROVOKE MY TROUBLE GUY COME
LONGER WIENER. RIGHT WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN THANK YOU- AND WE
WILL NOW. OUR NEXT BILL IS-
KAMALA YES I AM. THE SERVER FOR
BEERUS. RECORD. ALONE
RESULTING IN ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC
COSTS. A LOT TO NEARLY FIFTEEN
THOUSAND JOBS ACROSS THE-AGRICULTURAL SECTOR. AND THE
AVERAGE ANNUAL TEMPERATURES HAVE
INCREASED ALREADY INCREASED
1 DEGREES FAHRENHEIT THE SUMMARY
TO CALIFORNIA EXCEEDING TWO
DEGREES. ACCORDING TO HE CRISIS
MADAM CHAIR. CALIFORNIA IS IN
THE MIDDLE OF A STATE WIDE
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS NEARLY ONE
IN SIX CALIFORNIA DOES HAS A
MENTAL HEALTH NEED AND ONE IN
TWENTY SUFFERS FROM A SERIOUS
MENTAL MENTAL ILLNESS THAT MAKES
IT DIFFICULT TO CARRY OUT MAJOR
LIFE ACTIVITIES THESE MEMBERS
ARE EVEN MORE THESE NUMBERS ARE
EVEN MORE SEVERE WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE STATE'S HOMELESS POPULATIONS
WITH 70% STRUGGLING WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
AND OR PHYSICAL DISABILITY. IN
ADDITION GROWING NUMBERS OF
INMATES ARE WAITING FOR STATE
HOSPITAL BEDS SOMETIMES FOR
MONTHS AT A TIME IN THE PAST
FIVE YEARS THE NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIA INMATES DEEMED
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL AND
ORDERED AND ORDERED SENT TO
STATE HOSPITALS INCREASED 60% A
FEW DECADES AGO FEWER THAN HALF
OF STATE HOSPITAL PATIENTS CAME
FROM THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
TODAY MORE THAN NINETY PERCENT.
DO WHEN PEOPLE IN PSYCHIATRIC
CRISIS LINE EMERGENCY ROOMS AND
JAILS IT'S FREQUENTLY BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T GET TREATMENT IN THE
COMMUNITY. EVEN WHEN THEY ASK
FOR IT. MANY CALIFORNIA CAT MANY
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES HAVE BEGUN
TURNING TO MENTAL HEALTH AND
HOMELESS COURTS AS A MEANS OF
ADDRESSING THE ROOT CAUSE OF
THESE ISSUES THESE PROGRAMS
ALLOW FOR THE INDIVIDUAL WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS AND HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS TO GET THE RESOURCES
THAT THEY NEED IN ORDER TO TURN
THEIR LIVES AROUND THESE COURTS
ALSO WORK TO EASE PRISON AND
JAIL CROWDING BY GETTING PEOPLE
INTO TREATMENT INSTEAD OF
CUSTODY THUS REDUCING THE
CHANCES OF RECIDIVISM DUE TO
UNTREATED MENTAL. MENTAL ILLNESS
. MANY CALIFORNIA COUNTIES HAVE
COLLABORATIVE COURTS TO ADDRESS
THE NEEDS OF AN IMPROVING
OUTCOMES FOR SPECIALIZED
POPULATIONS OF CRIMINAL
OFFENDERS. THIS INCLUDES FORTY
FOUR COUNTIES WITH MENTAL HEALTH
COURTS FOR ADULT OFFENDERS AND
THIRTEEN COUNTIES WITH HOMELESS
WORKS. NUMEROUS REVIEWS AND
EVALUATIONS HAVE FOUND THAT
MENTAL HEALTH COURTS REDUCE
INCARCERATION AND RE OFFENSE
WHILE IMPROVING THE QUALITY OF
LIFE AMONG THOSE DIAGNOSED WITH
MENTAL ILLNESSES. IN FACT A TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN STUDY OF
THE SACRAMENTO COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH COURT FOUND THAT ROUGHLY
70% OF PARTICIPANTS COMPLETED
THE COURT AND HAD A LOWER RATE
OF REARREST THAN NON GRADUATES.
IN ADDITION THEY HAD A 75% LOWER
CHANCE OF BEING HOUSE
HOSPITALIZED AND A DECREASE IN
REAR FENCE ACROSS GENDERS ETHNO
RACIAL BACKGROUNDS AND AGES.
HOWEVER DESPITE THESE COURTS
BEING PROVEN AS SUCCESSFUL TOOL
FOR HELPING HER MENTALLY ILL
POPULATIONS WHO BECOME. JUSTICE
INVOLVED THESE ARE COURT THESE
COURTS ARE OFTEN UNDERFUNDED AND
HAVING SUFFICIENT PROGRAMMING
OPTIONS FOR PARTICIPATING
DEFENDANTS. THAT IS WHY I HAVE
DECIDED TO INTRODUCE SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN IN ORDER TO GET
INDIVIDUALS WITH MENTAL ILLNESS
AND HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS THE
CARE THEY NEED AND TO PROMOTE
REHABILITATION AND HOUSING
STABILITY. SB FOURTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN ESTABLISHES TO GRANT
PROGRAMS WON A GRANT PROGRAM TO
HELP COUNTIES TO ESTABLISH OR
EXPAND COLLABORATIVE MENTAL
HEALTH IN HOMELESS QUARTZ INTO A
GRANT PROGRAM FOR COUNTIES TO
INSTITUTE REENTRY SERVICES FOR
JAIL INMATES AT RISK OF BECOMING
HOMELESS UPON RELEASE. I WILL
ALSO NOTE THAT THESE THIS PAST
WEEK WE HAVE HAD THE PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL ABOUT WAYS IN WHICH TO
IMPROVE THE BILL. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO IMPLEMENTING SOME OF
THESE AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
JOINING ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
HIS SAN MARINO COUNTY SHERIFF
SHANNON'S I GUESS- FOUR AND IF
HE'S NOT AVAILABLE WE ALSO HAVE
SERGEANTS JULIUS MY CHRISTIAN
SEVERINO COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT LEGISLATIVE LIAISON
AND ALSO JOINING ON THE LINE.
WILL BE FRANCINE BURN WITH THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA
AS AN INFORMATIONAL ONLY WITNESS
TO HELP ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW MENTAL
HEALTH COURTS WORK IN CALIFORNIA
. GREAT WILL GO WITH YOUR LEAD
WITNESS WHO I'M ASSUMING IS ON
THE LINE SO MODERATOR PLEASE
PROCEED WITH HAVING THE LEAD
WITNESS FOR S. B. M. FOURTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN. MODERATOR. I'M
LOOKING FOR THEIR LINE. I DO NOT
SEE THEM CONNECTED..
THEY'RE NOT CONNECTED TO THE
CONFERENCE. I AM OKAY SHERIFF IS
HAVING A DIFFICULT TIME GETTING
THROUGH HE'S ON HOLD OF THE-
SHERIFF IS ON HOLD- SIX ONE
MOMENT LET ME CHECK OKAY WOULD
YOU SAY THE NAME OF THE SHERIFF
AGAIN HI IT IS SHERIFF SHANNON
DICUS SHERIFF SHANNON DICUS AND
THAT PERSON IS ON HOLD. MY
APOLOGIES WE HAVE NO LINE TRYING
TO HOLD SO THEY MAY HAVE MISSED
DIOLS. IS THERE A NUMBER THAT-
OKAY LET'S HAVE- IT SURE OF
DICUS RECALL THE NUMBER AND THAT
NUMBER IS. WORK WILL GET THE
MODERATOR IF ROOMS WAIT A MINUTE. IS THERE A NUMBER THAT THEY
HAVE THE TIRES WERE BOTH PPO.
IT'S A REALLY GREAT WITH NUMBERS
DIFFERENT- GOT IT. WOULD YOU
LIKE ME TO GIVE IT OVER THE
PHONE OR- YOU HAVE IT DO YOU
HAVE THE NUMBER MODERATOR FOR
EARLY AND LATE NIGHTS OKAY
EIGHT. EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT. GO
AHEAD. EIGHT SIX TWO. ZERO.
THREE FIVE SIX. ALL RIGHT SO
SURE OF- A **** IS IF YOU ARE
LISTENING THE NUMBER TO CALL IS. 888-862-0356. TO
WATER INSURED BASINS WILL
INCREASINGLY BE USED AS LEVERAGE
THE
I'LL LET YOU KNOW WHEN THEY JOIN
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WELL WHERE
YOU'RE FROM. THIRD
EFFORT TO PROVIDE CRITICAL
FUNDING. FOR THESE CONVEYANCE
PROJECTS THAT DELIVER WATER TO
FARMS AND SERVE THIRTY ONE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS. BUT I
BELIEVE MORE MUST BE DONE TO
SECURE OUR FUTURE IN CALIFORNIA
WE BELIEVE THAT WATER IN
CALIFORNIA. CENTER CORTESE AND
I'VE- MUST BE MODERNIZED. ANY
WEIGHT THAT WE I JUST SPOKE TO
IN THAT CONTEXT. AND I WANT TO
GIVE YOU ANOTHER EXAMPLE WE TOOK
OUT THE CONCERN OF CYBER ATTACKS
ON OUR WATER AND FOOD SECTORS TO
THE ALLEY GOES OFFICE LAST YEAR.
AND THE RESEARCH THAT BE FOUND-
BE CONCLUDED THAT IT THERE WAS A
LACK OF DEDICATED CYBERSECURITY
FUNDING AND STAFF LIMITS A
PREPARED IT'S OF CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE SECTOR ENTITIES.
ARE THEY ALSO NOTED AN
INCREASING NUMBER OF CYBER
ATTACKS. ON
YEAH.
WHAT IS YOUR READING. HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ACROSS ALL ENTITIES
INSTRUCTORS
WHY DON'T YOU THERE'S OTHER
PEOPLE IN SUPPORT OKAY GO BACK
TO WORK BETTER TO GET RID OF ALL
RIGHT LET'S SEE IF THERE'S-
MODERATOR WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
WHILE WE'RE WAITING FOR THE
SHERIFF IS WE'LL SEE IF THERE'S
ANY OTHER WITNESSES. ONE SECOND
WHO IS GOING TO TESTIFYING
BEHALF- WE HAVE REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE SHARE FOR CONTEST FI.
AS A LEAD WITNESS AND THAT IS
AGREEABLE WITH OUR LEAD WITNESS. OKAY ALL RIGHT SO LET'S HAVE
THE SHERIFF'S REPRESENTATIVE
TESTIFIED THEN IS THE LEAD
WITNESS GO AHEAD ALL RIGHT SIR.
GO AHEAD MODERATOR YES. DID YOU
SAY YOU WERE LOOKING FOR SHARING
DAY NO NO SHARE SHERIFF SHERIFF
**** SHANNON DICUS- I'M- ON
RIGHT NOW OKAY WHETHER PROCEED.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. EIGHT THANK
YOU MEMBERS I APOLOGIZE FOR THE
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES BUT AS
YOU'RE AWARE- BILL FOURTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN ESTABLISHES GRANT
PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT EVERY USING
HOMELESSNESS AMONG INMATES
RELEASED FROM CUSTODY AND
ADDRESSES CRIME REDUCTION OF THE
MENTALLY ILL. AT A LARGE SCALE
AND HAM RADIO COUNTY THIS HAS
BEEN OUR DAILY MENTAL HEALTH
POPULATION OF FIFTEEN POINT FOUR
PERCENT. WHICH IS COMPARATIVE TO
TWENTY SIX HUNDRED INMATES
FEMENINO COUNTY TRACKS THE TOP
ONE HUNDRED FREQUENTLY ARRESTED
INDIVIDUALS. AND TWENTY TWENTY
OF THE TOP THREE CHARGES OF
THESE REAR FENDERS WERE UNDER
THE INFLUENCE OF A CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE PUBLIC INTOXICATION
AND TRESPASSING. FORTY SEVEN OF
THOSE ONE HUNDRED DO NOT HAVE AN
ADDRESS. THAT THE WHOLE MENTAL
HEALTH COURTS ARE A TYPE OF
COLLABORATIVE COURT. ALTERNATIVE
TO THE TRADITIONAL COURT SYSTEM
AND PROVIDE SPECIFIC SERVICES OF
TREATMENT TO DEFENDANTS WHO ARE
DEALING WITH MENTAL ILLNESS.
ALTHOUGH EACH MNTAL HEALTH
COURT HAS DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS
AND SERVICES AVAILABLE TO
PARTICIPANTS THEY SHARE THE SAME
GOALS OF SUPPORTING PARTICIPANTS. AND THEIR SUCCESSFUL RETURN TO
SOCIETY. REDUCING THE IN FOR
SAFETY AND THE OF THE- ALMOST
CHORDS VERY SPECIAL SESSION HELD
IN A LOCAL SHELTER OTHER
COMMUNITY SITE. FOR ALMOST AND
RESOLVE OUTSTANDING MISDEMEANOR
CRIMINAL. INCLUDING MANY OF
QUALITY OF LIFE INFRACTION SUCH
AS DISORDERLY CONDUCT PUBLIC
DRUNKENNESS. SPEAKING ON THE
SIDEWALK. THE HOMELESS COURT
PROGRAM. RECOGNIZE MUCH PART
VOLUNTARY EFFORTS TO IMPROVE
LIVES AND MOVED FROM THE STREETS
TOWARDS SELF SUFFICIENCY
INCLUDING PARTICIPATION IN
COMMUNITY BASED TREATMENT
SERVICES. PROVIDING COMMUNITY
OUTREACH AND ASSISTANCE TO
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS WITH
OUTSTANDING COURT CASES IS A
PRIMARY FOCUS BECAUSE THESE
TYPES OF CASES TEND TO ESCALATE
WHEN HOMELESS DEFENDANTS FAILED
TO APPEAR IN COURT. MANY COUNTY
HAVE COLLABORATIVE COURTS TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF SPECIALIZED
POPULATIONS OF CRIMINAL
OFFENDERS HOWEVER THESE COURTS
ARE OFTEN UNDERFUNDED. AND HAVE
INSUFFICIENT PROGRAMMING OPTIONS
. SINCE JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE DEPUTY FROM THE FEMENINO
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT HAVE
CONTACTED APPROXIMATELY THREE
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS IN THE
STREET. 30% OF THOSE CONTACTED
HELP SELF ADMITTED MENTAL HEALTH
DIAGNOSIS 22% OF THOSE CONTACTED
PERSISTED WITH HOUSING BUT
REFUSE ADDITIONAL SERVICES. WHAT
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN COUNTIES TO WORK TOGETHER
TO GET THE HOMELESS AND MENTALLY
ILL INDIVIDUALS INTO TREATMENT
INSTEAD OF BEING PLACED IN JAIL.
FOR THOSE REASONS I'M IN SUPPORT
OF SENATE BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN AN URGENT I. THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING. I THANK YOU SHERIFF
AND- IF YOU ARMS. CAN STAY ON
THE LINE BECAUSE- I MAY HAVE A
QUESTION. WHEN WE GET TO THE
DISCUSSION PART BUT WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE ON WITH WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. SO LET ME SEE IF THERE
ARE WITNESSES IN THE ROOM IN
SUPPORT YOU CAN COME UP TO THE-
MIKE INDICATE YOUR- NAME
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION.
GOOD MORNING MR MEMBERS WHO
SHALL MUCH OR ON BEHALF OFTHE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF
QUESTION. GOOD MORNING SERGEANT
WHO IS GOING ON FOR THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
APARTMENT ENSURE CHAD BIANCO IN
SUPPORT. GREAT ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE
ROOM. ALL RIGHT MODERATOR LET'S-
IT HE UP WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
SB FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN AND
AGAIN THAT YOUR NAME AFFILIATION
IN YOUR POSITION. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. BECAUSE THE MOMENT
FOR FIRST PERSON THANK YOU.
COLLECTIVELY THREE MINUTES. HI
MY NAME IS
NINE ONE HUNDRED AND SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU CARE
MEMBERS BACK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION OFTEN SUPPORT. IF
THERE ARE ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
OF PEOPLE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. NO FURTHER LINES IN SUPPORT OF
SB FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
CONTINUE MEDICARE. THANKS SO
MUCH- LET'S SEE- LET'S NOW GO TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. AND I
BELIEVE WE DO HAVE A- ONE
MOMENT- I BELIEVE WE DO WE HAVE
NO LEAD OPPOSITION LISTED LET ME
SEE IF THERE WAS ANY- IF THERE
IS ANY. OPPOSITION IN THE
HEARING ROOM- DO WE HAVE ANYONE
HERE WHO WANTS TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FOURTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN. SEEING NINE DO WE HAVE
ANY ON THE PHONE LINES. FOR THE
LATEST BEGIN. OPPOSITION OF SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
AM SURE THERE ARE NO LINES IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FOURTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN YES CONTINUE. THANK YOU-
WILL NOW GO TO THE DYESS AND
HAVE DISCUSSION- SENATOR I HAVE
A QUESTION AND YOU MAY ANSWER
THE LEAD- FIGHT. IN GENERAL I
SUPPORT THE CONCEPT OF THE BILL
AND WHAT THE- WHAT IS TRYING TO
BE ACCOMPLISHED HERE HOWEVER
WHAT I AM- IT WE HAVE. REENTRY
PROGRAMS THAT ARE DIVERSIONARY
COURTS ARE USE AND SOME OF THEM
ARE RUN BY- FIVE DIFFERENT
ENTITIES AND OF COURSE THE COURT
IS- CHOOSES WHAT ENTITIES AND
THE COURT HAS CONFIDENCE IN THE
ENTITIES THEY'RE CHOOSING AND
BUT THIS BILL HAS THE
SPECIFICATION THAT IT MUST BE
THE SHERIFF'S OFFICE THAT
OPERATES THE PROGRAM SO IN OTHER
WORDS IT'S THE SHERIFF'S OFFICE
THAT RECEIVES THE GRANT VERSES
FIVE. OR SOLELY VERSES ALLOWING
FOR- POTENTIALLY OTHER ENTITIES
FOR RECEIVING THE GRANT TO RUN
THE PROGRAM SO I'M WONDERING WHY
THAT THE STIPULATION THAT IT
MUST BE THE SHERIFF'S OFFICE
ONLY- MAY I ASK YOU THERE'S-
SHIRT I GUESS FOR OUR TECHNICAL.
EXPERTS TO SPEAK ON THAT
FRANCINE BURN. TO BE OKAY. FIVE
SHIRT ON IS IT THE TECHNICAL
WITNESS THAT ASKED FOR IT THE
SPECIFICATION OR IS THIS YEAR'S
OFFICE. YOU KNOW THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION I HAD THE ORIGINAL
CONVERSATIONS CAME BECAUSE OF MY
CONVERSATIONS WITH- SHERIFF
DICUS OKAY SO THAT'S HOW WE
MEASURE IF I GUESS IF YOU'RE ON
THE LINE PERHAPS YOU COULD
ANSWER THE QUESTION IF YOU'RE
STILL THERE. SURE SENATOR. IN IN
CONVERSATION WITH- CENTER UNTIL
LOW IN FAMILY YOU KNOW COUNTY
THESE TYPES OF COURTS THAT YOU
DESCRIBED ARE NOT AVAILABLE
SINCE THE INCEPTION OF THESE
PEOPLE ARE WITH THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT IN TERMS OF TAKING
THEM INTO CUSTODY WE SIMPLY
WANTED TO COORDINATE BUILDING
THE CAPACITY IN THIS COUNTY TO
BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
OF HOMELESSNESS AND MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES AND- IN THIS
COUNTY I PROBABLY HAVE THE MOST
ONGOING KNOWLEDGE OF HOW WE CAN
MAKE THIS WORK AND IT'S MORE
ABOUT COORDINATORS EFFORT AND A
COORDINATORS OFFER. TO BRING
THIS TYPE OF SERVICE ARE COUNTY
AND USE MORE OF THE
CONSERVATORSHIP MODEL WHICH IS
IN LINE WITH THE CARE COURT
MODEL THAT THE GOVERNOR. IS
CURRENTLY PROPOSING. EVEN YES
BUT I THINK EVEN IN THE CARE
COURT MODEL. THE FUNDING WOULD
NOT ONLY GO THROUGH FOR EXAMPLE
THE SHERIFF'S OFFICE BUT- WHAT I
GUESS WHAT I WANT TO KNOW IS
WHETHER YOU'D BE OPEN AND-
APOLOGIES FOR NOT REALIZING THAT
SAMBAR DDD DO YOU KNOW COUNTY
DOES NOT YET HAVE THESE TYPE OF
DIVERSITY COURTS- BUT I THINK I
REALLY APPLAUD YOU FOR YOUR
RECOGNITION OF THE VALUE OF
THEM. AND BUT I WONDER IF YOU'D
BE OPEN TO HAVING THE GRANTS GO
ALSO BE AVAILABLE TO. ENTITIES
THAT THE COURT. ON THAT THE
COURT ITSELF ALSO DEEMS AS A
CAPABLE OF PROVIDING THE SERVICE
THAT YOU ARE JUST TRYING TO
CHIEF. HELLO I WOULD BE
INTERESTED THAT I AM DOING MY
BEST TO BE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
ALL OF THE LAW AND JUSTICE
SYSTEM AS A WHOLE PARTICULARLY
HERE IN OUR COUNTY. JUST SO THAT
WE BUILD CAPACITY TO BETTER
SERVE THIS POPULATION. GREAT-
YES I THINK THAT THAT MIGHT HELP
ACHIEVE YOUR OBJECTIVE BECAUSE
THERE MAY BE- GIVEN WHAT YOU ARE
TRYING TO- IS THERE. WE DON'T
KNOW YET YOU CITED SOME VERY
SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS AND- YOU
KNOW IF THIS IS SUCCESSFUL THERE
MAY BE- THERE MAY BE NEED FOR-
BE EITHER ADDITIONAL PROGRAMS OR
TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THIS KIND
OF SERVICE IN ORDER FOR YOUR
DIVERSION PROGRAM TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. I'M OPEN TO ANYTHING
FURTHER CONVERSATIONS TO MAKE
THIS A MORE SUCCESSFUL AND
EFFICIENT- PROGRAM I JUST KNOW
THAT THERE IS A NEED AND YES WE
ARE WILLING TO DO THE WORK
THAT'S NEEDED IN ORDER TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT HAPPENS GREAT SO-
WHAT I'D LIKE TO SUGGEST
DESERVE. SINNER TO A BOOK IF
YOU'RE WILLING TO MAKE THAT
AMENDMENT I MEAN IT THIS PAST
MOVE ON TO ANOTHER COMMITTEE
ANYWAY THAT WE CAN- IF THAT
AMENDMENT COULD BE TAKEN IN THAT
SECOND COMMITTEE. ON BUT WE CAN
HAVE PUBLIC SAFETY IN YOUR STAFF
WORK OUT WHAT THE LANGUAGE IS SO
YOU'RE COMFORTABLE IN OKAY IT
WORKS ABSOLUTELY OKAY DEFINITELY
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING MORE
CONVERSATIONS IN THIS IS AS I
SAID EARLIER THIS ISN'T A NEW
SPACE FOR ME SO I AM VERY AN
OPENING HERE OKAY- EXCELLENT LET
ME SEE IF THERE'S- IF MY OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBER HAS ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS. OKAY- A-
DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL
OF. ALL RIGHT SO WE HAVE A
MOTION. AND WITH THE AGAIN WITH
THE- AGREEMENT THAT- SENATOR
OCHO VOTERS JUST MADE.
REGARDING- AMENDING. AND-
SENATOR TROUBLES ME CLOSE- I
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE BY QUICKLY
TELLING A STORY THAT SHOWS THE
REAL WORLD IMPACT THESE COURTS
CAN HALF THE STORY SHE PHILLIPS
WHICH IS TOLD IN THE SACBEE
ARTICLE YOU HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU
TODAY PHYLLIS WAS ARRESTED A
LITTLE MORE THAN TWO YEARS AGO
FOR SECOND DEGREE BURGLARY AFTER
BREAKING INTO AN UNLOCKED SHED
AND USING THE OWNER'S KITCHEN
AND BARBECUE TO COOK FOR HERSELF
. SHE WAS HOMELESS HAD BEEN UP
FOR DAYS WAS IN THE MIDDLE OF A
SCHIZOPHRENIC EPISODE.
EXASPERATED BY HER DRUG
ADDICTION. AND THOUGHT THE HOUSE
WAS HER OWN. THIS WAS HER SECOND
STRIKE WHICH CARRIED A MANDATORY
SENTENCE OF THREE YEARS IN
PRISON. ONE YEAR AND THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE DAYS
LATER PHILIP STOOD ONCE MORE IN
A SACRAMENTO COURTROOM. BUT THIS
TIME THE MOOD WAS VERY
DIFFERENT. IT WAS HER GRADUATION
DAY. AS A RESULT OF THE
SACRAMENTO'S INNOVATIVE MENTAL
HEALTH COURT SHE HAD COMPLETED
HER PROGRAM WITH DISTINCTION IN
JUST ELEVEN MONTHS AND IS NOW
WORKING AS A DRUG AND ALCOHOL
COUNSELOR. FOR WELL SPACE IN
SACRAMENTO. THIS IS JUST ONE
EXAMPLE OF. A OUT OF MANY OF AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO HAS HAD THE LIFE
CHANGING RESULTS THANKS TO AN
INNOVATIVE MENTAL HEALTH COURT
DIVERSION PROGRAM. WE MUST DO A
BETTER JOB WE MUST DO A BETTER
JOB. AS A STATE OF PRIORITIZING
THE NEEDS OF A MENTALLY ILL
POPULATIONS I BELIEVE SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN IS A STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. EXCELLENT CONSULTANT LET'S
CALL THE ROLL AND AGAIN THIS IS-
DO YOU PASSED WITH AGREEMENT
THAT THERE WILL BE THE AMENDMENT
WORKED OUT AND TAKEN- IN
APPROACH BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE
THE BILL GOES NEXT SECTOR ACT
THEY GET THAT RIGHT OKAY.
PROCEED WITH THE ROLL CALL. SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN- SKINNER.
HI SKINNER I THE TROUBLED I
TROUBLE GUY COM LAGER WINNER.
WIENER AYE. EXCELLENT AT FARM
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR OUR
MISSING MEMBER BUT YOU HAVE A
THREE AYE SO WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
SB FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX SENATOR
CAFIERO. IF THE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX AND
COMMITTEES TODAY. THIS BILL WILL
WILL MAKE IT A FELONY PUNISHABLE
BY UP TO THREE YEARS IN JAIL IF
AN OPERATOR OF AN ILLEGAL
CANNABIS GROW SITE IS FOUND TO
HAVE STOLEN WATER TAMPERED WITH
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE DOUG AND
UNPERMITTED WELL OR POLLUTED
GROUNDWATER SOURCES.
CALIFORNIA'S ARID CLIMATE MEANS
THAT EVERY YEAR REGARDLESS OF
THE YEARS RAIN OUTPUT OUR WATER
RESOURCES ARE STRETCHED THIN.
EVEN DURING SEASONS OF AVERAGE
RAINFALL AND SNOW CALIFORNIA
WATER RESOURCES ARE
OVERSUBSCRIBED THERE IS NOT
ENOUGH WATER IN OUR SYSTEM TO
MEET ALL OF THE NEEDS OF OUR
RESIDENTS THIS YEAR CALIFORNIA
IS PROJECTED TO BE HEADED
TOWARDS A HISTORIC ONE THOUSAND
YEAR DROUGHT. AS ONE OF THE
CONSISTENTLY CONSISTENTLY DRY
PROLONGED PERIODS IN RECORDED
HISTORY SCARY THING. ORDING TO
MEASUREMENTS COLLECTED FROM THIS
YEAR ALONE CALIFORNIA'S SNOWPACK
IS AT 39% OF ITS AVERAGE LEVEL
AND IT IS 23% LOWER THAN THIS
TIME LAST YEAR SO IT'S GETTING
WORSE. LOW SNOW PACK MEANS OUR
WATER SUPPLY FROM SNOW FALL WILL
NOT MEET DEMANDS IN THE SUMMER
AND THE FALL. THE AGRICULTURAL
ALLOCATION FROM THE FEDERAL AND
STATE WATER PROJECTS WILL BE
ZERO THIS YEAR. AS OF MARCH
THIRTY FIRST ALMOST ALL OF THE
STATE IS UNDER SEVERE DROUGHT
CONDITIONS WITH LARGE PARTS OF
THE NORTHERN AND CENTRAL AREAS
OF THE STATE EXPERIENCING
EXTREME DROUGHT. I SHARE THIS
DATA WITH YOU TODAY BECAUSE THAT
IS THAT IN LARGE PART THE
MOTIVATION. BEHIND THE BILL
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE. ILLICIT
CANNABIS CULTIVATORS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE THREATENING BOTH
ABOVE AND BELOW GROUND WATER
SUPPLIES SUPPLIES THAT ARE
LIFELINES FOR RURAL COMMUNITIES
AND URBAN CENTERS ALIKE.
ACCORDING TO A RECENT CAL MATTER
STUDY EXAMPLES OF WATER THEFT BY
ILLICIT CANNABIS GROWS IN THE
STATE ARE PROLIFIC. IN THE HIGH
DESERT F LOS ANGELES COUNTY
WATER THEFT RESULTED IN A WATER
SHUT OFF TO OVER THREE HUNDRED
HOMES IN MENDOCINO COUNTY THE
RUSSIAN RIVER IS BECOMING
DEPLETED. BECAUSE RIVERS AND
STREAMS THAT FEED INTO IT ARE
BEING DIVERTED. THE BROOKINGS
INSTITUTE REPORTED RECENTLY THAT
THIS SAYS ACTIVITY HAS LED TO
OVER TWENTY FOUR STREAMS IN THE
REGIONS. IN THE REGION GOING DRY
A DEVASTATING OUTCOME FOR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. LAST YEAR IN
SISKIYOU COUNTY ILLEGAL CANNABIS
CULTIVATORS STOLE AS MUCH AS TWO
MILLION GALLONS OF WATER PER
DAY. ENOUGH WATER TO SUPPLY UP
TO THREE QUARTERS OF ITS
POPULATION. IN TWENTY TWENTY THE
BROOKINGS INSTITUTE ESTIMATED
THAT UPWARDS OF NINE POINT FIVE
MILLION GALLONS OF WATER WAS
DIVERTED BY ILLEGAL CANNABIS
ACTIVITIES THAT'S DRINKING WATER
FOR OUR COMMUNITIES WATER FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HABITAT TO SUPPORT
FISH AND WILDLIFE. AND WATER TO
CAN HELP COMBAT FOREST FIRES
CURRENT LAW DOES NOT PROVIDE A
DETERRENT OR RESOURCES TO TRACK
AND STOP THE ILLICIT ACTIVITIES
OF A MULTI BILLION DOLLAR
CRIMINAL INDUSTRY. THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
HAS THE AUTHORITY TO FIND
ILLEGAL CANNABIS OPERATIONS UP
TO A THOUSAND DOLLARS A DAY FOR
STEALING WATER BUT FOR THIS
LEVEL OF CRIMINAL ACTIVITY IF
FINE IS SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH. IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN STATE OFFICIALS
CHARGED OVER ONE MILLION DOLLARS
IN FINES TO OVER A THOUSAND
WATER RIGHTS VIOLATORS YET WE
CONTINUE TO SEE A GROWING
PROBLEM. IN ADDITION TO
CRIMINALIZING WATER THEFT THIS
BILL ALSO ENHANCES PENALTIES FOR
GROUND WATER POLLUTION AND
ENVIRONMENTAL DEGRADATION.
ILLICIT CANNABIS CULTIVATORS DO
NOT ABIDE BY THE STATE
REGULATIONS REGARDING PROPER
PESTICIDE INSECTICIDE AND
RODENTICIDE USE AND DISPOSAL AS
A RESULT LARGER MONTH AMOUNT
TOXIC CHEMICALS ARE USED STORED
AND DISPOSED OF IMPROPERLY AND
CAUSE DAMAGE TO OUR STATE
SURFACE. AND GROUNDWATER
RESOURCES IN ADDITION THE USE OF
RODENTICIDES INADVERTENTLY
POISONED CREDITORS THE CONSUMER
RODENTS THAT HAVE BEEN EXPOSED
TO THE CHEMICALS. FOR ALL THESE
REASONS I ASK YOU CONSIDER
ADDING CRIMINAL PENALTIES I
BELIEVE THATPUNISHING THIS
ACTIVITY IS A CRIMINAL OFFENSE
IS NOT ONLY WARRANTED BUT
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO PROTECT
OUR NATURAL RESOURCES AND
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES WHO ARE
DEPENDENT ON DWINDLING WATER
SUPPLIES AND DELIVERIES. AFTER
LISTENING TO CONCERNS RAISED BY
MEMBER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AND COMMITTED TODAY TO HELP
ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED SHOULD THE BILL PASS
THE COMMITTEE I WILL- AGREEDTO
AMEND THE BILL TO REDUCE THE
PENALTY TO A WOBBLER THUS
ALLOWING THE COURTS THE
DISCRETION. TO DETERMINE THE
CHARGE OUT NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER
TWO TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
PLANTS IT WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
THE PENALTY FROM SIX TO FIFTY.
WE'RE NOT LOOKING FOR THE SMALL
TIME BACKYARD GROWERS WE'RE
LOOKING FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE DOING
THIS IS A COMMERCIAL ACTIVITY.
AND ARE ARE DOING IT HIDDEN-
USUALLY IN RURAL AND- ISOLATED.
LOCATIONS WITH THAT I WOULD
REDUCE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. I THANK YOU FOR ALL OF
THE COMMENTS BECAUSE I THINK
THEY WERE VERY HELPFUL. THANK
YOU SENATOR CAFIERO LET'S GO TO
YOUR- LEAD WITNESS IN- SUPPORT-
MADAM CHAIR IT'S THEIR THIRD
DECK DECK IT WITH THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA AND NICOLE WARDMAN
LEGISLATIVE ADDED ADVOCATE WITH
PRECISION PRECISION ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF SAN BERNADINO COUNTY
GRACE HERE IN PERSON RIGHT
EXCELLENT YOU GO HEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN SKINNER AND
MEMBERS- THE COLD WAR LIMON WITH
PRECISION ADVOCACY HERE ON
BEHALF OF SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY-
THIS WROTE THE PROUD SPONSOR OF
SB FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX. ILLEGAL
CANNABIS FARMS ARE A SERIOUS
GROWING THREAT IN ACROSS RURAL
AREAS OF CALIFORNIA. ILLEGAL
CANNABIS CULTIVATORS FREQUENTLY
ENGAGE IN HUMAN TRAFFICKING
WATER THEFT AND ENVIRONMENTAL
POLLUTION AS PART OF THEIR
pSEVERAL YEARS THOUSANDS OF
ILLEGAL GROWS HAVE POPPED UP IN
THE DESERT COMMUNITIES OF SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY. BECAUSE SOME
CULTIVATION SITES GO UNDETECTED
FOR YEARS THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DAMAGE COULD LAST GENERATIONS.
CALIFORNIA STATE PENALTIES ARE
NOT STRONG ENOUGH TO DETER THESE
LARGE SCALE CRIMINALS FROM
ENGAGING IN WIDESPREAD ILLICIT
CANNABIS FARMING NOR DO THEY
RECOGNIZE THE DANGER THAT THE
ILLEGAL THE ILLEGAL GROWS POST
TO THE ENVIRONMENT LONG TERM.
ILLEGAL CANNABIS FARMERS
FREQUENTLY BREAK WATER PIPES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE TO STEAL WATER OR
DIG ON PERMITTED ILLEGAL WELLS
TO TAP GROUNDWATER. ADDITIONALLY
THE WIDESPREAD USE OF DANGEROUS
AND DEADLY PESTICIDES ADOLESCENT
CANNABIS FARMS CAN BE LETHAL TO
BOTH HUMANS AND WILDLIFE POSING
IMMEDIATE AND LONG TERM RISKS TO
THOSE WORKING IN AND NEAR THE
SITE. IF YOU COULD WRAP UP
BECAUSE THE OTHER TO WITNESS YES
IT'S THEIR TIME YES TODAY WE'RE
ASKING YOU TO PASS SB. FOURTEEN
TWENTY SIX TO ASSIST IN
COMBATING THE DAMAGE DONE PAY
ILLICIT CULTIVATION IN OUR RURAL
COMMUNITIES. AS I HAVE THE SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY LEGISLATIVE
AND GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS.
MANAGER HERE IN CASE OF
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. THINGS WERE
GOING TO THE PHONE LINE FOR SIR
DO COULD FROM THE RURAL COUNTIES
REPRESENTATIVE CALIFORNIA GO
AHEAD. MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THIRTY CAT ON BEHALF OF THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THAT SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX. READING OF
THE CHEMICAL DIVISION AS A
PRIORITY FOR OUR THIRTY MEMBER
COUNTIES WE ARE FREQUENT CUT
TARGET OF A LARGE SCALE ILLEGAL
CANNABIS GROWS PROBABLY RELATED
HIT LEGAL CULTIVATION FROM WATER
FAST POPULOUS PLACED. AT SEVEN
FIVE RELY THERE'S TRASH DEBRIS
AND ESPECIALLY TO CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY HAS GREATLY INCREASED
OUR COUNTY THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
MANY COUNTY PLATE WITH A LOOK AT
CANNABIS CULTIVATION ARE ALSO IN
THE MIDST OF A DROUGHT EMERGENCY
REINFORCING THE NEED TO PROTECT
THE PLANET RESEARCH. FOR EXAMPLE
MENDOCINO COUNTY THE FIRST
CANDIDATE TO DECLARE A DROUGHT
IN TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY WANT. TO LOOK WATER ALL. FOR EXAMPLE
RIDE WITHOUT WATER TO WHICH IS
IN A MORE TO. I HAVE AN EMERGING
WATER. A STORY. I'LL LIMITATION
ON TO FIVE GALLON THE- IT'S FREE
. SUFFERING FROM WATER. YOU'RE
TAPPING INTO AND SIMILAR STORY
LIKE IF. ARE YOU COMMON ACROSS
THE NORTH COAST ALWAYS HEARING
ABOUT IT. CURRENT PENALTY EITHER
NOT TRY ENOUGH TO CRIME. FROM
ENGAGING IN Y. USE CAN FARMING.
AND DO NOT RECOGNIZE INJURIES
LOOK RATHER POSED TO SUPPLY. AND
GRAVEL POLLUTION. THE PRESIDENT
OF THE- WITH OUR COMMUNITY TO
MAKE PERMITTING CAN PRIME BURKE
. FOR THE PUBLIC AND FURTHER
HINDERS THE LEGAL INDUSTRY
ADDITIONAL TOOLS ARE NEEDED
PROTECT THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND FURTHER DISCOURAGE
ILLICIT CANNABIS OPERATORS.
STRENGTHENING THE MARKET FOR
THOSE WHO OPERATE LEGALLY
FEDERAL PENALTIES ARE IMPORTANT
STEPS THE PARALYMPIC CAN
AFFECTED EITHER A HARMFUL EFFECT
THEY'RE HAVING IN OUR LIMITED
WATER SPRITE THE PIPE. THEREFORE
WE HAVE OUR THERAPY I URGE AND
EITHER ON SB. FOURTEEN TWENTY
SIX THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT LET'S
SEE IF THERE'S ANY I WHICH- IN
SUPPORT IN THE YOU CAN UP TO
THE- TO THAT MICROPHONE INSECURE
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION.
ENTER MEMBERS- JULIUS AND
CHRISTIAN WITH SALMON IN THE
COMMISSION'S DEPARTMENT SUPPORT
BY ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. RIGHT SEEN ON IN THE
HEARING ROOM WILL GO TO THE
MODERATOR PLEASE MODERATOR QUEUE
UP ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
S. B- FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX. THANK
YOU IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. ME
JUST A MOMENT. APPOINT A LINE OF
ONE HUNDRED AND SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HM MEMBERS BACK ON THE
OFF THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION IN PART. THANK YOU
VERY ONE MOMENT FOR THE NEXT
PERSON. WHY FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD- YES HELLO MY NAME IS AN
ENGLISH MAJOR AND I AM WITH THE
MOJAVE WATER AGENCY. WE HAVE
BEEN SEVERELY AFFECTED BY YEAH
YES DO NAY. THE MOTION BEFORE IN
Q. GO AHEAD NEXT THE WITNESS.
ANY IF ANYONE ELSE IS IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. SO
WE JUST A MOMENT FOR THE NEXT
PERSON. IN A DIFFERENT TIME AND
THAT'S WHAT I WAS TRYING TO.
ONE OF ONE HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BY ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CLOTHING LINE NO RESPONSE. THIRTY OTHER LINES IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I'M SURE THERE ARE NO FOR THE
LINE TO SUPPORT SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY SIX PLEASE PROCEED GREAT
WILL NOW MOVE TOWARD LEAD
OPPOSITION AND WE HAVE LISTED IS
GENET. SANTA PARDON FROM THE
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE AND LESLIE
CALDWELL HOUSTON FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE SO GO AHEAD I'M
MODERATOR- ALLOW OUR LEAD
OPPOSITION TO TESTIFY. GOOD
MORNING KAREN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MANAGEMENT AND I THINK THAT GAME
AND I AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE
DIRECTOR. OF THE ALLIANCE I AM
HERE IN TESTIFIED RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION CASH D. TWELVE FORTY
SIX- IN LIGHT OF THE POTENTIAL
MET THE MAN MEANT THAT THE
AUTHOR HAD MENTIONED- WE HAVEN'T. SEEN THE AMENDMENT YEAH I'M
GONNA. I OPPOSITION TO THE
VERSION CAN PRINT- SB TWELVE
FORTY SIX- WOULDN'T AFFECT ME TO
SELL OFFENSE. GROUNDWATER AND
POLLUTION OF GROUNDWATER FOR THE
POPULATION OF CANNABIS THE NEW
OFFENSES WOULD BE PUNISHABLE BY
UP TO THREE YEARS IN PRISON EPA
IS A NATIONAL ORGANIZATION
PROMOTING DRUG POLICIES GRAVITY
I ASK THE QUESTION HEALTH AND
HUMAN RIGHTS. WE ARE VERY
SYMPATHETIC TO THE FIRE TO
PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT DURING
THE CULTIVATION OF CANNABIS BUT
USING CRIMINAL PENALTIES TO
ACHIEVE THAT IT WILL BE
INEFFECTIVE AND OFTEN
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE- AGAIN WE ARE
STOP IF YOU THE DIFFERENCE PLUS
THAT MECHANISM- OTHER THAN JUST
CRIMINAL LAW. EXISTING LAW
ALREADY PROVIDES A FELONY
OFFENSE FOR INTENTIONALLY PUBLIC
NEGLIGENCE CAUSING SUBSTANTIAL
ENVIRONMENTAL HARM TO THE PUBLIC
LANDS OR OTHER RESOURCES HE
ADDED LANGUAGE INFO FORTY
SIXTEEN TO LOWER THE BARCLAY NOT
REQUIRING ADDITIONAL. BARSANTI
CLOSE NEGLIGENT. THE CALIFORNIA
. CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES AS
AMENDED BY THE- REGULATED
ACTIVITIES THAT FAIR ONE. OR A
WOMAN A KNACK TABLE IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN. IT'S PAST IT IT WOULD
HAPPEN. DENTAL MORE. NEARLY
THREE POINT AND RECEIVED THAN
50% 7% OF VOTE SB TO SIX THE
TAKEAWAY. EXACTLY CLOUD ACT.
NINE ONE RESPONDED TO MY OFFENSE
WITH SO HE CAN AND THE SENSE
THAT. TELL VOTE IF THEY OVER
KIND TIME AGAIN. BECAUSE I WINE
HELD ONE GUY WE WERE PARK IN
CREATING NEW FELLOW. OUT ALONG
WITH A CLOUD POCKETS THAT COME
FELLING STEAK NOT ONLY BY THE
EIGHT. OF MULTIPLE LETTER
LECTURE IS SIMPLY PASSED POLICY
. PROVIDE PARTS OF THE WITH THE
CULTIVATION CANNABIS I'M NOT.
FICTION AND NEVER IN PENALTIES
RATHER THESE CONVICTS AND THEIR
OWN. DEVASTATING LAUDABLE.
PARTICULAR COMMUNITIES OF.
ADDITIONAL THIS WHAT IT PEOPLE
TO HIRE. YEAH INVOLVED GROWING
KIND OF ON THE FROM THE LIMIT.
IT WOULD AMOUNT A NET WIDENING
TO THAT LOCATION FOR THESE
REASONS- IT WOULD TAKE HEALTH
LONGER. EVEN IF THE DROP UP WITH
AN X. RAY WOULD HAVE TIME.
THE STRIKING OUT
OKAY NEXT- OPPOSITION WITNESS.
THE MORNING CHAIR AND COMMUNITY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION. BUT MUCH
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY FIFTH. WELL WE ARE. TO
THE GOLD PROTECTION ENVIRONMENT
PARTICULARLY IN THESE DIFFICULT
TIMES THROUGHOUT WE BELIEVE
USING CRIMINAL PENALTIES. TO
CHANGE THIS AND WILL BE IS IN
EFFECT. WE URGE THE USER THE
CRIMINAL IN THE PICTURE ROOM
SUPPORT THE USE OF OTHER
IMPORTANT NOW. TO PROTECT THE
GET THE ENVIRONMENT DURING THE
CULTIVATION OF CANNABIS. SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX SIXTY TAKE
OUR STATE BACK IN TIME- BACK TO
THE TIME THAT CALIFORNIA
RESPONDED TO MARIJUANA OFFENSES
WITH FELONY CENTERS IMPROVING
SENTENCES. IT MUST BE POINTED
OUT THE COULD NOT USUALLY THE
ONLY RESPONSIBLE. WOULD BE
ARRESTED IN THE SEARCH. RATHER
DAY LABOR. POOR PEOPLE
INVENTIONS. OR EVEN FLAVEL.
MINDING THE IN HIS OR HER. THE
PERSON WILL BE DEBT IF NOT
IMPOSSIBLE TO FIND LAW
ENFORCEMENT WELL. AWARE OF THIS
PROBLEM. CALIFORNIANS HAVE READ
. STATE THERE TO ANALYZE THE
UNDER WITH COURSE CREATING NEW
FELLA IS POLICY POLITE IN THE
FACE. OF THE PEOPLE STATED
POSITION. THE FIVE ALARM FIREMEN
ILL TO K. CULTIVATOR. CANNOT BE
A LA BY TELLING THEY CONVICTIONS
AND THEREFORE WE URGE YOUR NO
VOTE ON SB FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX
THANK YOU. ALRIGHT LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. GRADY
MAY TESTIFY- NAME AND
AFFILIATION. THANK YOU ARE NOT
SURE HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN OPPOSITION.
MANY OTHERS. RIGHT MODERATOR YOU
CAN QUEUE UP ANY- CALLERS IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR ANY CALLERS ON THE PHONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. BY SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EMILY WENDLER ON BEHALF OF THE
YOUNG WOMEN'S FREEDOM CENTER AND
SISTER WARRIORS FREEDOM
COALITION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. IF THERE ARE ANY OTHER
LINES IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX PLEASE PRESS
THE ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. THERE
ARE NO FURTHER LINES IN
OPPOSITION CONTINUE READING
CHAIR THANK YOU SO WILL NOW
RETURN TO THE- DIESS A TO SEE IF
WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS BY OUR MEMBERS GO AHEAD
SIR. I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- SO
FOR THE THANK YOU THE AUTHOR
FOR- ACCEPT ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS
TO. A REDUCES TO WOBBLER AND
ALSO TO SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF PLANTS. THROUGHOUT
SWEEPING UP THE YOU KNOW THE
SMALL. OF VIOLATORS- YOU'RE
NORMALLY- I DON'T YOUR TECHNICAL
SUPPORT BILLS THAT CREATE NEW
CRIMES- AND I DON'T BE HONEST I
DO HAVE SOME TREPIDATION ABOUT-
THIS BILL BECAUSE- YOU KNOW JUST
BECAUSE OF THE RISK OF. THIRTY
NINE YOU KNOW THE OWNERS- THE
KINGPINS WHO ARE BEING- ARRESTED
SOMETIMES IT'S THE SORT OF MORE
<c.cyan>RONT LINE. OF FOLKS WHO ARE</c>
UNFORTUNATE ENOUGH TO BE LIKE.
TENDING THE PLANTS OR OR OR
WHATEVER- SO I DO HAVE CONCERNS
I'LL BE HONEST- I ALSO THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE- IN VARIOUS
PARTS OF THE STATE WITH THESE
ILLEGAL GROWS THAT ARE REALLY.
DEEPLY DESTRUCTIVE
ENVIRONMENTALLY- REALLY REALLY
REALLY HARMFUL AND BAD- SO THIS
KIND OF BEHAVIOR IS NOT. IT'S
NOT YOU KNOW HARM US IT'S
REALLY- IT'S JUST CAUSING A LOT
OF- ENVIRONMENTAL DEGRADATION IN
VARIOUS PARTS OF THE STATE- SO I
WILL- SUPPORT MOVING THE BILL
OUT OF COMMITTEE TODAY WITH
THOSE ON AMENDMENTS.
UNDERSTANDING THAT I HOPE THAT
YOU'LL CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
AS IT MOVES THROUGH THE-
PROCESS. I DO I WOULD BE REMISS
IF I ABOUT THIS OPPORTUNITY- GO
BY JUST- REMIND PEOPLE THAT THE
REASON THAT THESE ILLEGAL GROWS
EXISTEN ARE PROLIFERATING SO
MUCH. IS BECAUSE DESPITE THE
CLEAR WILL OF THE VOTERS- THAT
CANNABIS IS TO BE A LEGAL
PRODUCT BOTH MEDICINALLY AND FOR
ADULT USE- WE HAVE AND- YOU KNOW
THE FACT THAT. WHAT SIXTY FOUR
ENTRUSTED CITIES TO BE
RESPONSIBLE ACTORS IN REGULATING
CANNABIS SALES ON THE VAST
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
62% TO BE PRECISE. CATEGORICALLY
BANNED ANY AT ALL SALE OF
CANNABIS SO IT'S LEGAL FOR
PEOPLE TO USE CANNABIS TO
POSSESS A- BUT YOU CAN'T LEGALLY
BUY IT ANYWHERE. IT'S A STUPID
SYSTEM I'M SORRY IT'S JUST A
TERRIBLE HORRIBLE SYSTEM WE'RE
SAYING- YEAH WE'RE WE'RE
LEGALIZING CANNABIS FOR MEDICINE
FOR OTHER USE BUT WE'RE GONNA
ACTUALLY JUST MAKE IT LOOK
ILLEGAL TO ACTUALLY HAVE A LEGAL
MARKET IN THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THE STATE. HI AND THEN ON TOP OF
IT WE PUT HUGE TAXES ON THE
LEGAL MARKET. AND WE CREATE A
HUGE INCENTIVES FOR THE ILLICIT
MARKET TO FLOURISH BECAUSE WE
MAKE IT SO EXPENSIVE FOR
LEGITIMATE OPERATORS TO OPERATE
AND MAKE THE PRODUCT REALLY
EXPENSIVE. SO WE SET UP A
HORRIBLE SYSTEM THAT FUELS THE
ILLICIT MARKET WHICH INCLUDES
ILLEGAL GROWS AND WE NEED TO FIX
THAT AND WE HAVE SOME BILLS THIS
YEAR. TO TRY TO START MOVING IN
THAT DIRECTION- AND I AM
SYMPATHETIC TO WHAT FOR EXAMPLE
RC RC WAS SAYING BUT OUR CRC IS
ALSO OPPOSING EFFORTS. TO TRY TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO MEDICAL
CANNABIS IN CALIFORNIA SO
ENCOURAGE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS NOT
JUST TO BE UPSET ABOUT ILLEGAL
GROWS BUT TO ALSO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION AND THE STOP
OBSTRUCTING THE LEGAL SALE OF
CANNABIS. THANK YOU. I THINK FOR
THE FIRST TIME I FEEL LIKE I
NEED TO HUG SENATOR WIENER.
SUPPORTING THE BILL PUBLIC
SAFETY BUT I WILL A THE CORE IN
THE COMMITTEE ON THAT END- THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY SPEAK AS
SOMEONE DO YOU KNOW COUNTY IS A
DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT I'M
ACUTELY AWARE OF THIS ISSUE IS
ILLEGAL CANNABIS GROW CANNABIS
GROWERS ARE AN ISSUE FACING MANY
OTHER CITIES AND THEY ARE
DIRECTLY IMPACTING THE HEALTH OF
OUR COMMUNITIES. THE UNREGULATED
USE OF PESTICIDES ON THESE GROW
SITES IS POLLUTING OUR
GROUNDWATER WHICH IS HAS WHICH
HAS A DETRIMENTAL EFFECT ON THE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND USUALLY IN THE
MOST RURAL PARTS OF OUR OF
CALIFORNIA THE EXPANSION OF THE
PENALTIES RELATING TO ILLEGAL
GROW SITES AND THE TOPPING OVER
GROUNDWATER WILL BE BETTER
EQUIPPED AT WILL BETTER EQUIP
LAW ENFORCEMENT WITH THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED TO
COMBAT THESE ILLEGAL OPERATIONS.
WHEN WE CONSIDER THE INTENSE
DROUGHT FACING CALIFORNIA THESE
GROW SITES ALSO POSE A RISK TO
OUR GROUND- AB- WATER MANAGEMENT
AS THEIR E. LEGALLY SIPHONING
LARGE QUANTITIES OF OUR
GROUNDWATER FOR THEIR OWN
REGULATED USE UNREGULATED USE
I'M SORRY. THE LEGAL TOPPING OUR
GROUNDWATER IN THE DUMPING OF
PESTICIDES BY ILLEGAL CANNABIS
GROW SITES IS PERTINENT AND
DANGEROUS ISSUE FACING OUR
ECONOMY AND OUR COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
ESPECIALLY THE INLAND EMPIRE-
BUT I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO NOTE.
THAT IT IS ALSO- IN A VERY IF.
THE ACTUAL LAND ITSELF NOT JUST
THE GROUND WATER ON THAT END AND
HAVING HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TOWARDS SOME OF THE SITES I CAN
TELL YOU THAT IS- IT IS
HEARTENING IT'S ALSO
DISHEARTENING IN THE FACT THAT
THEY CAN COME BACK OVER AND OVER
AGAIN QUITE- OFTEN IT JUST BY
THE NEXT WEEK. IS ACTUALLY ALSO
VERY TROUBLESOME SO THANK YOU
SENATOR A COUPLE YEAR FOR TAKING
THE LEAD ON THIS ISSUE AND I'M
SO GRATEFUL THAT YOU DID. AND I
A WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL.
THANK YOU- FOR WE GO TO- YOUR
CLOTHES I HAVE SOME COMMENTS-
WEEK THE DIFFICULTY WITH THIS
BILL FOR ME IS THAT WE HAVE
EXISTING- CRIMINAL STATUTE FOR
THE POLLUTING OF THE GROUND
WATER OR THE POLLUTING OF THE
SOIL FOR YOU KNOW FROM THE
PESTICIDE USE AND SUCH AND THE
WHAT THIS BILL IS FOCUSED ON IS
THE STEALING OF THE GROUNDWATER
NOW STEALING A GROWN ORDERS
SERIOUS. AND IS A FORMER
DIRECTOR OF THE EAST BAY REAP
REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT WHICH HAS
A HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES OF OPEN
SPACE WE HAD A LOT OF ILLEGAL
GROWS WE DID AND SO WE- BUT
UNFORTUNATELY MOST OF THE TIME.
WHEN WE WOULD- WHEN OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT WOULD GO TO THOSE
GROWS EITHER THERE WASN'T THERE
WAS NO ONE THERE AND IT WAS
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO EVER TRACE
WHO ACTUALLY OPERATED TO GROW OR
IF THERE WAS SOMEONE THERE IT
WAS SOMEONE IT WAS. INTERNET
ANALOGOUS TO SORT OF THE STREET.
THE PERSON ON THE STREET TO
SELLING THE DRUG IT'S NOT THE
PERSON THAT THAT PERSON WHO IS
AT THE GROW IS JUST YOU KNOW
FIRST UNFORTUNATELY. BEING PAID
BY SOMEBODY TO TENDED VERSES
THAT THEY SET UP THE GROW. AND
SO MY CONCERN. I'VE YOU KNOW I
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS BUT MY
CONCERN IS THAT WE WILL. BE ONCE
AGAIN. ENFORCING THE LAW ON
REALLY- IT PERIPHERAL CHARACTERS
COMPARED TO THE ACTUAL PEOPLE
WHO ARE TAPPING INTO GROUNDWATER
IN CAUSING THE ILLEGAL GROW. AND
THAT'S WHAT'S SO DIFFICULT IN
THESE CIRCUMSTANCES HOWEVER AND
WE HAVE BEEN STOPPING MANY MANY
BILLS YOU KNOW FOR EXAMPLE ONE
FEDERAL FOR EXACTLY THAT REASON
BECAUSE TO JUST TWO. HITS LIKE
AND THAT YOU CAN TAKE ALL THE
LOS STREET DEALERS OFF AND YET
YOU'RE STILL GOING TO HAVE THIS
EVENT- IT'S SO CHEAP IT'S SO. AT
THE BIG QUANTITY YOU NEED TO SO
TINY YOU KNOW THERE YOU JUST
KEEP FILL IT YOU KNOW THERE'S
ANOTHER ANOTHER ENTITY WHAT WILL
COME IN AND SELL IT UNLESS WE
CAN GET AT THE ACTUAL
MANUFACTURERS OF IT OR THE- OR
THE ORGANIZERS OF THE- YOU KNOW
PICKING PENCE'S THEY SAY. NOW
THE TWO HERE AND THE REASON THAT
I BE WILLING TO MAKE THE
EXCEPTION IS THAT WE HAVE
LEGALIZED MARIJUANA. AND SO.
THERE IS IT THAT REALLY THERE IS
NO REASON TO HAVE ILLEGAL GROWS
. AND BUT I AGREE WITH SENATOR
WIENER. ANY COUNTY THAT SUPPORTS
THIS BILL BETTER MAKE IT LEGALLY
AVAILABLE TO BUY CANNABIS IN
THEIR AREA BECAUSE WE HAVE OUR
VERY OWN. LEGAL LAW HAS
ENCOURAGED THE ILLICIT BUSINESS.
AND IT IS FOR THOSE PEOPLE THAT
ARE PLAYING BY THE RULES THEY
ARE BEING PUNISHED NOW THE
ENTITIES THAT ARE OPERATING
LEGAL GROWS. SO THIS IS WHY I AM
WILLING TO MAKE THAT EXCEPTION
I'M STILL UNCOMFORTABLE WITH IN
EFFECT YOU KNOW HAVING ANYBODY
EVEN THOSE A WAFFLER GET A
DOUBLE FELONY WHO IS JUST STATE
REALLY MAKE A MINOR PARTICIPANT-
AND- MAYBE I'M DOING A WILLING
SUSPENSION OF DISBELIEF THE
HOPING THAT DA'S WOULD. RESHAPE
THOSE CANISTER. AND NOT CHARGE
THE FULL FELONY. ARMED AND YOU
KNOW WE COULD GO ON THE ROUTE
OF. TRYING TO ADD JUST MORE-
FEES CIVIL PENALTIES VERSUS A
CRIME BUT HOWEVER AGAIN IF IT'S
A FIT PLAYER THEY DON'T HAVE THE
MONEY TO PAY IT ANYWAY SO THIS
IS ALL TRICKY. BUT IT IS THE
CASE THAT THIS IS A LEGAL. DRUG
AND WE HAVE TO DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO DISCOURAGE ANYTHING THAT
IS UNDERMINING THE LEGAL- OUR
LEGAL MARKET PLACE. SO I WILL
SUPPORT IT AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS AND-
GO AHEAD YES I KNOW I JUST WANT
TO CLARIFY IF I AM AT THE
MEMBERS WILL BE TAKEN AND THE
NEXT COMMITTEE AND NOT. HERE
BECAUSE- THAT IT IS A WOBBLER
AND THAT THE THRESHOLD OF PLANTS
IS GOING TO BE FIFTY OR ABOVE.
CORRECT SO ANY OTHER COMMENT
BEFORE GO AHEAD SIR. AND I'M
SORRY TO SEE THE STRESS AGAIN
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THE US
BECAUSE PEOPLE SHOULD BE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THIS
ENVIRONMENTAL DESTRUCTION.
HOWEVER THIS WILL BE ABLE IT WAS
JUST KEEP HAPPENING THESE GROWTH
WILL JUST BE REPLACED BY NEW
ILLEGAL GROWS UNTIL THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA STARTS ALLOWING LEGAL
OPERATIONS OF CANNABIS EVERY
ROUTE THE STATE. AND HAD NOT
HAVING THESE HUGE SWATHS WERE IT
IS. EFFECTIVELY ILLEGAL- AND SO
OF COURSE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO DO
IT ILLEGALLY AND DESTROY THE
ENVIRONMENT. GOOD CENTER. AND I
ALSO JUST WANT TO ADD YOU KNOW
IT'S NOT JUST THAT BUT IT'S
GETTING OUR ACT TOGETHER WITH
THE REGULATED MARKET PLACE AND
ALL OF AND DRIVES SENATOR KABIR
ON I SAID ON THE SAME COMMITTEE
AND WE HAVE HEARD. A NUMBER OF
PANELISTS TALK ABOUT HOW
CHALLENGING IT IS- IN THIS
PARTICULAR SPACE. YOU ARE
CERTAINLY ENCOURAGING THIS KIND
OF ACTIVITY UNTIL WE GET A
COMPREHENSIVE REALISTIC HOLISTIC
APPROACH TO THIS MARKET. AND HOW
WE WOW WE ALLOW HOW WE REGULATE
HOW WE ENFORCE WHAT REAL
IMPLEMENTATION LOOKS LIKE SO
THAT EVERYONE FEELS LIKE IF THEY
WANT TO PARTICIPATE THEY CAN IN
A WAY THAT MAKES SENSE. AND
WITHOUT IT CONSUMERS WILL
CONTINUE TO DO WHAT THEY WANT TO
DO AND THERE WILL BE- A DEMAND
FOR THAT IN THE UNREGULATED
ILLEGAL MARKET. DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. SOME OF. ALL RIGHT AND
WITH THE CAVEATS THAT I
DESCRIBED AND ALSO THE- AUTHOR
DID. ALL RIGHT- BROKE OFF. SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY SIXTY PASSED TO
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WILDLIFE
pBOGUE I TROUBLE GUY COME LONGER
. KAMLAGER I WINNER WINNER I'D
FORTY ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU- THE BILL'S ALTO THINK
THAT'S OUR FIRST BILL OUT MAYBE
I DON'T KNOW- LET'S WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE A BREAK FOR CAUCUS AND
COME BACK AND RESUME LET'S JUST
GET THE ROLL CALL ON ALL THE
OUTSTANDING ITEMS THAT WE HAVE
SO FAR. GO AHEAD- MISPRINTS S.
B. TEN THIRTY FOUR ATKINS WIENER
. THIRTY FOUR THIRTEEN OF. IT'S
TEN THIRTY FOUR ITS FOURTH- IT'S
AT THE ATKINS AS FEW PEOPLE TOM
WIENER WIENER I IT'S THAT'S FOUR
ZERO OR EIGHT ZERO S. B. TEN
THIRTY FOUR IST OUT FOUR ZERO
I'M NEXT BILL- SB THIRTEEN
THIRTY THREE BATES- WIENER.
THIRTY THREE YES OFF NO WINNER
NO THE VOTE IS ONE TO ONE SHE
REQUESTED RECONSIDERATION S. B.
THIRTEEN THIRTY THREE IS- FAILS. ONE TO ONE AND DISCOURAGES
RECONSIDERATION. SB NINE TWENTY
FIVE BATES THE VOTES THREE TO
ZERO WIENER. FIVE WINNER I'D
REYES IS ORDER THE NINE TO FIVE
IS OUT OF VOTE FOUR ZERO. I
DON'T. NINE OH FOUR WAS PULLED.
YES HE DOES PHAM. S. B. EIGHT
TWENTY POURTANT. COMMA PROVIDER
A WINNER WINNER AYE THAT IS WHAT
HERE- MANY NINE IS OUT FOUR
ZERO. THAT IS- IT MORE- IT FORTY
S. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN A TO
A BOGUS COM LOGGER. YEAH
KAMLAGER. FORTY S. THIRTEEN
TWENTY IS OUT FOUR ZERO THE
COMMITTEE IS NOW AND WE WILL
RETURN TO THIS VERY LOCATION AT
ONE THIRTY AND THREE. REALLY-
CONVENE AND- DO THE REST OF THE
BILL WHICH FORTUNATELY ARE NOT
WE'RE RECONVENING AT PUBLIC
SAFETY. WELCOME SENATOR GROWTH
YOU MAY PRESENT SENATE BILL TEN
FORTY TWO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. SENATE BILL TEN
FORTY TWO IS A BI PARTISAN OR
BIPARTISAN MEASURE THAT IS JOINT
AUTHORED BY SENATOR CAFIERO AND
CO AUTHORED BY EIGHT SENATORS N.
THIRTEEN ASSEMBLY MEMBERS. OUR
BILL WOULD INCLUDE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IN THE LIST OF
CRIMES THAT ARE DEFINED AS
SERIOUS AND VIOLENT UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW MAKING THE CRIME
AND A STRIKE UNDER THE THREE
STRIKES LAW. THE FASTEST GROWING
CRIMINAL INDUSTRY IN THE WORLD
IS THE BUYING AND SELLING OF
HUMAN BEINGS. IN CALIFORNIA IS
ONE OF THE LARGEST HUBS FOR
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. DATA FROM
SERVICE PROVIDERS IN THE U. S.
NATIONAL HUMAN TRAFFICKING
HOTLINE HAS CONSISTENTLY SHOWN
THAT GROUPS WHO EXPERIENCE
MARGINALIZATION OR MARGINALIZED
BY RACE INCOME GENDER IDENTITY
SEXUAL ORIENTATION OR
IMMIGRATION STATUS THEY ARE MORE
LIKELY TO BE EXPLOITED THROUGH
SEX AND LABOR TRAFFICKING. THE
INTERNATIONAL LABOR ORGANIZATION
ESTIMATES THAT IN THE LAST
DECADE THERE WERE MORE THAN
FORTY MILLION HUMAN TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS WORLDWIDE. OF THAT TOTAL
25% WERE CHILDREN AND 75% WERE
WOMEN AND GIRLS LET THAT SINK IN
FOR JUST A MINUTE. THAT'S AN
ESTIMATED THIRTY MILLION WOMEN
AND GIRLS THAT ARE VICTIMS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. CURRENTLY
THERE ARE FORTY TWO CRIMES THAT
ARE DEFINED AS SERIOUS AND
TWENTY THREE CRIMES THAT ARE
DEFINED AS VIOLENT UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW. TODAY IN
CALIFORNIA LAW ROBBERY IS A
VIOLENT FELONY SOMEBODY CAN WALK
INTO A BANK HAD A NOTE TO THE
TELLER DEMANDING THE MONEY IN
THEIR CASH DRAWER AND THAT IS
CONSIDERED A SERIES OF VIOLENT
FELONY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. BUT SEX TRAFFICKING
A CHILD IS NOT. TODAY IN
CALIFORNIA CARJACKING IS LISTED
AS A SERIOUS FELONY AND
RIGHTFULLY SO BUT THE ACT OF
SELLING A HUMAN BEING IS NOT. SP
TEN FORTY TWO WILL HELP
STRENGTHEN PROTECTIONS FOR THE
MILLIONS OF VICTIMS OF SEX AND
LABOR TRAFFICKING TO SERVE AS A
DETERRENT FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
WISH TO PERPETRATE THIS
HORRENDOUS CRIME. ALWAYS I CAN
TELL YOU THIS IS THE HARDEST
BILL THAT MY STAFF AND I HAVE
EVER RESEARCHED THE STORIES OF
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN THAT ARE
TRAFFICKED ON A DAILY BASIS ARE
ALMOST TOO MUCH TO BEAR- TALLY
AND IN HUMANITY OF THESE
VICTIMS. AND WHAT THEY ENDORSE
SOMETHING OUT OF A HORROR MOVIE
. YOUR INCH COUNTY HUMAN
TRAFFICKING TASK FORCE RECENTLY
SHARED A STORY FROM ONE OF THEIR
HUMAN TRAFFICKING INVESTIGATIONS
IN WHICH TWO FEMALE THAT VICTIMS
WERE HELD CAPTIVE INSIDE OF THE
BED FRAME. AT A MOTEL AFTER
ATTEMPTING TO RUN AWAY THEY WERE
BEING TRAFFICKED FOR COMMERCIAL
SEX IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. THE
TRAFFICKERS PLACE THE MATTRESS
BACK ON TOP OF THE BED FRAME AS
THEY SLEPT TO KEEP THEM FROM
ESCAPING. THE VICTIMS WERE LEFT
NAKED WITH WATER POURED OVER
THEM IN THE AIR CONDITIONING
DOWN TO A FREEZING LEVEL FORCED
TO URINATE THEM ON THEMSELVES
AND HAD CEREAL CHEERIOS THROWN
AT THEM TO EAT OFF THE FLOOR.
THE VIOLENCE AND TORTURED
TORTURE THAT IS ENDORSED BY
THESE VICTIMS ALSO INCLUDED RAPE
SODOMY AND BEATINGS. ONE OF THE
FEMALE VICTIMS AS RAPE WITH A
GUN HELD TO YOUR MOUTH. THE
VICTIMS WERE FORCED TO STAY
INSIDE THE BED FRAME WHILE
WAITING FOR THE SEX PURCHASERS
ANSWERING ADS THAT WERE POSTED
ONLINE. ART FROM THE PHYSICAL
ABUSE ONE VICTIM HAD MEDICAL
COMPLICATIONS DUE TO MAKEUP
SPONGES BEING INSERTED INTO HER
VAGINAL CANAL DURING THE
MENSTRUAL CYCLE AS PART OF THE
WORK MANTRA FROM RETRACTING
TRAFFICKER IT SAYS NO DAYS OFF.
WHICH IS COMMON FOR VICTIMS OF
SEX TRAFFICKING. IN JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO FOX ELEVEN
NEWS IN LOS ANGELES SHARED A
STORY OF A SIXTEEN YEAR OLD
SIMONE WHO WAS KIDNAPPED AND
TRAFFICKED BY A MAN SHE JUST
MET. SIMONE WAS IMMEDIATELY
TAKEN INTO A HOTEL WHERE OTHER
WOMEN WERE BEING HELD. AND SHE
WAS FORCED TO SELL HER BODY.
SOMEONE SAYS A TRAFFICKER WARNED
HER THAT IF SHE TRIED TO ESCAPE
HE WOULD KILL HER MOTHER AND HER
GRANDMOTHER. SIMONE WAS
FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO ESCAPE AFTER
MAKING A CALL TO HER MOTHER AND
HER KID WINNER CAPTIVES CAPTORS
GUARD WAS DOWN. SHE DIDN'T KNOW
WHERE SHE WAS WHERE SHE WAS THAT
SHE TOLD HER MOM I CAN SEE A
SEVEN ELEVEN. ENTIRE FAMILY
SEARCH DIFFERENT LOCATIONS UNTIL
THE FOUNDER OUTSIDE OF THAT
SEVEN ELEVEN. SIMONE IS NOW A
CRISIS INTERVENTIONAL LIST
INTERVENTIONIST AT THE TEAM
PROJECT THE NONPROFIT THAT HELPS
SURVIVORS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING%
IN LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA. THE
TOOL IS A YOUNG INDONESIAN WOMAN
WHO WAS UNKNOWINGLY SOLD TO
TRAFFICKERS AS A DOMESTIC
SERVANT A MODERN DAY SLAVE
TRAPPED IN A HOME IN LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA SHE WORKED DAILY TILL
TEN OR ELEVEN PM. SHE SLEPT ON
THE FLOOR OF THE TV ROOM SHE
ROSE EVERY COUPLE OF HOURS TO
TAKE CARE OF THE CAPTORS BABY
INCH SHE AND BEFORE EVERY
MORNING SHE WOKE UP AND HAD
BREAKFAST READY. THE ABUSE FROM
HER SLAVE HOLDER ALSO KNOWN AS
THE MATRIARCH OF THE FAMILY
ULTIMATELY TURNED PHYSICAL AND
MENTAL FOUND HERSELF. IN A
HOSPITAL EMERGENCY ROOM YET SHE
HAD NOWHERE TO ESCAPE SHE HAD NO
MONEY HE SPOKE LIMITED ENGLISH
AND- SHE HAD SPOKE LIMITED
ENGLISH. PROTECTING THEIR
INVESTMENT THE COUPLE PURCHASED
WHO PURCHASED METAL HAD
INTIMIDATED HER WITH THE THREAT
OF JAIL IF SHE EVER DARED TO
RENT. HEN THE VIOLENCE WORSENED
IN YEAR THREE MY TOOL MANAGED TO
WRITE A NOTE TO THE NANNY NEXT
DOOR THAT SHE HAD GOTTEN TO KNOW
WHICH SIMPLY READ. PLEASE HELP
ME. HUMAN TRAFFICKING SURVIVOR
SUCH AS THESE COMMUNITY GROUPS
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM ACROSS THE
STATE HAVE STOOD IN SUPPORT OF
SB TEN FORTY TWO. IN FEBRUARY OF
THIS YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TO THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT. PARTICIPATED IN AN
OPERATION RECLAIM AND REBUILD
WHICH RESULTED IN THE ARREST OF
THIRTY TRAFFICKERS. LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SHERIFF BILL IN A WAY
THAT HAS SPOKEN OUT IN SUPPORT
OF SB TEN FORTY TWO. HIS QUOTE
WAS THIS BILL WILL FIGHT TO
PROTECT VICTIMS STRENGTHEN
PREVENTION AND INCREASE THE
PROSECUTION OF THOSE WHO BUY AND
SELL HUMAN BEINGS. WHEN DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ACROSS THE STATE ARE
TELLING US LEGISLATORS THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE THE TOOLS IN THEIR
TOOLBOX TO PROPERLY PERFORM
THEIR JOB. IT'S TIME FOR US IS
LAWMAKERS TO DO OUR JOB. IT'S
TIME FOR US TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE THE PROPER THE
PROPERLY A PROPER TOOLS IN THEIR
TOOLBOX TO PROSECUTE THESE TOP
CRIMES. PASSING SB TEN FORTY TWO
WILL SERVE TO PROTECT FUTURE
GENERATIONS BY STOPPING PEOPLE
FROM ENGAGING IN THIS CRIME
TODAY. S. B. TEN FORTY TWO IS
RECEIVED OVER FIFTY LETTERS OF
SUPPORT FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES DISTRICT ATTORNEYS AND
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS
THE- WE INTERNATIONAL. CRIME
VICTIMS UNITED ALLIANCE AGAINST
FAMILY VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY
CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA. IN
ADDITION MY OFFICE HAS RECEIVED
NEARLY THREE THOUSAND LETTERS OF
SUPPORT FROM EVERYDAY
CALIFORNIANS THAT JUST WANT TO
SEE HUMAN TRAFFICKING PROPERLY
DEFINED AS SERIOUS AND VIOLENT.
ELIZABETH SMART HAS ENDORSED
THIS BILL STATING THAT HAS TO BE
TEN FORTY TWO SHOULD BE PASSED
INTO LAW WITHOUT HESITATION. TOO
MANY VICTIMS FEAR COMING FORWARD
SPEAKING OUT FOR FEAR OF THEIR
TRAFFICKERS REPERCUSSIONS TOO
OFTEN THEY ARE RETRICTED IN
THEIR EFFORTS TO SERVE JUSTICE
AND FAR TOO OFTEN VICTIMS AND
SURVIVORS NEVER EVEN GET A
GLIMPSE AT JUSTICE. TRAFFICKING
IS A HEINOUS AND BRUTAL CRIME
THANKFULLY MANY OF US WILL NEVER
HAVE TO EXPERIENCE THIS IS A
SMALL STEP THAT WE CAN TAKE TO
BEGIN PROTECTING OUR SURVIVORS
IN PROCRIT PROCRIT. SOME SMALL
MODERN FORM OF JUSTICE.
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THE STATE
HAVE SHARED THEIR PERSONAL
STORIES AND VOICED VOICE THEIR
SUPPORT FOR S. B. THIRTEEN FORTY
TWO. BUT HERE WITH ME TO SHARE
THEIR TESTIMONY DIRECTLY OURTWO
EXPERTS IN THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING
FIELD. FULLY ENTRENCHED IN
COMBATING HUMAN TRAFFICKING
OAKLAND DISTRICT ATTORNEY NANCY
O'MALLEY'S OFFICE HAS PROSECUTED
MORE THAN EIGHT HUNDRED HUMAN
SEX TRAFFICKING CASES A MAJORITY
OF WHICH HAVE INVOLVED MINOR
FEMALE VICTIMS DEAL MALLEY HAS
HANDLED NUMEROUS CASES IN WHICH
THE VICTIMS WERE MURDERED.
PHYSICALLY ABUSED
PSYCHOLOGICALLY TERRORIZED
MANIPULATED AND COERCED AND LEFT
TO DEAL WITH THE TRAGIC
AFTERMATH OF BEING SEX
TRAFFICKED. TRAFFIC WE ARE
PLEASED TO HAVE D. E. O. MALLEY
TESTIFY FIRST IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE. ADDITIONALLY IN ORDER
TO SHINE A LIGHT ON THIS ISSUE
WITH FIRST HAND KNOWLEDGE MY
SECOND WITNESS IS A CONSTITUENT
OF MINE IN MY DISTRICT THAT IS A
HUMAN TRAFFICKING SURVIVOR
SURVIVOR MISS ODESSA PERKINS-
I'M SO SORRY WITH EVERYTHING
THAT'S HAPPENED TODAY IN THE
DELAY IN THE COMMITTEE I
COMPLETELY FORGOT AND IT'S I DO
APOLOGIZE PLEASE ACCEPT MY
SINCERE APOLOGY WE HAVE A OUR
JOINT AUTHOR. IS GOING TO MAKE A
STATEMENT. ABSOLUTELY NO NO
PROBLEM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY A FEW BRIEF
WORDS- CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE
LARGEST SITES FOR HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IN THE UNITED
STATES. HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AFFECTS WOMEN CHILDREN MEN
PEOPLE OF COLOR IMMIGRANTS AND
THE LGBTQ PLUS COMMUNITY ANYONE
WHO IS VULNERABLE. S. B. TEN
FORTY TWO ADS HUMAN TRAFFICKING
TO THE LIST OF SERIOUS AND
VIOLENT CRIMES IN THE PENAL CODE
AND IT STRIKE FOR THE PURPOSES
OF THE THREE STRIKES LAW. IT IS
LONG OVERDUE FOR CALIFORNIA TO
RECOGNIZE THEIR THEIR HORRENDOUS
PAIN IN HUMAN SUFFERING AND THE
LONG TERM DEVASTATION AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL TRAUMA OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING ANDDO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT. AS A JOINT AUTHOR OF
THIS MEASURE MEASURE TODAY I ASK
FOR YOUR IPHONE THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY A FEW WORDS.
THANK YOU MA'AM DISTRICT
ATTORNEY O'MALLEY PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATORS AND THANK YOU
SENATOR GROWN CENTER CAMEO FOR
YOU'RE YOU'RE REALLY REMARKABLE
WORDS DESCRIBING THIS INSIDIOUS
CRIME OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING. I AM
THE CREATOR OF WHAT WE CALL HE'D
WATCH HEAT MEANS HUMAN
EXPLOITATION AND TRAFFICKING AND
HE WATCHES A FIVE PRONGED
COMMUNITY BLUEPRINT SO
COMMUNITIES SUCH AS MY OWN IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY. CAN I HAVE A
STRATEGIC A FORMULA FOR CREATING
THEIR OWN EFFORTS TO COMBAT
HUMAN TRAFFICKING HE WATCHES
BEEN ADOPTED THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES AND BY THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. AND THEIR HUMAN
TRAFFICKING DIVISION I ALSO HAVE
A FOUNDATION WHICH IS CALLED THE
HEAT INSTITUTE. AND HE INSTITUTE
OF FOCUSES ON RESEARCH AND
STUDYING ROOT CAUSES OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING THE IMPACT OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AS WELL AS THE
MENTALITY AND THE PSYCHOLOGY OF
A TRAFFICKER. AND A PURCHASER.
WE HAVE A PUBLISHED DOCUMENTS
FOR SURE AND ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT DOCUMENTS I BELIEVE WE
HAVE PUBLISHED. IS A DOCUMENT
THAT THAT EVALUATES THE
DIFFERENT THERAPEUTIC MODALITIES
THAT ARE EFFECTIVE IN HELPING
HUMAN TRAFFICKING VICTIMS
SURVIVORS RECOVER FROM THEIR
TRAUMA AND BE ABLE TO HEAL FROM
THE INJURIES THAT THEY'VE
SUFFERED. I'VE WORKED ON THESE
ISSUES AROUND HUMAN TRAFFICKING
SINCE MY VERY FIRST CASE IN
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN. WHEN I
HAD A THE VICTIM WAS IN TWELVE
YEARS OLD. SHE WAS BEING
TRAFFICKED BY A THIRTY NINE YEAR
OLD MAN AND WHEN THE POLICE WERE
ABLE TO INTERVENE AND RESCUE HER
SHE WAS BEING RAPED BY A PERSON
WHO PAID. TO RAPE HER WHO IS
FIFTY YEARS OLD. I PROSECUTED
BOTH THE TRAFFICKER AND THE
PURCHASER BUT IN THOSE DAYS WE
DID NOT HAVE A CRIME OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING WE DIDN'T HAVE A
TERM CALLED HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
SO IT'S BEEN MY EFFORTS EVER
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN TO
REALLY CHANGE THE PARADIGM OF
CALIFORNIA AROUND HOW WE VIEW
HUMAN TRAFFICKING HOW WE USE TO
JUDGE SO HARSHLY VICTIMS AND
BLAME THEM FOR THEIR SITUATION.
AND HOW WE HAVE DONE SO MUCH IN
OUR COMMUNITY AND TO OUR LAWS TO
REALLY CHANGE THAT PARADIGM. I
WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND
FOR ME WHAT WE CALL HEAT WE'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT ADULT. PEOPLE
WHO ARE ENGAGING IN COMMERCIAL
SEX THAT'S A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT SITUATION FOR MOST
THERE ARE ADULTS WHO HAVE BEEN
TRAFFICKED SINCE CHILDHOOD. HAVE
GROWN INTO CONTINUING THAT-
COMMERCIAL SEX BUT WE'RE REALLY
FOCUSING ON THOSE THAT ARE
BEING. LURED INTO A TRAFFICKING
ENVIRONMENT WHO ARE BEING HELD
IN SLAVERY AND LET'S BE CLEAR
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS MODERN DAY
SLAVERY. WE WORKED VERY HARD TO
BRING ATTENTION TO HUMAN
TRAFFICKING NOT ONLY IN
CALIFORNIA BUT ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY. EVERY STATE IN THE
UNION HAS NOW IDENTIFIED HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AS ONE OF THE MAJOR
CRIMES IN THEIR STATE. WE HAVE
WORKED VERY HARD ALSO TO BUILD A
JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT RECOGNIZES
THE DEEP PSYCHOLOGICAL IMPACT OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING THE PHYSICAL
ABUSE THAT GOES ON THAT IS SO- I
MEAN THE THEY ARE ALL YOU CAN
SAY IT'S THE MOST INHUMANE
TREATMENT OF INDIVIDUALS OF
HUMAN BEINGS. AND WE HAVE LOOKED
AT THE NUMBER OF TRAFFICKED
VICTIMS WHO HAVE BEEN KILLED.
SOME BY THE TRAFFICKER SOME BY
THE PURCHASER. I ALSO WANT TO
BRING TO THE ATTENTION OF THE
COMMITTEE THE RESEARCH THAT'S
BEING DONE NOT JUST AROUND HOW
WHAT'S HAPPENING AND WHAT THE
IMPACT THE LIFELONG IMPACT FOR
SURVIVORS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
BUT ALSO THE RESEARCH ON WHO IS
THE TRAFFICKER WHAT'S IN THEIR
PSYCHOLOGY. SO WE LOOK AT
RESEARCH FROM CANADA AND THE
UNITED STATES THAT HAS FOCUSED
ON TRAFFICKERS IN IN SHORT
WASN'T WHAT IS EMERGING FROM
THAT THOSE THAT RESEARCH IS THE
HIGH INCIDENT OF PSYCHOPATHY.
PSYCHOPATHY IS DEFINED AS A
PERSON WHO HAS NO CONSCIENCE WHO
HAS NO CARING FOR ANOTHER AND
THAT IS CLEARLY WHAT TRAFFICKERS
ARE THEY ARE SELLING INDIVIDUALS
WITHOUT REGARD FOR THE IMPACT ON
THEM. THE REAL RESEARCH ALSO
ADDRESSES THE PREDATORY NATURE
OF THE CRIME OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. AND THE VIOLENCE IN
UTTER DISREGARD FOR THE IMPACT
ON THE VICTIM OF TRAFFICKING.
AND THERE IS NEVER JUST ONE
VICTIM BEING TRAFFICKED BY A
TRAFFICKER. IT IS AT THE EIGHT
TRAFFICKER WHO FITS IN THE
CATEGORY IN THE RESEARCH THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS SOMEONE
WHO WILL CONTINUE TO LOWER
CONTINUE TO RECRUIT CONTINUE TO
PULL OTHER VICTIMS INTO THIS. IN
MY OFFICE AS SENATOR GROSS SAID
WE HAVE PROSECUTED OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED CASES. THAT INVOLVES
MORE THAN A THOUSAND VICTIMS OF
SEX TRAFFICKING. RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE SEVENTY EIGHT CASES PENDING
WAITING FOR COURT ROOM TO BRING
JUSTICE TO THE VICTIMS AND TO
HOLD THAT TRAFFICKERS
ACCOUNTABLE. WE ALSO HAVE
CREATED- HAVE DONE SEVEN
THOUSAND SAFETY PLANS FOR YOUNG.
VICTIMS WHO ARE VULNERABLE TO
BEING TRAFFICKED OR HAVE BEEN
TRAFFICKED AND EXPLOITED. THE
END OF THE AND NOW I JUST WANT
TO ADDRESS ONE THING IN THE
ANALYSIS AND THAT TALKS ABOUT
THE STORY OF RENE. WHO HERSELF
WAS TRAFFICKED BUT THEN I BECAME
A RECRUITER IF YOU WILL. I WANT
TO REMIND THE COMMITTEE THAT
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
YOUR THE LEGISLATURE HAS CREATED
SEVERAL LAWS THAT REALLY PROTECT
AND REQUIRE US WE DO IT ANYWAY
THAT IT REQUIRES US TO LOOK AT
THE- HISTORY OF AN INDIVIDUAL
WHO GETS CAUGHT UP AS A
PERPETRATOR OF CRIME AND I PUT
THAT IN QUOTES. AND THAT WE ARE
NOW REQUIRED TO LOOK AT WHETHER
OR NOT THAT PARTICULAR
INDIVIDUAL WAS THE VICTIM OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IN THE EARLIER
YEARS. WE ALSO HAVE BUILT YOU
HAVE BUILT STRONG LAWS FOR VAGUE
TO VACATING OLD CONVICTIONS OF
SOMEBODY WHO WAS ACTUALLY BEING
TRAFFICKED. WHAT WAS PROSECUTED
AS A PERPETRATOR SO WE'RE
BUILDING IT YOU ARE BUILDING IN
THE PROTECTIONS BUT THE TIME IS
NOW FOR CALIFORNIA TO REALLY
TELL THE TRUTH ABOUT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND THE TRUTH ABOUT
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS THAT IS A
VIOLENT CRIME. AND IT IS A
SERIOUS CRIME AND IT SHOULD BE
REGARDED AS SUCH IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MA'AM. THANK YOU MISS- FORMERLY
WE NOW HAVE- A DESSA DECIS
PERKINS. HELLO I'M HONORED TO BE
HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY BUT AS
MUCH AS I AM HONORED I AM ALSO
EQUALLY SADDENED BECAUSE OF WHY
I'M HERE. I AM HERE TO PLEAD
WITH YOU TO PASS SB TEN FORTY
TWO AND MAKE THIS ALREADY
HEINOUS ACT INTO A VICIOUS
CRIME. AND NOT CONTINUE TO GIVE
HUMAN AND SEX TRAFFICKERS A SLAP
ON THE WRIST. AS A LITTLE GIRL.
I SHOULD HAVE BEEN PLAYING WITH
BARBIE DOLLS I SHOULD BE WEARING
CUTE DRESSES. BUT INSTEAD I WAS
PUT ON PERFUME. NICE CLOTHING
AND I WAS PENETRATED. I WAS
MOLESTED I WAS RAPED AND I WAS
SOLD TO THE HIGHEST BIDDER WHICH
IS AN ACT OF MODERN DAY SLAVERY
. MY BODY WAS TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF
FOR YEARS. I WANT TO TELL YOU A
STORY BECAUSE I'M ALSO A TEACHER
AND THE INTERVENTION COUNSELOR-
THE BEGINNING OF THE SCHOOL
YEAR. ONE OF MY STUDENTS- I'LL
TELL YOU A STORY ABOUT ONE OF MY
STUDENTS BECAUSE THIS IS
CURRENTLY WHAT'S HAPPENING TO
OUR FUTURE LEADERS WHEN SCHOOL
STARTED IN AUGUST THIS YOUNG
GIRL NICE GREAT DIDN'T HAVE MUCH
OF ANYTHING. AND BECAUSE SHE
TRUSTED ME YOU SEE I TELL MY
STUDENTS ABOUT MY LIFE BECAUSE I
WANT THEM TO TRUST ME. FIRST THE
FIRST THING SHE DID WAS ASK ME
FOR MONEY FOR SOME FEMININE
PRODUCTS SOMETHING VERY SIMPLE.
THEN SHE ASKED ME FOR A BACKPACK
I NOTICED HERS WAS TORN AND SHE
WAS TYING PARTS OF IT TOGETHER I
TOLD HER I WOULD FIRST SPEAK TO
THE ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE I
DIDN'T WANT TO GET IN TROUBLE
FOR BUYING THINGS LIKE THAT FOR
STUDENTS. WELL WE ENDED UP
GETTING THAT BACKPACK FOR HER
ABOUT TWO MONTHS HAVE PASSED AND
SHE WAS GONE SHE WAS BACK INTO
THE FOSTER SYSTEM. ONE DAY SHE
ENDED UP COMING BACK. SHE HAD
NICE CLOTHES. SHOES JEWELRY.
WHATEVER YOU CAN DO THAT SHE HAD
BEEN. WITHIN A MONTH I THEN SAW
HER PENDING EXPULSION. I HAD
FOUND OUT SHE WAS BEING
TRAFFICKED AND SHE WAS CARRYING
A LEGAL ITEMS ONTO OUR CAMPUS. I
SAY ALL THAT TO SAY THIS THIS
COULD BE YOUR DAUGHTER. YOUR SON
YOUR NIECE NEPHEW NEIGHBOR'S
CHILDREN HUMAN TRAFFICKING DOES
NOT. I REPEAT IT DOES NOT
DISCRIMINATE. IT DOES NOT CARE
HOW MUCH MONEY YOU HAVE. YOUR
LOVED ONE COULD BE A VICTIM OF
MODERN DAY SLAVERY AS WELL. WHAT
THIS BILL ALREADY BE PASSED IF
IT WAS YOUR LOVED ONE. OR OUR
CHILDREN AND THEIR INNOCENCE NOT
WORTHY ENOUGH IN YOUR ICE TO BE
PROTECTED AND TREATED LIKE HUMAN
BEINGS NOT SOMEONE'S PROPERTY
NOT SOMEONE SLAVE. ARE YOU GOING
TO DO THE RIGHT THING TODAY AND
HELP SAVE OUR CHILDREN THESE ARE
OUR FUTURE. OR ARE YOU GOING TO
CONTINUE TO SIT ON YOUR HANDS
AND REMAIN SILENT. ASSUMING THAT
THIS SERIOUS CRIME CANNOT TOUCH
YOUR FAMILY. IN THE FAMOUS WORDS
OF MAMIE TILL MOBLEY WHAT
HAPPENS TO ONE OF US SHOULD BE
THE BUSINESS OF ALL OF US. HERE
IS A BILL. SB TEN FORTY TWO
DURING MY TIME THIS BILL WAS NOT
ACTIVE. MAYBE IF IT HAD BEEN
MAYBE I WOULD HAVE FELT SAFE AND
I WOULD HAVE REPORTED IT I DON'T
I DON'T DON'T HI AND DON'T ALL
THE VICTIMS BEFORE ME AND THAT
ARE COMING AFTER ME DESERVE TO
FEEL FREE. IF THIS BILL IS IF
THIS IS TRULY THE LAND OF THE
FREE.THE HOME OF THE BRAVE AND
WE ARE CREATED EQUAL. I ASK YOU
TO PASS THIS BILL SO THE
MESSAGES SENT LOUD AND CLEAR TO
ALL THOSE THAT ARE TREATING US
AS SLAVES AND CAPITALIZING OFF
OF OUR BODIES. S. S. B. TEN
FORTY TWO FOR ALL THOSE THAT
WILL COME AFTER ME. FOR ALL
THEIR DREAMS. FOR ALL THOSE
SCARED TO SPEAK UP GIVE US OUR
FREEDOM. WHAT I SAW YESTERDAY.
AS I SPOKE INDIVIDUALLY TO
SENATE MEMBERS I SAW THAT THERE
WAS SO MUCH POWER IN THAT ROOM.
SO I KNOW THAT YOU GUYS HAVE THE
POWER TO HELP US. I ASKED
RESPECTIVELY FOR YOUR A VOTE ON
SB TEN FORTY TWO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH PROTESTER. WE WILL NOW
CONTINUE WITH WITNESSES HERE IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES- TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED THAT WOULD LIKE TO-
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN FORTY
TWO MANAGER THANK YOU BRANDED UP
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SHERIFF IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON WHO'D ONLY ON ON
BEHALF OF THE VERSE I KIND OF
SHARES FARMAN AND SHERIFF CHAD
BIANCO IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON JULIE SECRETION OF WE
HAVE A SEPARATE SUMMER DINO
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
ENSURE SHANNON DICUS AND SUPPORT
. GOOD AFTERNOON KERN COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY SINCE DECEMBER
SPONSOR HERE TO SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SYLVIA I AM
A PARENT ADVOCATE AND I AM A
MOTHER OF A CHILD WHO WAS
TRAFFIC AT THE AGE OF THIRTEEN
AND I'M HERE TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF THE PARENTS AND ALSO HAVING
CHILDREN HAVE BEEN TRAFFICKED
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL IS A
VIOLENT AND- VIOLENT CRIME
BECAUSE MY DAUGHTER'S JOB WAS
BROKEN. MY DAUGHTER INNOCENCE
WAS TAKEN. THE FIRST HALF OF THE
BROKEN JAW. IS ACTUALLY FREE NOW
THE SECOND TRAFFICKER. BUT THE
MY DAUGHTER TESTIFIED AGAINST HE
CAN BE OT A LITTLE AND THREE
YEARS. SO I HOLD STRONG AND DO
BELIEVE THAT YOU MAY YOU PLEASE
HELP US SUPPORT AND PASS THIS
BILL THE OTHER FAMILIES THAT I
WORK ALONG SIDE DO NOT HAVE TO
GO THROUGH WHAT I AM GOING
THROUGH. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM I WOULD LIKE TO REMIND THE
WITNESSES THAT AT THIS TIME WE
NEED YOUR NAME THE ORGANIZATION
THAT YOU'RE PRESENTING AND
WHETHER OR NOT YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE ACTUALLY THIS TIME ONLY
SUPPORT- WITNESSES WOULD BE.
ALLOWED THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KIMBERLY
LEWIS I'M THE ELECTED DISTRICT
ATTORNEY IN MERCED COUNTY. AND
OUR COUNTY SUPPORTS. MY NAME IS
JENNA MCKAY WITH THE JOHN MCKAY
FOUNDATION AND I'M A SURVIVOR OF
THIS CRIME. SIXTEEN YEARS AGO I
WAS LURED OUT OF MY COMMUNITY IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
TRAFFICKED. SIXTEEN YEARS LATER
I STILL HAVE CHIROPRACTIC CARE
AND HOME TO THERAPY AND THERAPY
EVERY WEEK. FOR MY PTSD AND FROM
THE LAST TIME I WAS SOLD. PLEASE
PASS THIS BILL FOR OTHER VICTIMS
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS LAURA
PHILLIPS WITH THE JENNA MCKAY
FOUNDATION AND I AM IN SUPPORT
OF SB TEN FORTY TWO. IF YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JD
WITH A JENNA MCKAY FOUNDATION
AND I SUPPORT SB TEN FORTY TWO.
HI MY NAME'S A DEVICE AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. HI MY NAME IS
DR ANGELA LOOK FROM KERN COUNTY
I WORK WITH CHILDREN WHO ARE IN
CHILD WELFARE WE'VE SEEN SEVERAL
HUNDRED CHILDREN WHO'VE BEEN
TRAFFICKED IN OUR COUNTY AND I
ASK YOU TO SUPPORT THIS. MY NAME
IS ESTHER YOU I WORK FOR SO
INTERNATIONAL AND WE SERVE
VICTIM CHILD AND ADULT VICTIMS
OF TRAFFICKING AND THEIR
FAMILIES. AND I AM SUPPORT OF SB
TEN FORTY TWO SO THAT THOSE
CHILDREN FAMILIES DON'T HAVE TO
LIVE IN FEAR EVERY DAY. HELLO MY
NAME'S SUZANNE SCHULTZ ON THE
PROGRAM MANAGER FOR THE SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY FAMILY JUSTICE
CENTER. AND WE WORK DAILY WITH
VICTIMS THAT ARE. TRYING TO PUT
HER LIFE BACK TOGETHER AFTER THE
DESTRUCTION BY TRAFICKERS SO WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN THIS
BILL. MY NAME'S GREG BIRD WITH
THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS JOYCE PERKINS AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND I'M ODESSA
PERKINS OCT. AND I STRONGLY ASK
DID YOU SUPPORT AND PASS THIS
BILL. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME AND
MY SENSE IS LITTLE I AM FROM THE
GROUP BECAUSE OF WITH THIS NOT
VICTIMS OF THE VIOLENT CRIME
FROM TOP ON KING COUNTY AND I
YEAH- SUPPORT HIS B. NOT. YET AS
THE TEMPERATURE THANK YOU. HI MY
NAME IS THAT THE SECOND BOND I
AM PRESIDENT OF THE LOUISE G.
ALVAREZ JUNIOR. REWARDS FOR
JUSTICE WE ALSO WORK WITH
VICTIMS OF VIOLENT CRIME IN
SOUTH KING COUNTY. PLEASE PASS
THIS BILL. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS- TYSON ACCORDING THE
DIRECTOR OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
PROSECUTIONS IN KERN COUNTY. AND
ON BEHALF OF THE MANY VICTIMS
THAT I SEE I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TOM
LEWIS ON A LOCAL ATTORNEY MERCED
CALIFORNIA AND I. ASKED THE TO
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M TOR
VERSALLES OUR DISTRICT ATTORNEY
OF SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY IN A
WORKED ON MANY BILLS WITH YOU
AND YOU KNOW I BELIEVE IN THE
WORK YOU'RE DOING BUT TODAY I
NEED YOU TO HELP ME AND GIVE ME
THE TOTAL TO HOLD THOSE WERE
MOST VIOLENT AND PERPETRATING
THE MOST. VIOLENCE SEXUAL
PREDATORY CONDUCT I'VE EVER
WITNESSED IN THIRTY FIVE YEARS
AS A DISTRICT ATTORNEY. MY
COUNTY NEEDS THIS TOOL. PLEASE
VOTE YES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO
HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES HERE IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. LET
THEM SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
FORTY TWO. SEE NON MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD- WILL SORRY THANK YOU
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WILLING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE MODERATE YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WILLING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SB TEN FORTY TWO WE'LL BEGIN.
THANK YOU IT IS GENEROUS YOUR
SPORT OF TEN FORTY TWO THESE
PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO AT THIS
TIME. PRETTY LITTLE I NUMBER ONE
FIFTY FIVE HE STILL HAS. GERMAN
MEMBERS PLAYER OF ME HAVE THE
FRESNO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL- DR- THANK YOU.
NATIONAL LINE NUMBER TWO FIFTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES ANNE
HARRINGTON FROM SAN DIEGO COUNTY
MEMBER OF THE NORTH COUNTY ANTI
HUMAN TRAFFICKING COLLABORATIVE
AND LONG PORT. SH SH NEXT LITTLE
LINE NUMBER TWO THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE SHARING CONSULTED
WITH THE RIGHT PUBLIC POLICY
GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
BAKERSFIELD AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. I FULL NUMBER LINE
NUMBER TWO TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES IN THE MATTHEWS ON
BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. WITHOUT A
LINE NUMBER TWO SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
THE ANABOLIC CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE TINY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
SUMMER STEPHAN OUR OFFICES IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN FORTY TWO
THANK YOU. I I'M NOT GONNA LIE
NUMBER TWO TWENTY SEVEN THE
STORE HAD. THIS IS DONNA PACKAGE
I'M CALLING I'M A CAREER
PROSECUTOR CURRENTLY HOUSED IN
MONTEREY COUNTY I WHOLE
HEARTEDLY SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
I ASK YOU TO DO THE SAME THANK
YOU. WELL NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO
SEVENTY FIVE IS GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS HILARY- I'M CALLING FROM
LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA AND WORK
WITH THE INTERNATIONAL AND I'M
PART OF AT TEN FORTY TWO. WE'RE
NOT GOING TO LIE NUMBER TWO
TWENTY IS GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
LARGELY TORAH AWFUL FROM DELHI
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT OF TEN
FORTY. NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO ALL
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS AMBER HI I AM A SURVIVOR OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND I WORK FOR
IS THE ONLY INTERNATIONAL AND I
AM SUPPORT OF THE SPELLS. THE
NUMBER ONE NUMBER THIRTY HE
STILL HAS. I NEED A SMALL FARM I
LIVE IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY I
THANK MAKING HIM AND HAVE HIM
EXPERIENCE AND I DON'T I SUPPORT. YOU CAN REVIEW THANK YOU. WELL
NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
HANNAH RAM I AM A RESIDENT OF
LOS ANGELES AND I AM IN SUPPORT
OF SB TEN FORTY TWO. WELL NUMBER
ONE NUMBER ONE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS HALEY
LATER AND I LIVE IN VENTURA
COUNTY AND I AM IN SUPPORT AT
TEN FORTY TWO. I'M NOT GOING TO
LIE NUMBER. TWO SIXTY THREE IS
GO AHEAD. YES NOW ANYTIME AND I
WORK AT DELHI INTERNATIONAL IN
EINER ART AT TEN FORTY TWO. BUT
NOTHING ON LINE NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS SPECIAL GET DURING I
LIVE IN LOS ANGELES AND I WORK
AT. EGHTEEN FORTY TWO. WILL NOT
BE GOING ONLINE NUMBER TWO FIFTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIFTY HOT
AND I LIVE IN LOS ANGELES AND I
SUPPORT THAT HE- AND. FORTY
WE'RE NOT GOING TO LIE NUMBER
ONE FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ANYTHING ELSE THEN I LIVE IN SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY AND I OR S. U.
ONE REPAIR FROM FORTY. I WILL
NOT BE GOING ONLINE NUMBER TWO
SEVENTEEN HIS FATHER HAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS HEATHER HENSON I LIVE
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT MAKING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS
THE VOLATILITY. WHEN ARE WE
GOING TO LINE NUMBER THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
HANYA HOLM I AM IN BAKERSFIELD
CALIFORNIA I WORK. AT THE
TEMPERATURE OF. BUT WE'RE GOING
TO LINE NUMBER TWO EIGHTY FIVE
WELL I HAD. IT MARKED THE CEO OF
THE ALLIANCE FAMILY VIOLENCE AND
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND THE BIG
RESULTS ALMOST AN HOUR AND I
FORGOT TO GET FORTY TO ENCOURAGE
ALL OF. YOU WILL NOT BE GOING TO
LINE NUMBER TWO EIGHTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AND THE
POLICE AND I AM B. ANSARI BUT I
THINK YOU WERE TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS ADVOCATE HERE AT THE
ALLIANCE AGAINST FAMILY VIOLENCE
AND SEXUAL ASSAULT. AND I
SUPPORTED TEN FORTY TWO. THANK
YOU. WHEN ARE WE GONNA LIE
NUMBER TWO FORTY THREE THESE BY
HAND. HI MY NAME IS ADELA
GIRLFRIEND I'M IN LA COUNTY
RESIDENT AND SUPPORT US AT THE
END WHAT YOU CAN. WHEN I
RECORDED LINE NUMBER TWO FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THE NUMBERS SHOW
MUTCHLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
FORTY THANK YOU. WE'RE NOT GOING
TO LIE NUMBER ONE FORTY THREE
WELL I HAVE HAD HI MY NAME IS
HITCHCOCK'S I LIVE IN LOS
ANGELES AND I REPORT. SENATE
BILL TEN FORTY. THERE THANK YOU
BECAUSE- THANKS WELL NOW YOU'RE
GOING TO LIE NUMBER TWO TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS SANDY AS FAR AS I AM IN LA
COUNTY RESIDENTS ALSO SURVIVOR
OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND ON
BEHALF. OF SURVIVORS LIKE ME IN
THE VICTIM'S LIFE- TODAY I
SUPPORT IT YOU CAN FORTY TWO.
WHEN I RECORDED LINE NUMBER TWO
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
HEAD WAS FULL LA COUNTY
RESIDENTS AND FORTESCUE CAN
FORTY TWO THANK YOU. I'M NOT
GONNA LIE NUMBER TWO FORTY NINE
WELL I HAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
DOUG. AND THE ROUNDER OF MAGICAL
AND COKE AND THE PEOPLE BUT THE
ABOLISHMENT KATHY'S UNIQUES. WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING AS A HUMAN
TRAFFICKING TWO THOUSAND AND
NINE. THE LAWYERS SEAN SUPPORT
AGAINST. THE TEN FORTY TWO THANK
YOU. WE'RE NOT WE'RE GOING TO
LINE NUMBER FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FINE TUNE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI WE HAVE NO TIME FROM
LONG BEACH CALIFORNIA YEAH. YEAH
WE INTERNATIONAL AND I WANTED TO
BE TRANSPORTED TO. WHEN I
RECORDED LINE NUMBER SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS JEAN AND HAIR AND I
LET THEM VENT. AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AT EACH AND FORTY TWO
THANK YOU. WILL NOT BE GOING
ONLINE BOTH. WHAT HAS. BUT THIS
IS JUST A TEST THE NATIVE FROM
CLOVIS CALIFORNIA- FOUNDER OF
GRACE FAMILY LOVE CHARITABLE
ORGANIZATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SP TEN FORTY TWO. THANK YOU.
WHEN ARE WE GOING TO LINE NUMBER
ONE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER
LAWRENCE AND I'M A RESIDENT OF
THE COUNTY AND I SUPPORT THE
FILL. WHEN ARE WE GOING TO LINE
NUMBER TWO SEVENTY EIGHT PEOPLE
HAD. MY NAME IS DAVID **** WHAT
BUT ON BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN IN
THE STATE I WRONG OR MAKING
HUMAN TRAFFICKING ARE CLASSIFIED
AS VIOLENT. WHEN ARE WE GOING TO
LINE NUMBER ONE FORTY FOUR HE
STILL HAS. HELLO ALL I HAVE FOR
YOU. AND I LIVE IN LA COMPANY
AND I'D WORK MATE TRAFFIC IN.
EIGHT S. N. FIVE ONE THOUSAND
EIGHT. AT THE ONE. THEIR OLD
BOARD HERE. WILL NOT BE GOING TO
LINE NUMBER TWO THIRTY YOU STILL
AHEAD. THIS IS GINGER SHAW OF
CALIFORNIA AGAINST SLAVERY IN
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SAFE
SHELTER COLLABORATIVE IN SUPPORT
OF SB CAN FORTY TWO. WHEN ARE WE
GOING TO LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FINE TWO
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
THINK THAT'S THE CASE NEYMAR
FROM CLOVIS CALIFORNIA NINE THE
COURT OF AS WE CAN FOR THE TEAM
. WE'RE NOT GOING TO LIE NUMBER
TWO TWENTY NINE IS GO AHEAD. BY
TWO TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I'M NOT GONNA LIE NUMBER
TWO FORTY EIGHT YOU WILL HAVE.
HI MY NAME IS URSULA LOPEZ BUT
JOHN HOW AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND SPEECH
AND- WHAT DO YOU. WHAT ARE WE
GOING TO LINE NUMBER TWO SIXTY
SIX AND A HALF. ANY HISTORICALLY
LINDEN I'M ON THE COMMUNITY
COUNCIL FOR THE CHILDREN'S
RECEIVING ALMOST SACRAMENTO
WHICH SERVES ABUSED AND
NEGLECTED CHILDREN AND ON BEHALF
OF THE VICTIMS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING- YOU STRONGLY TO
PASS THEIR SPEECH AND FORTY TWO
. WHEN ARE WE GOING TO LINE
NUMBER TWO FORTY ONE PEOPLE HAVE
. HELLO MY NAME IS CAROL HART. A
LIVE IN LA COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AT. EIGHT TEN FORTY TWO.
WHEN ARE WE GONNA LIE NUMBER TWO
THIRTY SEVEN WELL I HAD. MY NAME
IS AND I LIVE IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY I WORK FOR A VERY
INTERNATIONAL I AND STRONG QUICK
AND HE CAN. WHAT ARE WE GOING TO
LINE NUMBER TWO THIRTY NINE WELL
I HAD. BY TWO THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WILL NOT BE GOING
TO LINE NUMBER TWO SIXTY FIVE
BUT HAS. HI MY NAME IS MARGIE
GARCIA I WORK IN BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT AND I AM
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
FORTY TWO. WHEN ARE WE GOING TO
LINE NUMBER. I'LL GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARTY OUT THE
BODY ARE YOU CALLING IN RESPECT
YOU'RE VERY STRONG AND ACTIVE
THE CALL. WILL BE K. SHE WILL
NOW BE GOING TO LINE NUMBER ONE
FIFTY EIGHT BUT HEY. HI MY NAME
IS EUGENE HELPLESS I AM A
RESIDENT OF LA COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SP TEN FORTY
TWO THANK YOU. WILL NOT BE GOING
ONLINE NUMBER TWO FORTY STATUS
BY HANDS. HI I AM DOCTOR CARTER-
I'M A LOCAL PHYSICIAN AGAIN
BERNIE THE ACCOUNTING AND I
START. YOU'RE NOT GOING TO LIE
NUMBER TWO EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI AND DOCTOR IN A
TURNING OUT THE DOOR. THAT'S THE
ONLY SUPPORT S. T. TEN FORTY TWO
ON BEHALF OF REGARD MISSIONS
POSSIBLE HELP HERE I LOVE THE
ORIGINAL AND THE NATIVE AMERICAN
WARRIORS PASSPORT. THANK YOU.
I'M GOING TO LIE NUMBER TWO
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO I'M CALLING FROM
CALIFORNIA AND I AND THE COURT
AT TEN FORTY TWO MY NAME IS HERE
ABOUT THANK YOU. WHEN ARE WE
GOING TO LIE NUMBER TWO NINETY
ONE WELL I HAD. HI MY NAME IS
BONNIE GETS. RESIDENTS OF LOS
ANGELES I'M IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
FORTY TWO. WHEN ARE WE GOING TO
LINE NUMBER TWO NINETY TWO WELL
I HAD. MY NAME IS JULIE LEVI ON
THE CO FOUNDER OF NO MORE JOHN
ENDING EXPLOITATION BY ENDING
THE MAN'S LIVE IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
PASSAGE OF SB TEN FORTY. WE'RE
NOT GOING TO LIE NUMBER THREE
HUNDRED IF I HAD. I NEED HELP IN
WEIGHT A RESIDENT OF KERN COUNTY
AND I SUPPORT SB TEN THIRTY TWO
. WELL WE GOT A LINE NUMBER TWO
NINETY NINE HE STILL HAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS ROBERT NIELSEN I LIVE
IN ESCONDIDO CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY SUPPORT- THE- FORTY
TWO- I'M AGAINST HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. WHEN ARE WE GOING
TO ONE NUMBER TWO NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS MELISSA ARVIN CALIFORNIA IN
KERN COUNTY I WAS AT TEN FORTY
TWO THANK. FOR EVERY JUST
ANOTHER MOMENT OUR NEXT PARTY.
THE JUST ONE NORMAL.
OUR NEXT REGULAR NUMBER ONE
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
HELLO MY NAME IS ALEXIS ROMERO I
WORK WITH- INTERNATIONAL
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE. TEN FORTY TWO.
INTERPERSONAL THIS TIME WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR MODERATE IF YOU WOULD
JUST CHECK THE LINE ONE MORE
TIME TO. MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
HEARD FROM ALL OF OUR SUPPORTERS
FOR SP TEN FORTY TWO. THANK YOU
ONE CAN LADIES GENTLEMEN IF YOU
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO GIVE YOU
SUPPORT FOR. S. FORTY TWO PRESS
ONE BUTTON ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WHAT ARE YOUR LINE NUMBER TWO
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
MOMENT. WE GOT A LINE NUMBER
THREE OH FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FOR WILL BE ONE ONE OR TWO
THIRTY NINE GO AHEAD. HOW DO YOU
KNOW WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO THIRTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI ANGIE
MARYLAND CORRECT HOW MANY I MEAN
FROM SUPPORT AT TEN FORTY YOU
AND ARE YOU BACK. THANK YOU.
WILL NOT BE GOING TO LINE NUMBER
TWO TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TO TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HE NOT ONLY YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE TO TWENTY NINE.
ONE OF YOUR LINE NUMBER TWO
NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS KAREN MIYAMOTO
AND I LIVED IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY I AM IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
FORTY TWO THANK YOU. SPIEGEL
ONLINE NUMBER THREE TEN IS GO
AHEAD. PINE TREES IN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS LINDA CAN AGAIN AND I
AM IN SUPPORT OF ATHLETES I'M
FORTY TWO AND I'M ALSO IN LA
COUNTY. I'M NOT GOING TO LIE
NUMBER ONE SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THREE HI MY NAME IS
GABRIELLE KARAMBA FROM LA COUNTY
ALSO WITH DELHI INTERNATIONAL
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE- I.
WILL NOT BE ONE LINE NUMBER TWO
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HE
HELPED HIMSELF SO INTERNATIONAL
IN STRONG SUPPORT. WE'LL BE NOW
POINT LINE FOR TWO NINETY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BEIJING CHARLES
LOS ANGELES COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF
SB AND FORTY TWO. WHAT ARE WE
GOING TO I. NUMBER THREE OH FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME.
ANGELA AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO LIE NUMBER
THREE OH THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD-
HI MY NAME IS SUSIE WATSON
REGISTERED NURSE FROM MARIN
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT-
SP TEN FORTY TWO. I'M NOT GOING
TO LIE NUMBER TWO TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO AGAIN HI
. WHO'S AND WE ARE IN STRONG
HOLD ON AT ALL AND ON TWO THANK
YOU. I I'M NOT GOING TO LIE
NUMBER TWO OH SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
SUSAN ALL RIGHT I LIVE IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND I AM OR FM HE
TRANSPORTING IT THANK YOU. NOT
GONNA LIE NUMBER TWO FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A LOT OF A LOT
AS WELL AS ARMY I WE'RE THE ONLY
NATIONAL. THANK YOU. WILL NOT BE
GOING LINE NUMBER THREE ONE ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
KATHERINE HONG AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT S. T. TEN FORTY TWO.
THANK YOU. AND YOUR PERCEPTION
YOUR PATIENCE WE NOW HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MR MODERATOR HAVING HEARD FROM
ALL OUR SUPPORTERS WILL NOT
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE
FROM ANY OPPOSITION WE DO HAVE
TO LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WILL BEGIN WITH- WHAT DOES BUT
I'M SORRY. YES WHAT IS PALADE
GARC. AND I APOLOGIZE FOR THE
PRONUNCIATION IF I MISSPOKE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR BUT
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS HELLO THE
CARD AND I AM INCLINED
TRAFFICKING A TRICKY. I AGREE ON
THE CRIMINAL LAW BUT I THINK THE
TRAINING FOR YOU TO TRY. WE ARE
A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
PROVIDING LEGAL SERVICES TO
SURVIVORS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
I OVERSEE OUR VICTIM RIGHT AND
BIG PICTURE PROGRAM. I FULLY
UPHOLD A HAND FORTY TWO WHILE
ALL OUR CLIENTS FOR HUMAN
TRAFFICKING SURVIVORS OVER 88%
HOW OLD OR EXPERIENCED DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. AND OVER 94% OF ALL
FOR EXPERIENCED PILOTS BUT
ACTUAL VIOLENCE OBVIOUSLY I'M
TALKING ABOUT SOME OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITY. YEAH OVER 90% OF OUR
CLIENTS ALSO HAVE A CRIMINAL
RECORD. HI THERE TRUST ME MANY
OF THEM ACTUALLY TALKING TO
TARGET ON THEIR BACK INSTEAD. OF
THE PEOPLE WHO TRAFFIC. I WOULD
BE ABLE TO ACT DATA SHOW THE
BACK MAJORITY OF SEX TRAFFICKING
THE WHO ARE OUR FASTEST BY BLACK
AND BROWN. FOR OVER A WEEK. AND
TO FIGHT FROM A YOUNG AGE. THE
THIRD I'M- IF I PERPETRATOR
INSTEAD OF BEING PROTECTED FIX
THEM AND THEY ARE OFTEN ARRESTED. FOR HUMAN TRAFFICKING RELATED
CHARGES. OKAY MY EXPERIENCE WITH
OTHER PROPERTIES BEFORE TWENTY
FIVE THE PROSECUTOR IN MIAMI
FLORIDA BY INVESTIGATORS AND
PROSECUTORS THANKS AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CASES I THOUGHT THE
EXACT SAME THING BUT SOME DO NOT
SELF IDENTIFY AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT FREQUENTLY MET
EXEMPLIFIED PERFECT. FROM BOTH.
OF YOU AT FOR HUMAN TRAFFICKING
VICTIM ON IT QUICKLY. THERE WILL
HAVE NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES FOR
VICTIMS. ARE I KNOW PEOPLE THAT
HE EXISTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FIVE. WELL LIKE I
SAID IF YOU FIND HIM. IN THE
LATEST CHARGES. I'M NOT IT ONE
WITH THE BEST CASES WATER FORTY.
HI RIGHT. YEP WHAT AND- CLOSER
TO HUMAN TRAFFIC OKAY HERE YOU
HOWEVER A VERY THAT SHE AND THE
A. O'MALLEY ABOUT ARE THE ONES
WERE GETTING ARRESTED.
ADDITIONALLY THE AMOUNT ABOUT
RUNNING WITH ONE OF OUR CLIENTS
AND MENTION TO YOU ALL THAT SHE
WOULD HAVE BEEN ELIGIBLE FOR THE
BIG PICTURE AND OTHER PROTECTION
BUT THE HONORABLE COMMITTEE HAD
WORKED ON IN THE PAST YEAR. BUT
IT MADE HIM REALLY I'M SURE IF
THIS WILL WORK I. THINK WHAT THE
AFFIRMATIVE DEFENSE UNDER THE
FIFTY TO THIRTY SIX TWENTY THREE
AND A BETA TRIAL WASHING. UNDER
FIFTY TO THIRTY SIX POINT. ONE
OR BOTH. IN FACT YOU IN FACT IT
IN WHICH- ANY VIOLENT OR- I'M
IT'S BEEN A WONDERFUL BAKING. SO
WHAT ARE YOU DOING WITH THE
PROTECTION THAT WILL POP BY.
SHOP LAST YEAR THERE ARE NO X.
LAID OUT IN THE L. I AM VERY YOU
TO VOTE FOR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THIS CARD WILL NOW
CONTINUE WITH- SECOND LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS APRIL GRAYSON
ARE YOU ON THE LINE. I AM THANK
YOU. PLEASE PROCEED MA'AM. GOOD
AFTERNOON CANADIAN HERE. MY NAME
IS GRACE AND I'M A POLICY
ASSOCIATE FOR YOUNG WOMAN AND I
ALSO WORK AT ME AGAINST THE FULL
HARM ANTI HUMAN TRAFFICKING
ORGANIZATION WHERE I AM AND I
WOULD LISTEN FOR FIVE BUCKS MY
MAIN MOTIVATOR PLAYED ON
DIFFERENT ECONOMIC. THE BUT
PEOPLE PARTICIPATE. I AM HERE
BECAUSE I THANK YOU CAN PUT IT.
F. FORTY TWO IF PASSED. WELL I
DO ALL THE HARD WORK OF CENTER
COME LOCKER AND THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE NETWORK FIVE FIVE FIVE
EIGHTY ONE FOUR. BUT THE VIRUS I
HAVE SIGNED IT THE LAW LAST
YEAR. I AM A MEMBER OF THE GASES
BUT THE BACK QUALITY. AS WELL AS
THE PERSONAL BY ALL TESTIMONY
FOR EIGHTY ONE OR LAST YEAR. I
THINK BEFORE YOU HAVE TO COME
OUT LIKE THE PRIVATE SECTOR HE-
WAS NEVER BEEN BACK NIGHT NOT
OFFERED ANYTHING. REALLY A
SURVIVOR. I WAS OUT FOR THE CPS
MA'AM AND ADD THAT EVERY THIS.
WAY YOU HAVE TO OFFER. I HAVE
NEVER BEEN SEEN AT EIGHTEEN YOU
CAN NOT BE ANYBODY THEM. AT
NINETEEN I WOULD RATHER LIVE BY
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
I'VE HEARD EVERYTHING YOU. I
REPEAT SEVENTEEN YEAR. HAVING A
FACTORY THE CARD THAT WOULD BE
HUMAN TRAFFICKING TODAY. I DON'T
. EIGHTY NINE AND I HAD TO COME
HOME AND READY FOR IT. AND IT. I
WOULD NEVER DENIED THE VICTIM OF
ME BECAUSE HE- ONLY THE
PERPETRATOR EVEN THOUGH I WAS
NINETEEN. IN MY TWENTY SEVEN
YEAR OLD CODEFENDANT AND-
SITTING NEXT TO ME. ALL COURT
PRACTICE. HE WASN'T EVEN
CONVICTED OF EMBEZZLING CHARGES
. CURRENTLY WE DO NOT HAVE A
CRIMINAL THAT IT'S NOT THAT
EASILY RECOGNIZES THE-
ESPECIALLY YOUNG WOMEN OF COLOR
WERE VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION. WHAT IF THE PASSES
I THINK YOU WILL BE REQUIRED TO
BECOME THE LEGAL AFFIRMATIVE
DEFENSE AND BACK THERE THE BIG
THEM THE HUMAN FACTOR. THEREFORE
THIS BILL WILL NOT ONLY HURT BIG
SOMETHING CURRENT OF FIFTY
CASES. WILL BE DOUBLED UNDER
EFFECT WHILE. ALSO AFFECTED
BARLEY OR BARBARA SPEAKING THERE
IS A RECORD BREAK AND
UNDERTAKER. EVER LIKE ME. THE
BILL WOULD HAVE SEVERE
COLLATERAL CONSEQUENCES FOR
VICTIMS OF THE BARBER. THE
SOLUTION IS NOT TO CREATE MORE
BURY IT THEM LOOKING AT PROPERLY
INVESTIGATE CASES PROVIDING
HEALING WE FOR THE PREVENT
FURTHER HARM AGAINST SURVIVOR BY
THE CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM. UNTIL
WE CAN PERFECT THEY COME FROM A
RED. NOT PASS LAWS THAT WILL
FURTHER HARMED. THEIR AND
ULTIMATELY DECIDED. EVEN UNDER
CURRENT LAW I AM STILL NOT
RECOGNIZED BY THE STATE AT THE
HEART OF EVERYTHING. I
UNDERSTAND THE- BUT I THOUGHT WE
COULD SUCCESSFULLY IDENTIFIED
BECAUSE- ALL BECAUSE OF THE
COLOR. IT PROVIDES WATER BUT WE
CANNOT BE IN SUPPORT IF YOU
SIMPLY. THE RECOGNITION OF THE
BARBER NOT MY FAMILY. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR SHARING YOUR TESTIMONY
OF MISS GRAYSON WILL NOW MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- TO SP
AT TEN FORTY TWO HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED DO WE HAVE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. FIVE YET
THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICES
SMARTER IF YOU WOULD PLEASE FROM
THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB. TEN
FORTY TWO. I'M SORRY WHICH STATE
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OPPOSITION
I'M SORRY I APOLOGIZE OPPOSITION
. THANK YOU YOUR OPPOSITION TEN
FORTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
THOUSAND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WONDER WHY NUMBER TWO FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WESLEY HOUSTON
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. EXPLORE
THE LINE NUMBER TWO THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. KATHY SURE
GREAT YOU KNOW YOUR CALIFORNIA
ACTION IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
NATIONAL I NUMBER TWO TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS ADRIANA GRANT SAYS I
AM ALSO A SURVIVOR OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND I'M ALSO
FORMERLY INCARCERATED I LIVE IN
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY AFTER THE
VICTORIAN ISLAND FROM OPPOSITION. OF ITSELF THANK YOU. NEXT TO A
LINE NUMBER TWO FORTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. EMILY WONDER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COALITION OF
WOMEN PRISONERS FREED UP DRIVE
THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH
LAW. YOUR WARRIORS FREEDOM
COALITION SURVIVED AND PUNISHED
AND THE YOUNG WOMEN'S FREEDOM
CENTER WHO ARE ALL
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE JUSTICE
FOR SURVIVORS COALITION AND ARE
ALL IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO SB
TEN FORTY TWO. THANK YOU. AND
YOUR PERSONAL TIME WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
CHECK LINES ONE MORE TIME JUST
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE HEARD
FROM ALL OUR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TEN FORTY TWO.
THANK YOU OKAY LADIES GENTLEMEN
IF YOU ARE NOT JUST A TEN FORTY
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND YOUR FIRST AT
THIS TIME WE STILL HAVE NO ONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR MODERATOR
AND WE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK
ALL OF OUR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WILL NOT BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO OUR MEMBERS-
SENATOR WIENER. ORDER A COPIOUS
NUMBER OF NUMBERS- SO- FIRST OF
ALL I JUST WANT TO SAY- AND- WE
MET YESTERDAY AND WHAT HAPPENED
TO YOU ALSO TO THE TO THE TO THE
PERSON WHO CALLED AND EXPRESSED
HER EXPERIENCE OBVIOUSLY PEOPLE
HAVE DIFFERENT VIEWS OF THE
SPELL BUT REGARDLESS WHAT WHAT
WHAT HAPPENED TO YOU WHAT
HAPPENED TO FAR TOO MANY PEOPLE
HERE AND AROUND THE WORLD- IN
TERMS OF YOU KNOW WHAT-
ABSOLUTELY IS- YOU KNOW THAT
IT'S JUST A- IT'S- IT'S A
HORRIFIC. ASSISTED A TRAGEDY
BUT- A- JUST THE MOST
DESTRUCTIVE. DESPICABLE I BECAME
A FIND THE RIGHT WORDS. I'M FOR
IT THAT PEOPLE ARE BECAUSE I
WOULD DO THIS TO OTHER PEOPLE-
AND- AND I THINK. WE ALL- AGREE
ABOUT THAT IT'S NOT. AN ISSUE AT
ALL. WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH
HERE IS AN ISSUE WHAT IS. WHAT
WHETHER TO INCREASE. THE CAR
SERRATION FOR THIS PARTICULAR
CRIME BEYOND THE ALREADY HARSH.
CRIMINAL PENALTIES FOR IT AND
YOUR RESPECTFULLY TO THE- THE
AUTHOR INTO SUPPORTERS- I DON'T
AGREE THAT THIS IS THE CORE OF
THE PUNISHMENT PENALTIES FOR
TRAFFICKING OR LIGHT IN
CALIFORNIA IT I TOTALLY RESPECT
PEOPLE WANTING TO HAVE A HIGHER
PENALTY TOTALLY RESPECT THAT-
BUT I DON'T THINK IT'S ACCURATE
TO PORTRAY THE CURRENT PENALTIES
ARE SOMEHOW BY. MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT THE VOTERS ADOPT THE
CURRENT PENALTIES I BELIEVE IN
TWENTY TWELVE WITH PROP THIRTY
FIVE MINS ANALYSIS ON YOUR HEAD
I'M GLAD I GOT MY NUMBERS RIGHT
SO IT WAS THE VOTERS OF
CALPURNIA WHO. STARTED THE
CURRENT PENALTIES AND THOSE
PENALTIES AND PLEASE SOMEONE
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG. OR THAT
FOR- FOR NON SEXUAL- FOR FORCED
LABOR HUMAN TRAFFICKING- IT'S A
MAXIMUM OF UP TO TWELVE YOU. UP
30% FOR TRAFFICKING INVOLVES
PIMPING PANDERING CHILD ****
THAT IS PUNISHABLE BY UP TO
TWENTY YEARS IN STATE PRISON. IF
THE IF THE VICTIM IS A MINOR-
AND THERE IS A PROBLEM AND
BECAUSE IT'S A COMMERCIAL SEX
ACT- INCLUDING PIMPING PANDERING
AND CHILD **** THAT'S HUMAN
TRAFFICKING PUNISHING PUNISH
PUNISHABLE EXCUSE ME BY UP TO
TWELVE YEARS AND UP TO LIFE IN
PRISON IF THERE'S ANY YOUR
POOREST FRAUD DECEIT COERCION
VIOLENCE THE REST ETCETERA
THAT'S FIFTEEN YEARS- TO LIFE.
IN A DAY THEN ON TOP OF THAT
BASE SENTENCE OF UP TO TWELVE
YEARS UP TO TWENTY YEARS TWELVE
YEARS OCT FIFTEEN THE LIFE
THERE'S AN ENHANCEMENT OF UP TO
TEN METERS ON TOP OF THAT. IF
THERE'S BODILY. SO UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE'S A MASSIVE SPECTRUM
OF THE TYPES OF HARMS OCCUR
BECAUSE OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING A
LOT OF WHAT WE HEARD TODAY- WITH
YOU KNOW I MEAN IT'S JUST
HORRIFIC TREATMENT OF HUMAN
BEINGS WITH SOME OF THE SEVERE
INJURY ACTOR ROB YOU BROKE. AND
RAPE AND ETCETERA AND WE HEARD
ALL OF THAT. AND THAT THERE'S
ALREADY HARSH UNDERLYING
PENALTIES PARTICULARLY IF THEIR
CHILDREN- IN ADDITION TO THE
POSSIBILITY OF A TEN UP TO A
FIVE SEVEN OR UP TO TEN YEAR
ENHANCEMENT OF GREAT BODILY
INJURY. IS INFLICTED ONLY KNOWS
DEFINITION OF GREAT BODILY
INJURY IS PRETTY BROAD- HI IN
ADDITION- MARK ESPECIALLY LIKE
IN TERMS OF WHAT WE HEARD SOME
OF THE HORRIBLE- DESCRIPTIONS OF
CRIMES THAT WE HEARD TODAY- IF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS ACCOMPANIED
BY OTHER. FELONIES THEY THOSE
CAN BE PUNISHED SEPARATELY AND
SPRINKLE IT WITH CONCURRENT
SENTENCES STOCKING THE SENTENCE.
AND SOME OF THOSE ARE ARE MANY
OF THOSE ARE OUR STRIKES OR
SERIOUS VIOLENCE OR KIDNAPPING.
FORCIBLE RAPE A RAPE OR SODOMY-
LEWD ACTS ON A CHILD- SEXUAL
PENETRATION BY MEANS OF FORCE-
VARIOUS KINDS OF ASSAULTS-
THREATS- AND SO FORTH AND THOSE
ARE NOT ONLY FELONIES WITH
ADDITIONAL PENALTIES ON TOP OF
THAT. BUT THOSE. ARE ALL SERIOUS
OR VIOLENT FELONIES AND UNLESS
THE STRIKE. WHEN I SAY ALL THIS
I KNOW AND I DON'T NOT GOOD
DYING TO GET INTO THE DETAILS OF
THE SENSING REGION HERE BUT I
SAY THIS FOR EVERYONE INCLUDING
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC OR
WATCHING TODAY I UNDERSTAND.
THAT IS NOT THE CASE THAT
COMMITTING THESE EGREGIOUS
HORRIFIC OFFENSES AGAINST OTHER
HUMAN BEINGS IS SOMEHOW PUNISH
LATELY IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW
IT'S PUNISHED VERY HARSHLY-
INCLUDING BECAUSE OF WHAT THE
VOTERS DID IN TWENTY TWELVE-
WITH WITH PROPER WITH PROP
THIRTY FIVE- SO. YOU SO I
UNDERSTAND THE MOTIVATION AND
RESPECT THE MOTIVATION BEHIND-
THE SPELL- AND THERE'S SO MUCH
MORE WE NEED TO DO FOR SURVIVORS
IN TERMS OF RESOURCES AND
SUPPORT AND I WILL SAY IT WAS A
LOT OF REFERENCE TO LGBTQ YOUTH-
I WANTED TO TALK ABOUT A MINUTE-
YES MY COMMUNITY. YOU KNOW
DESERVED IN MY COMMUNITY. PEOPLE
WHO. YOU KNOW I WAS A I'LL BE
CAN I WAS LUCKY THAT I HAD
PARENTS WHO SUPPORTED ME AND
LOVED ME. AND LET ME HAVE A ROOF
OVER MY HEAD. BECAUSE SO MANY
MEMBERS OF MY COMMUNITY. YOU'RE
KICKED OUT OF THEIR HOUSES OF
OUR HOMES THEIR PARENTS REJECT
THEM. BECAUSE THEY COME OUT
COULD BE A TWELVE THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN YEARS OLD AND THEY ARE
ON THE STREET IT'S NOT A
COINCIDENCE THAT ALMOST ABOUT
HALF. OF HOMELESS YOUTH ARE
LGBTQ HALF 50% OF HOMELESS YOUTH
ARE LGBTQ THAT'S NOT RANDOM
THAT'S BECAUSE THESE CHILDREN
ARE GETTING REJECTED FROM THEIR
FAMILIES REJECTED FROM THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND THEY END UP ON
THE STREETS. AND IT IS NOT
SHOCKING. THAT SOME OF THEM ARE
GETTING TRAFFICKED THEY'RE SO
VULNERABLE BECAUSE SOCIETY
REJECTS THEM BECAUSE OUR
FAMILIES REJECT THEM. AND WE SEE
DESPICABLE POLITICIANS.
DESPICABLE POLITICIANS PEOPLE
LIKE GREG ABBOTT AND RHONDA
SANTOS AND ALL THESE PEOPLE. WHO
ON THE BACKS. OF LGBTQ KIDS ARE
TRYING TO SCORE POLITICAL POINTS
TO BECOME PRESIDENT OR SENATOR
WHATEVER THEY WANT TO BE. AND
WHEN THEY DO THAT MORE OF THESE
KIDS END UP ON THE STREETS. AND
MORE THESE KIDS END UP
TRAFFICKED AND THEY'RE NOT BEING
TRAFFICKED BECAUSE THE SENTENCE
ISN'T HARSH ENOUGH THEY'RE NOT
BEING TRAFFIC BECAUSE IT'S NOT A
STRIKE BECAUSE THE PERSON'S ONLY
GETTING TWELVE OR TWENTY YEARS.
IN PRISON INSTEAD OF LIFE IN
PRISON THEY'RE GETTING TRAFFIC
BECAUSE WHAT SOCIETY HAS DONE TO
THEM. AND I CAN GO THROUGH OTHER
COMMUNITIES. BETTER TREATED LIKE
GARBAGE IN THE SOCIETY. AND WHEN
WE LOOK AT WHO'S GETTING
TRAFFICKED IN THIS SOCIETY.
DISPROPORTIONATELY IT'S. IT'S
NOT PEOPLE WITH MY BACKGROUND.
I'M NOT SAYING IT DOESN'T HAPPEN
IT DOES CAN HAPPEN TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE BUT THERE ARE CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE BEING VERY
DISPROPORTIONATELY SUBJECTED TO
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND IT'S NOT
BECAUSE PEOPLE AREN'T GETTING A
STRIKE OR GOING TO PRISON FOR
LIFE. IT'S BECAUSE OF THE WAY
THAT THIS SOCIETY TREATS CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES AND TREATS THE
CHILDREN IN THOSE COMMUNITIES
AND THEY END UP VULNERABLE ON
THE STREET. IN FOSTER CARE
DUMPED OUT OF FOSTER CARE AND
THEY END UP BEING TRAFFICKED- SO
LET'S FOCUS ON SUPPORTING THE
SURVIVORS LET'S SUPPORT THESE
KIDS BEFORE. THEY END UP IN
OPPOSITION. BUT PASSING THIS
BILL TODAY IN MY PERSONAL VIEW
IS NOT GOING TO CHANGE THIS IS
NOT GOING TO HELP. US THOSE
SURVIVORS WITH ALL RESPECT AND
SO I WON'T BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL TODAY. THANK YOU
SENATOR WIENER. SENATOR SKINNER. WHICH I CAN CONTINUE. THE
FIRST. SINCE YOU'VE BEEN
PRESIDING OVER THIS ENTIRE BILL
LET YOU KEEP THE MIKE AND- I WAS
ABLE TO HEAR SOME OF THE
TESTIMONY BUT UNFORTUNATELY I
WAS- HAVING TO PRESENT A BUILD
ANOTHER COMMITTEE WHICH HAPPENS
ON. IN THE JUGGLING OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES AND I WAS ABLE TO
MEET- THE KEY WITNESS AT. BOTH
WITNESSES AND IN ADVANCE OF THE
HEARING. OUR. I IN NO WAY
MINIMIZE THE CRIME OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. IT IS A SERIOUS
CRIME. HOWEVER WHEN WE USE THE
EXAMPLE OF THAT IF SOMEONE
COMMITS A ROBBERY THAT THEY CAN
GET A THIRD STRIKE AND IN THIS
CASE SOMEONE CAN'T I THINK AS
SENATOR WIENER EXPLAINED IT
DEPENDS ON THE CIRCUMSTANCE THAT
IT IS NOT JUST A FLAT OUT THAT
THEY CANNOT- NOW I PERSONALLY
DON'T AGREE THAT ROBBERY SHOULD
HAVE A THIRD STRIKE I THINK
CERTAIN TYPES OF- ROBBERY MAY.
BE SHOULD BE ELEVATED BUT NOT
ALL AND OUR THIRD STRIKE LAW HAS
NOT BENEFITED CALIFORNIANS OR
PUBLIC SAFETY. ON. THE OTHER
LOOK SENTENCING WE CAN ALWAYS
DEBATE WHETHER OUR SENTENCING
PRACTICES ARE ADEQUATE BUT- WHEN
I LOOK AT THE ANALYSIS AND THERE
IS DIFFERENT CATEGORIES
OBVIOUSLY THE PERSON COULD BE
CHARGED OF ONE OF WHICH WOULD
GIVE EIGHT FOURTEEN OR TWENTY
YEARS AND OF COURSE IF THEY HAVE
ADDITIONAL. CRIMES THAT THEY'RE
CHARGED THAT CAN ADD OTHER TIME
OR VERY SEVENTIES ALSO KERRY
ENHANCEMENTS SO I DON'T THINK IT
IS ACCURATE OR FAIR TO DESCRIBE
THAT OUR SENTENCING LAWS WOULD
ONLY ALLOW FOR A HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS TO SERVE SAY TWELVE
YEARS. ON. THIS IS EX EXTREMELY
EMOTIONAL SUBJECT AND-
LEGITIMATELY BECAUSE THOSE WHO
ARE TRAFFICKED THEIR LIVES ARE
SO TORN APART THE TRAUMA IS. IT
MAY NEVER BE ABLE TO BE HEALED
FROM. BUT OUR CHANGING CERTAIN
PARTS OF THE LAW TO A THIRD
STRIKE IS NOT GOING TO ACHIEVE
THAT. AND SO I AM UNABLE TO
SUPPORT THE BILL IS STRUCTURED
TODAY. YES AND THE LAST ONE.
WITH OUR DUE RESPECT DON'T MAKE
ME CRY HEY. FIRST OF ALL TO
SENATOR WIENER'S POINT ABOUT HIS
COMMUNITY. I JUST WANT YOU TO
KNOW THAT- MANY OF US. SEE YOUR
CHILDREN NO MATTER WHERE THEY
ARE. IN THEIR SEXUAL ORIENTATION
AS PRECIOUS. PRECIOUS LITTLE
BEANS ESPECIALLY PEOPLE OF FAITH
LIKE MY- AND THE FACT THAT MANY
OF THEM GO HOMELESS OR KICKED
OUT OF THEIR HOME IS ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY I SUPPORT EVERYTHING
THAT I CAN FOR FOSTER YOUTH. AND
KIDS I DON'T THINK ANY CHILD
SHOULD BE KICKED OUT OF THEIR
HOME. AND AS A MATTER OF FACT
WHEN I LEARNED ABOUT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING R. SEVERAL YEARS
BACK AND BECAME AWARE THANKS TO
DR OPAL SINGLETON AND THE
RESEARCH AND THE WORK THAT SHE
HAS DONE IN THIS FIELD. I
ACTUALLY WENT BACK HOME AND I
SHARED IT WITH MY KIDS AT THE
TIME I HAD A THIRTEEN YEAR OLD.
DAUGHTER AND- SHARE WITH HER
HEALTH PEOPLE ARE GROOMED AND-
RIDE INTO THIS SPACE. AND MY
THIRTEEN YEAR OLD SAID MOM. WE
DON'T KNOW ABOUT THIS WE SHOULD
ALL LEARN HIS THEY NEED TO TELL
EVERYBODY SHE BECAME DESPERATE.
FOR HER FRIENDS AND SCHOOLMATES
TO LEARN ABOUT IT. AS THE FIERCE
MAMA BEAR. EVERY HILD PRECIOUS
AND PROTECTED. WHEN IT COMES TO
THIS BILL. I WANT TO ADDRESS THE
FACT THAT I UNDERSTAND HIS ONCE
AGAIN I WISH I HAD MORE DEPTH.
BUT ONE THING IS CLEAR. LET YOU
FOLKS HAVE EXPRESSED THE FACT
THAT THEY ARE. OTHER CRIMES THAT
ARE CONSIDERED SERIOUS FELONIES
YOU EXPLAIN THAT TODAY EARLIER
IN YOUR TESTIMONY. IT ALSO
EXPRESSED THE EIGHT FOURTEEN AND
TWENTY YEARS BUT ONE THING THAT
. WAS NOTED EARLIER TODAY IS THE
FACT THAT. THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
ARE SENTENCED BUT FOR X. Y. NZ
REASONS ARE RELEASED. AND GO
BACK AND COMMIT THE CRIME AGAIN
. AND IT HAPPENS OVER AND OVER
AGAIN AND I THINK THAT IS WHY WE
HAVE. HELLO THERE IS AN INTENT
OR IT BASICALLY AN INTENT OR
DESIRE TO MAKE THIS A THREE
STRIKES ARE PART OF THE THREE
STRIKES- COMPONENT OR ELEMENT IS
BECAUSE WE WANT TO CURB. THOSE
THAT ARE PERPETRATORS CONTINUES
PERPETRATORS FROM BEING ABLE TO
USE THE SYSTEM. AND BASICALLY
INFLICT HARM ON CHILDREN FULL OF
COLOR WOMEN AND EVEN MEN. I
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE GIVEN
OPPORTUNITY- TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THESE QUESTIONS BECAUSE I'M NOT
AN EXPERT AND I'M JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND BUT I WOULD LOVE TO
GIVE OUR DISTRICT ATTORNEY
O'MALLEY AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THAT WERE EXPRESSED.
RESERVATIONS THAT- THE CRIMINAL
ATTACH- CRIMINAL LAW SUPERVISING
ATTORNEY MS CLARK. STATED AND-
THE A POLICY ASSOCIATE YOUNG
WOMEN'S FREEDOM CENTER- MISS
GRACE AND EXPRESSED. WOULD YOU
MIND ADDRESSING SOME OF THE
ISSUES WITH REGARD TO WHETHER OR
NOT. THEY ARE SEEN THE VICTIMS
ARE SEEN AND WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'RE PROTECTED IF THEY ARE
ARRESTED- IN THIS SPACE. WHEN
SOME OF THE FIRST OF ALL I JUST
WANNA THIS IS BEEN VERY VERY
EMOTIONAL BECAUSE OF EVERYTHING
HAS BEEN EXPRESSED BY THE THREE
SENATORS BY SENATOR BREAUX
SENATOR CAFIERO SO- AND ALL THE
SPEAKERS. WHAT WHAT WE HAVE
CHANGED SO MUCH OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS WHEN I STARTED IN
THIS AS I SAID IN NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN. THERE WAS NOTHING.
OTHER THAN FOR SOMEONE WHO IS
UNDER FOURTEEN AND WE COULD
TREAT IT LIKE CHILD MOLEST. WE
HAVE LEARNED SO MUCH WE HAVE
DONE SO MUCH BUT ONE OF THE
THINGS WE HAVE LEARNED. IS THAT
FIRST OF ALL THAT THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE VICTIMIZED. WHO
THEN CAN FIND THEMSELVES
INVOLVED IN CRIMINAL ACTIVITY.
PART OF WHAT OUR LAW DOES NOW IS
IT. NOT JUST ALLOWS PEOPLE LIKE
ME AND OTHER PROSECUTORS LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO LOOK AT PEOPLE'S
BACKGROUND. AND MOTIVATION AND
PARTICULARLY THEIR VICTIMIZATION
THAT PUT THEM IN A PATH OF.
BEING EITHER EIGHT USED BY A
TRAFFICKER TO COMMIT CRIMES OR
TO. FOR THEIR LIFE SAVING TO
ENGAGE AND SOMETHING LIKE A
RECRUITING OR SOMETHING. I THINK
THAT. WE ARE VERY COGNIZANT OF
THE IMPACT OF TRAFFICKING WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS ALL DAY
. THAT LEADS PEOPLE TO A PLACE
WHERE THEY WOULDN'T OTHERWISE DO
IT. BUT WE DO HAVE LAWS WE DO
HAVE THERE'S A LEGAL DEFENSE IF
SOMEBODY IS ACCUSED OF A CRIME A
pBE USED AT TRIAL DEPENDING ON
THE CRIME. WELL IT IT'S
AVAILABLE- AND THAT'S THAT
BECOME SOMETHING FOR A JURY TO
DECIDE SO I THINK IT ALSO
DEPENDS ON THE MAGNITUDE OF WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. IN MY
COUNTY AND MANY COUNTIES THAT
HAVE BROUGHT FORTH HUMAN
TRAFFICKING EXPERTS TO SIT IN
THE CHAIR THAT I SIT IN. THAT
ONE OF THE THINGS WE ARE LOOKING
AT IS WHAT IS THE WHAT HOW IS IT
THAT A PERSON WHO WAS ONCE
TRAFFIC OR IS ENGAGING IN SOME
CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR WHAT IS THE
ROOT OF THAT. THE SAME ANALYSIS
WERE DOING FOR VICTIMS WE'RE
DOING FOR PEOPLE WHO GET CAUGHT
UP IN CRIME. AND IF IN FACT THE
ROOT OF THEIR CONDUCT. IS
BECAUSE THEY WERE TRAFFICKED AND
THEIR PSYCHOLOGICAL RESPONSE AND
IMPACT OF THAT TRAFFICKING
EXPERIENCE NOW PUTS THEM IN A
DIFFERENT POSITION. THAN THAT IS
TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION FOR
PEOPLE THAT UNDERSTAND AND- MATT
AND HANDLE CASES INVOLVING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING BUT IF SOMEBODY WAS
CONVICTED. THERE ARE VACANT YOUR
LAWS WHICH WE HEARD ABOUT FROM A
MEMBER OF THE OPPOSITION. WE'RE
VERY ACTIVE ACROSS THE STATE
THERE ARE VACANT YOUR LAWS THERE
ARE ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
BRINGING THESE CASES TO OUR
ATTENTION. WE OURSELVES IN
PROSECUTORS OFFICES ARE LOOKING
AT COLD CASES TO SEE WHETHER OR
NOT. THE CRIME WAS COMMITTED
WHILE SOMEONE IS BEING
TRAFFICKED OR AS A RESULT OF
BEING TRAFFICKED. THERE ARE
THERE'S RE SENTENCING LAWS THAT
YOUR LEGISLATURE HAS CREATED
THAT HAS ALLOWED US. MEANING
PROSECUTORS AND TO GO BACK AND
PULL CASES BACK INTO THE COURT
TO SAY THIS SENTENCE IS NOT
WARRANTED WAS NOT WARRANTED WE
CAN RE SENTENCE PEOPLE. AND THEN
LASTLY BUT YOU KNOW WE WHEN
THEY'RE WHEN THEY'RE CHALLENGES
THERE ALSO THE COMMUTATION LAWS
THAT HAVE BECOME. MUCH MORE
AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN CONVICTED OF CRIMES THROUGH
GOVERNOR IS BEEN. VERY
RESPONSIVE. TO HEARING AND
READING ABOUT SOMEBODY'S
BACKGROUND THAT LED TO
CONVICTION SO. I WOULD SAY THAT
PART OF IT IS BRINGING IT FOR
BRINGING THESE OLD CONVICTIONS
IN THESE OLD CIRCUMSTANCES FORD
AND THE LAW HAS GIVEN US YOUR-
TO YOUR CREATION. THE LAW HAS
GIVEN US SEVERAL VEHICLES FOR.
BEING ABLE TO SET ASIDE
CONVICTIONS OR BEING ABLE TO
RESEND SOME SOMEONE IF THEY'RE
STILL INCARCERATED AND BRING
THEM BACK. THERE ARE JUST SO
MANY AREAS AND PARTICULARLY ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT ARE THE
VACANT YOUR LAWS FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE CONVICTED OF CRIMES. WHEN
IT'S DETERMINED THAT WHEN THEY
COMMITTED THAT CRIME THEY WERE
VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
THAT'S THE BASIS OF THE BAKER
LAWS FOR THOSE THAT HAVE BEEN
TRAFFICKED. I HOPE THAT ANSWERS
YOUR QUESTION IT SAYS IT DOES.
AND THEN LASTLY THERE WAS
ANOTHER. UP FOR THE RECORD WOULD
YOU MIND- BECAUSE I KNOW ARE MY
COLLEAGUES ARE VERY VERY FOCUSED
ON RESEARCH AND DATA- IN ORDER
TO SUPPORT POLICY COULD YOU
EXPLAIN THE RESEARCH IN THE DATA
THAT YOU ARE COMING ACROSS WITH
REGARDS TO NOT NECESSARY THAT
PART- THE VICTIMS WHO HAD BEEN-
COMPELLED TO COME INTO THIS INTO
THIS HUMAN TRAFFICKING SPACE BUT
MORE SO THROUGH THE PERPETRATORS
AND SPECIALLY WITH REGARDS TO.
THOSE WHO ARE REPEAT OFFENDERS
THAT CONTINUOUSLY COME BACK AND-
COMMIT THIS CRIME. WELL THERE IS
A LOT OF RESEARCH. AND MORE
EMERGING RESEARCH IN THIS
PARTICULAR AREA TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT THE PSYCHOLOGY OF A PERSON
WHO'S A HUMAN TRAFFICKER SO THAT
IS DIFFERENT IN THAT WHEN WE
FIRST STARTED SEEING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING EMERGING WE ARE
SEEING- PEOPLE THAT WERE
SWITCHING FROM SELLING DRUGS TO
SELLING PEOPLE. YOU KNOW IT
WASN'T THE SAME MENTALITY BUT
WHAT WE DO AND THE RESEARCH IS
NOT SHOWING US IS THAT THERE'S A
HIGH PERCENTAGE OF PSYCHOPATHY
IN INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS THE ONES WHO ARE
HAVE NO HUMAN EMOTION AND
REGARDS TO THE INDIVIDUAL
THEY'RE THEY'RE SELLING. THE ONE
WHO IS USING VIOLENCE SOMETIMES
TO FORCE THEM TO DO TO ENGAGE IN
THAT SEXUAL ACTIVITY SO THERE'S
A HIGH DEGREE OF PSYCHOPATHY AND
THAT IS A VERY INTERESTING. FROM
A PSYCHOLOGICAL STANDPOINT
BECAUSE THE PERCENTAGE OF
INDIVIDUALS IN OUR SOCIETY
ACCORDING TO RESEARCH OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE TRUE PSYCHO PASS OR
HAVE. THAT PSYCHOPATHY IS PRETTY
SMALL BUT IN THE WORLD OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS AT LEAST WITH THE
RESEARCH IS STARTING TO SHOW US
IN THE WORLD OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS THAT. PERCENTAGE OF
THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE CYCLE
PASTOR HAVE PSYCHOPATHY AS PART
OF THEIR MAKE UP IS HIGH. AND
THAT IS VERY SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE
IF A PERSON'S WIRING IF YOU WILL
MENTAL WIRING IS SUCH THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE HUMAN EMPATHY AND
THEY DON'T. THEY DON'T HAVE THAT
KIND OF CARING THAT WE ARE ALL
EXPRESSING HERE- THEN. THERE'S
NO- THERE'S NO INCENTIVE OR
THERE'S NO SOCIAL OF PRESSURE TO
ACT DIFFERENTLY. WHAT THE
RESEARCH IS ALSO SHOWING US IS
THAT FOR HUMAN TRAFFICKERS. AND
THESE ARE ADULTS HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS AND I'M FOLK THAT WE
FOCUS ON THAT THERE'S A
PREDATORY NATURE OF THE CRIME
THERE THE RESEARCH SAYS THAT
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR SOMEBODY TO
LOWER INTO A TRAFFICKING. OR
INTO MODERN DAY SO CAN YOU MAKE
THAT SPECIFIC TO THE I THINK THE
DATA THIS IS RESEARCH BUT HOW
DOES THAT RELATE TO THE- THE
QUESTION OF THERE. THE
SENTENCING AND THE REPEAT
OFFENSE THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DESCRIBE IS THEIR DATA THAT
SHOWS THAT. WELL THERE'S NOT
DATE IN TERMS OF SENTENCING BUT
THEIR STATE IN TERMS OF THE MAKE
UP OF AN INDIVIDUAL RIGHT SO.
BUT SO BASICALLY WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT RIGHT NOW
IS HOW WOULD THAT DATA JUSTIFY.
ON THE NEED FOR- THREE STRIKES
ARE HAVING HUMAN TRAFFICKING BE
PART AS A SEARS AND FELONY. TO
BE CHARGED AS A THREE STRIKES I
THINK THAT'S OR YES SO THANK YOU
I'M I APOLOGIZE I WASN'T SO
FOCUSED ON THAT. THE THREE
STRIKES LAW. ANALYSTS SAY A
STRIKE I MEAN A STRIKE IF YOU
WILL. I IS IT REALLY FOCUSED ON
PEOPLE WHO ARE REPEAT OFFENDERS.
SO IF SOMEBODY COMMITS A STRIKE
CRIMEI WON'T USE ROBBERY
BECAUSE I AGREE ON SOME LEVEL
WITH SENATOR SKINNER. BUT AND
IT'S A SERIOUS VIOLENT FELONY.
AND THEY ARE INCARCERATED AND
THEY COME OUT AND THEY NEVER
COMMIT ANOTHER CRIME. THEN THE
THREE STRIKES LAW REALLY DOESN'T
IMPACT THEM DIRECTLY IN TERMS OF
CAUSING A GREATER SENTENCE IT IS
THE SENTENCE THAT THE PENAL
CODE. ALLOCATE WHERE WHERE I
BELIEVE THIS RESEARCH WILL LEAD
US TO IS THAT SOMEBODY WHO HAS
HAS SITE HAS THE PSYCHOPATHY AND
SOMEBODY WHO. DOESN'T HAVE OR IS
A PREDATOR IN THERE AS THEIR
NATURE OR HAS DISREGARD FOR THE
IMPACT OF THE CRIME THERE'S NO
PSYCHOLOGICAL INCENTIVE NOT TO
CONTINUE THAT BEHAVIOR. SO THREE
STRIKES IS REALLY ABOUT. CAN
CONTINUE TO COMMIT CRIMES AFTER
YOU'VE BEEN COMMITTED CONVICTED
OF A CRIME AND- THE RESEARCH IS
NOT SO SPECIFIC TO SAY HOW DOES
THIS PSYCHOPATHY. FIT INTO
SENTENCING BUT I WOULD ARGUE
THAT THE IF SOMEBODY IS A
PREDATOR AND THEY AREN'T BOUND
BY THE RULES OF SOCIETY AND THEY
HAVE A HIGH DEGREE OF
PSYCHOPATHY AND PREDATORY NATURE
THAT THERE'S- NOTHING TO STOP
THEM ONCE THEY'RE BACK OUT IN
THE FREE SOCIETY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR MALLEY- TO OUR MEMBERS
HAVE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. IN
THIS CASE I DON'T KNOW. THANK
YOU S. SINNERS SCANNER WE- AT
CENTER GROVE WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
YES MA'AM THANK YOU. M. I WANT
TO ADDRESS A MISS GRAYSON AT
FIRST AS A REBUTTAL WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT BECAUSE OF WHAT SHE WENT
THROUGH IN HER STORY IN THE
OPPOSITION. I WANT TO BE CLEAR
TO MISS GRACE AND THAT SHE
MATTERS. AND I WAS GOING TO BE
CLEAR TO MISCREANTS AND THAT
THIS BILL TEN FORTY TWO DOES NOT
AFFECT PIMPING AND PANDERING OR
DRESS PIMPING AND PANDERING AT
ALL. IN ANY WAY SHAPE OR FORM.
TEN FORTY TWO ONLY APPLIES TO
SECTION CODE TO THIRTY SIX POINT
ONE WHICH- WHICH A MYSTERY SCENE
REPRESENTED AS THE PROSTITUTION
OR SEX WORK REFERENCED IN SIX
FORTY SEVEN WHICH THIS BILL DOES
NOT TOUCH. SO FOR YEARS BEFORE
THAT BALLOT MEASURE WAS PASSED
INDIVIDUALS LIKE MISS GRACE AND
WERE ARRESTED AND NOT TREATED AS
VICTIMS. AND NOW THEY ARE THAT
MR GRAYSON WAS SENTENCED PRIOR
TO THAT AND THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING. SO I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVEN CURRENTLY MOVING
FORWARD WITH TEN FORTY TWO THIS
IS NOT A DRESS PIMPING AND
PANDERING. I ALSO WANTED TO
ADDRESS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
OAKLAND. AND SAY I DEEPLY
RESPECT YOU BOTH OF YOU YOU'RE
ALWAYS ON THE LISTEN TALK THINGS
OUT WE DON'T AGREE. A LOT. BUT
THERE IS A GENUINE KINDNESS AND
DEFENSE FOR HOW YOU THINK ANY
RESPECT HELLO I THINK. ON ISSUES
THIS IS ESPECIALLY DIFFICULT
ONES LIKE THIS AND I DON'T MEAN
TO. IT'S JUST THIS IS A VERY
HARD SUBJECT MATTER. AND TO MY
COLLEAGUE TO BERKELEY WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT IT'S NOT ALWAYS
ABOUT REFORM. IT'S NOT ALWAYS
ABOUT SOMEBODY COMING OUT OF THE
PRISON SYSTEM TO BE A BETTER
PERSON NOW WE HAVE PEOPLE IN
THIS BUILDING THAT HAVE DONE
THAT COME AT THE PRISON SYSTEM
IN GAME THREE EMPLOYED- DO THE
RIGHT THINGS. BUT SOMETIMES IT'S
NOT ALWAYS ABOUT REFORM IT'S
ABOUT JUSTICE AND TO BE FRANK
IT'S ABOUT PUNISHMENT.
PUNISHMENT FOR WHAT PEOPLE DO TO
OTHER HUMAN BEINGS. ADD TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
AGAIN DEEP RESPECT YOU WERE
ALWAYS SO KIND TO ME EVERY TIME
I COME TO YOU AND- HAVE ISSUES
OR A BILL. AND THE COMMUNITY
THAT YOU REPRESENT. THEM WHEN
YOU SAID MY COMMUNITY. MY HEART
BREAKS FOR THAT COMMUNITY
BECAUSE RESEARCHING THE SPILL
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT. THERE
ARE MORE VICIOUS CRIMES
PERPETRATED AGAINST TRANSGENDER
AND L. G. B. T. Q. INDIVIDUALS
IN THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING SPACE.
THE ANY OTHER. F. ANY OTHER
SECTOR. AND THERE WAS A WITNESS
THAT TESTIFIED ABOUT HOW THIS
HURTS BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES THE BILL DOES IT
HURT BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES
IT'S EVIDENCE IN STUDIES THAT
WERE BROUGHT FORTH BY THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT DOWN IN THAT AREA.
THAT OVER 50% OF THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE TRAFFICKED SEX TRAFFICKED
ARE BLACK AND BROWN. MY WITNESS.
FROM KERN COUNTY IS BLACK AND
SHE STOOD BEFORE ALL OF YOU
YESTERDAY MAYBE NOT MISS SKINNER
BECAUSE SHE WAS VERY VERY
NERVOUS ABOUT MEETING A SENATOR
. AND SHE SAID THAT DURING THE
SLAVERY DAYS THEY STOOD ON THE
AUCTION BLOCK. NAKED AS PEOPLE
WALKED BY AND THEY WERE SOLD TO
THE HIGHEST BIDDER. AT TODAY
THAT'S JUST THE LOCATION CHANGE
THEY'RE STILL. GRADED OUT ON THE
STREETS OR IN THIS CASE A HOTEL
ROOM NAKED AND SOLD TO THE
HIGHEST BIDDER. THIS IS A VERY-
EMOTIONAL AND EMOTIONALLY
CHARGED SUBJECT MATTER. WHEN I
ASKED MY STAFF TO PUT TOGETHER.
A A LIST OF THINGS WERE NOT
CONSIDERED SERIOUS AND VIOLENT
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I
WAS ACTUALLY THINKING OF SMASH
AND GRABS. CARRYING A PICKAXE IN
WALGREENS BECAUSE NEVER EVER IN
A MILLION YEARS DID I EVER THINK
THAT HUMAN TRAFFICKING THE
BUYING AND SELLING OF A HUMAN
BEING WAS NOT CONSIDERED SERIOUS
OR VIOLENT. THE MIUTE LAB READ
A LITTLE BIT ON DISTRICT
GOVERNMENT ATTORNEY O'MALLEY'S
COMMENTS BECAUSE- M. AS JUST A
RESPONSE TO YOUR QUESTIONS. TO
MAKE THIS A SERIOUS AND VIOLENT
FELONY IN A STRIKING AGAIN I'M
NO LEGAL EXPERT. BUT IT DOESN'T
AFFECT THE FIRST SENTENCE TWELVE
YEARS. THIRTEEN YEARS BUT IF
THEY GET OUT IF THEY GO TO
PRISON HAND THEY GET PICTURES
OFF FOR GOOD BEHAVIOR IN A TIME
AND DAY SERVED IN ALL THE THINGS
THAT WE ALLOW. AND THEY GET BACK
OUT ON THE STREET AND THEY RE
OFFEND. AS A TRAFFICKER. IF THIS
BILL WAS TO PASS. THEY COULD
HAVE A STRIKE AND THEY WOULD
HAVE ENHANCED SEVERE. PUNISHMENT
PENALTIES. AND I KNOW I JUST MY
COLLEAGUE AND I FROM SAN
FRANCISCO DEEPLY I DEEPLY
RESPECT BUT WE DO DISAGREE
BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE THAT SOME
THINGS. SHOULD BE ABOUT
PUNISHMENT. SO IN CLOSING I'D
LIKE TO THINK OF. MY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY CYNTHIA ZIMMER TO HAVE
THE COURAGE TO BRING THIS
FOURTH. AND N. B. THAT THE
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL I WANT TO
THANK VERY LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY IN THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE SURVIVAL
ORGANIZATIONS NONPROFITS. AND
PEOPLE THAT TESTIFIED ON THE
PHONE FROM ALL OVER THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
TO BRING JUSTICE TO THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN VIOLENTLY. I AM
ASSAULTED. I WILL ALSO TELL YOU
THAT THE DEFINITION OF SLAVERY
IS A CONDITION OF A HUMAN BEING
BEING OWNED BY ANOTHER SLAVE WAS
CONSIDERED LAW AS PROPERTY OR
CHATTEL AND WAS DEPRIVED OF MOST
OF THE RIGHTS ORDINARILY HELD BY
FREE PERSONS HUMAN TRAFFICKING
LIKE MY CONSTITUENT ODESSA
PERKINS SAID YESTERDAY. IS
MODERN DAY SLAVERY AND SHE IS
HERE ALONG WITH OTHER WITNESSES
THAT TESTIFIED. ON BEHALF OF
MILLIONS OF VICTIMS THAT THIS IS
MODERN DAY SLAVERY. TRAFFICKED
VICTIMS ARE OWNED BY OTHER
PEOPLE THEY ARE DEPRIVED OF MOST
OF THE RIGHTS HELD BY OTHERS
THEY ARE CONSIDERED PROPERTY
SOME ARE EVEN TATTOOED FOR
BRANDED TO PROVE OWNERSHIP.
THEY'RE A SLAVE TO SEX OR LABOR
TRAFFICKERS. A VOTE TODAY TO NOT
SUPPORT THIS BILL WILL BE
SENDING A MESSAGE I BELIEVE TO
THE CURRENT VICTIMS AND
SURVIVORS OF THIS GROTESQUE
CRIME BUT ESPECIALLY THE
TRAFFICKERS THEMSELVES THAT THEY
DON'T NEED TO TAKE THIS CRIME
SERIOUS AND IT'S NOT SERIOUS
ENOUGH TO BE CONSIDERED A STRIKE
. THE VOTE NO I DO BELIEVE THAT
I THINK YOU'RE SAYING THAT YOUR-
YOU'RE SUPPORTING NOT SUPPORTING
THAT. YOU AGREE THAT SELLING A
HUMAN BEING IS NOT A SERIOUS
VIOLENT FELONY. I URGE YOU TO
LISTEN TO THE EXPERTS IN THIS
FIELD AND I REALIZE THEY'RE
EXPERTS ON BOTH SIDES OF THIS
ISSUE. BUT I THINK THE ANALYSIS
HAD A LOT OF ERRORS IN IT. AND I
THINK THE PEOPLE ON THE GROUND
THAT PROSECUTE THESE CRIMES THAT
NEED THE TOOLS IN THEIR TOOLBOX
TO MAKE SURE. THAT THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PERPETRATE THESE
CRIMES LIKE THE MOTHER WHO
TESTIFIED REAL BRIEFLY. IN THE
ME TOO SECTION. AS SHE TESTIFIED
AT THE PRESS CONFERENCE TODAY N.
M. ONE OF THE INDIVIDUALS GOT
OUT JUST AFTER A FEW MONTHS. SHE
WATCHED HER DAUGHTER GET RATE
SHE WATCHED HER DAUGHTER GET
BEATEN. AND THERE'S GOTTA BE
HARSHER PENALTIES FOR PEOPLE WHO
WOULD BE WILLING TO PERPETRATE
THAT AGAINST ANOTHER HUMAN BEING
. I TOLD MY ALL MY WITNESSES AND
EVERYBODY THAT CALLED IN ON THE
PHONE WE ONLY NEED THREE VOTES.
WE HAVE A JOINT DEMOCRAT. AUTHOR
IN WE HAVE THIRTEEN DEMOCRAT CO
AUTHORS SO THIS IS TRULY A
BIPARTISAN BILL. AND WE NEED
THREE VOTES TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION TO MAKE ADJUSTMENTS
TO THIS BILL WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE SO THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE
OUR TRAFFICKED VICTIMS AND
SURVIVORS ARE TAKING CARE OF.
BUT THERE IS ALSO A JUST
PUNISHMENT FOR THE CRIMES THAT
THE COMMIT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I. BOAT. THE BILL. SENATOR
OCHO IT GAVE ME BACK THE GAVEL
SO THAT SHE COULD MOVE THE BILL
. WE WILL TAKE A VOTE. CENTER
GROVE THIS IS THE MOST DIFFICULT
COMMITTEE TO SERVE ON. THE
THINGS THAT COME BEFORE US. THE
EXPERIENCES OF VICTIMS AND THIS
ONE OF THIS PARTICULAR CRIME THE
EXPERIENCES OF VICTIMS. I MEAN I
DON'T WANT TO PUT. AND WHEN WE
TALK FOR EXAMPLE. AROUND RAPE
SITUATIONS AND JUST FIFTY A.
O'MALLEY IS BROUGHT MANY BILLS
WHERE WE TRIED TO FIX WHERE WE
HAD WE'VE HAD YEARS WHERE.
PROSECUTORS AND OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT WOULD NOT TREAT RAPE
SERIOUSLY WE HAD REVENUE FOR
YEARS JUST IGNORED AND SIT ON
SHELVES. AND IF I DON'T NEED TO
GO INTO GREAT DETAIL BUT THE
TYPES OF. STORIES EXPERIENCES I
DON'T WANT TO MINIMIZE THE
STORIES BUT THE PERSONAL
EXPERIENCES OF PEOPLE THAT COME
TO THIS COMMITTEE EITHER THAT
THERE THEY WERE THEMSELVES THE
VICTIM OF A HORRIFIC CRIME OR
THEY HAD A CHILD OR A MURDER
RAPE HUMAN TRAFFICKING YOUR NAME
IS IT IS THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST
EMOTIONALLY TOILING COMMIT. AND
OUR LAWS ARE NOT PERFECT BY ANY
MEANS. AND THERE ARE CERTAINLY
PERHAPS WE SHOULD HAVE A WHOLE
DIFFERENT SYSTEM OF EVALUATING A
CRIMINAL ON THE ON THE FROM THE
POINT OF VIEW OF THEIR- IF THEY
ARE SOCIAL PATH. AND- WHAT. WE
WOULD PROBABLY FIND THERE'S A
NUMBER OF CATEGORIES OF CRIMES
THAT PROBABLY ATTRACT SOCIOPATHS
MORE THAN OTHERS. AND YET WE
DON'T HAVE A SENSING SYSTEM THAT
TRIES TO IDENTIFY THAT. SO WE
ARE TRYING NOW TO DEVELOPERS WE
ARE TRYING NOW TO DEAL WITH THE
CREW- THE EXISTING SENSING
SYSTEM WITH THE TOOLS THAT ARE
BEFORE US. AND CLEARLY YOU HAVE
MADE A VERY- VERY PASSIONATE
ARTICULATE. AND ONE. SOMETHING
THAT MANY PEOPLE COULD SUPPORT
AS TO WHY WE SHOULD MAKE THIS
CHANGE. AS YOU HEARD IN I DO NOT
NEED TO SAY THIS IN ANY WAY TO
RUB IT IN FOR ANYONE WHO IS NOT
GOING TO APPRECIATE THAT THIS
BILL MAY NOT. BE SUPPORTED TODAY
. THAT I FEEL THAT WE HAVE MORE
BIT MORE. LAWS ON THE BOOKS THAT
CAN BE USED AGAINST THESE
PERPETRATORS. AND WE HAVE TO IN
THIS COMMITTEE WAY THE FULL
AMOUNT OF. OF TOOLS THAT A
PROSECUTOR HAS EVEN WON THE
PROSECUTORS DON'T FEEL THEY'RE
ADEQUATE OR INDIVIDUAL
PROSECUTORS DON'T END THERE OF
COURSE ENTITLED TO THAT AND
THAT'S WHAT OUR ANALYSIS THAT'S
WHAT OUR KID STAFF IN THE
COMMITTEE ARE TRYING TO DO WHEN
THEY PROVIDE THAT ANALYSIS TO US
AND OF COURSE YOU KNOW I'VE HAD
TIMES WHERE BILLS OF MINE I
DIDN'T AGREE WITH ANALYSIS
THREAT. THAT ALWAYS CAN BE
DEBATED. BUT I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT. HOWEVER ANY OF US BOTH
TODAY IT IS NOT BECAUSE THE-
WHAT WAS PRESENTED TO US WAS NOT
COMPELLING FOR. YOU POWERFUL IT
WAS THAT WE ARE WE ARE LOOKING
AT THE FACTS AND MAKING
CONCUSIONS IN. IN DIFFERENT
WAYS SO WITH THAT WE WILL TAKE A
VOTE WE HAVE A MOTION. ON THE
VOTE THE MOTION WOULD BE TO PASS
AND SEND TO- TO GO TO A POPE'S
APPROPRIATIONS PHYLLIS SEVERAL
CALLS ABOUT. S. B. TEN FORTY THE
PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS SCANNER
NOT VOTING SCANNER NOT VOTING
TROUBLED I TROUBLE GUY COM
LONGER WINNER. WINNER NOW. WE
CAN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST
A RECONSIDERATION WE CAN GRANT
THAT. A PETITION FOR
RECONSIDERATION THANK YOU FOR
REMINDING ME THEN WE WILL GRANT
RECONSIDERATION THANK YOU MA'AM
YOU'RE WELCOME.
YES I'VE BEEN HERE THE WHOLE.
ALL. OKAY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. OBVIOUSLY THIS BILL BE MUCH
MUCH EASIER TO PRESENT THEY
LISTEN TO AND- AND I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME- MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
TO PRESENT SENATE BILL ELEVEN
THIRTY THREE WHICH CLARIFIES
EXISTING LAW FOR WHEN A STATE OF
EMERGENCY IS DECLARED TO ENSURE
BETTER COMPLIANCE AND
PROTECTIONS FOR CONSUMERS IN THE
MARKET PLACE. THE ANTI PRICING
GOUGING LAW THAT IS TRIGGERED
AFTER A STATE OF EMERGENCY
DECLARED PROHIBITS MANY
INDUSTRIES FROM INCREASING
PRICES MORE THAN 10% THE PENALTY
FOR VIOLATING THIS LAW INCLUDE
FINES AND JAIL TIME DUE TO PENAL
CODE SECTION THREE NINETY SIX
SECTION THREE NINETY SIX WAS
SIGNED INTO LAW IN NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR TO PROTECT CITIZENS
FROM EXCESSIVE AND UNJUSTIFIED
INCREASES IN PRICES CHARGED FOR
GOODS AND SERVICES. THAT ARE
VITAL AND NECESSARY FOR THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF CONSUMERS
RESULTING FROM ABNORMAL DIS
DISRUPTIONS OF THE MARKET.
ALTHOUGH THE PRICE GOUGING
LIMITATIONS WAS ONLY INTENDED TO
APPLY FOR THIRTY DAYS STATE AND
LOCAL OFFICIALS HAVE EXTENDED
NUMEROUS STATE OF EMERGENCIES
FOR MONTHS EVEN YEARS THERE BY-
MAKING THE CORRECT THIRTY DAY
PERIOD. UNKNOWN TO THE GENERAL
PUBLIC OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS
SOME EMERGENCY DUE TO CORPORATE
NINETEEN AND WILDFIRES AND
DROUGHTS HAVE YET TO BE ENDED.
UNFORTUNATELY THESE EXTENSIONS
ARE NOT ALWAYS MADE PUBLIC BY
STATE AND LOCAL OFFICIALS WHICH
LEAVES BUSINESSES CONFUSED ON
HOW TO PROPERLY COMPLY WITH
EXISTING LAW. SENATE BILL ELEVEN
THIRTY THREE FIXES THIS PROBLEM
BY REQUIRING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES TO KEEP AN
UPDATE UP TO DATE WEBSITE
REGARDING ALL DECLARED EMERGENCY
PROCLAMATIONS AT THIS POINT I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH ME ON SENATE BILL ELEVEN
THIRTY THREE IN FACT I HAVE THE
AUTHOR AMENDMENTS BUT I WILL BE
TAKING IF APPROVED BY THE CHAIR.
ADDRESSES ALL THE ISSUES RAISED
IN THE ANALYSIS. OF THE MEMBERS
TO- WHAT DO THE FOLLOWING
REQUIRE SPECIFIC FINDINGS
RELATED TO HOUSING IN ORDER TO
CONTINUE THE STATE OF EMERGENCY
THAT EXISTS BEYOND ONE YEAR.
DELETE THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND RENT CONTROL HOUSING
EXEMPTIONS FROM THE BILL THESE
ARE MOMENTS AND BEEN TAKEN AND
SET A PRICE GOUGING CAP OF 10%
PER YEAR HOWEVER UPON FURTHER
NEGOTIATIONS WITH COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO CUT
THIS- PIECE RIGHT OUT OF THE
BILL AS WELL. HAVING SAID ALL
THIS AS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES TO KEEP AN UP TO DATE
WEBSITE AND ONLY REQUIRE FINANCE
RELATED TO HOUSING TO CONTINUE A
STATE OF EMERGENCY THAT EXTENDS
BEYOND ONE YEAR. AS AMENDED THIS
BILL WILL STRIKE A BALANCE
BETWEEN PROTECTING OUR
CONSTITUENTS- DEVASTATED BY
EMERGENCIES WHILE ALSO
CONSIDERING THE IMPACTS WERE
RENTAL UNIT OWNERS HOMEOWNERS
WHO HAVE BEEN HIT HARD AS WELL.
FOR THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
AFTER I VOTE IN HERE WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND
TO HAVE ANY ANSWERS ON TECHNICAL
ISSUES- ANSWERED AS TONY BY YOU
REPRESENTING THE SPONSOR OF THE
BILL AND HE IS HERE TODAY- IF
YOU HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS MADAM CHAIR SO- BEFORE
WE START WITH OUR LEAD WITNESS-
SENATOR. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR-
ARTICULATING THE AMENDMENTS
REALLY APPRECIATE IT I WANT TO
JUST- AND I MAY NOT OF HEARD IT
BUT I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT
YOU'RE ALSO TAKING THE AMENDMENT
THAT SHOWS THAT THAT THREE
NINETY SIX B. ONLY. APPLIES TO
NON RENTAL HOUSING. YEAH MA'AM
OKAY. AND THEN- WE COULD DO THIS
IN THE END BUT THERE'S AN
OUTSTANDING AMENDMENT THAT WAS
STILL GOING TO BE A DISCUSSED IN
WOULD BE TAKEN AT THE NEXT
COMMITTEE BUT THAT'S THE ONE
ABOUT THE- THE NO LAW GOVERNING
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN A RENTAL UNIT
BECOMES VACANT DURING A STATE OF
EMERGENCY AND THAT WE WOULD WORK
OUT SOMETHING THAT WOULD ADDRESS
TRYING TO PREVENT EXCESSIVE
BRANDED YES HE WAS ACTING
MANAGER WE TRY TO CLEAN IT UP
RIGHT SO I COULD BRING IT BEFORE
USE HAPPINESS POSSIBLE WONDERFUL
I APPRECIATE AND THEN SENATOR
WIENER DID YOU EVER QUESTION
ANOTHER QUESTION I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE OUR- FULLY UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S NOW IN THE BILL AND I
THINK I UNDERSTAND BUT I'M VERY.
GOOD AT SO I HADA- IN ADDITION
TO THE ITEMS THAT THAT THE CHAIR
MENTIONS- SO AND I THINK YOU
SAID IS THAT THE 10% INCREASE
WILL WILL REMAIN AS IS THE
SERVERS ARE OVER THE LIFE OF A
STATE OF EMERGENCY UP 210% CAP
NOT 10% PER YEAR- THE- YES
WEBSITE REQUIREMENT WILL STAY-
AND THEN THE FINDINGS ISSUE
WILL- THE- AFTER. FINDINGS THAT
IT- RELATES TO HOUSING- ROOTED
SIMMERED SEE IMPACTS HOUSING-
HAS TO BE IT FOR ONLY THE LAST
FOR MORE THAN A YEAR IT'S NOT
THE BEGINNING- AND THEN- RENT
CONTROLLED HOUSING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WILL REMAIN SUBJECT TO-
THE RENDELL'S DOING PROTECTIONS
YES SIR THAT'S ALL I CARE THAT'S
EXACTLY RIGHT RUSSIA AND- THAT'S
WHY WE WANTED TO MAKE THE
AMENDMENTS AND CLARIFY
EVERYTHING AS WE CAN ALONG
RATHER THAN DO IT LATER BECAUSE
THAT'S WHY I STARTED OUT AS A
PRETTY SIMPLE BILL BECAUSE OF
THE WORK THAT THE CHAIRS AND
I'VE WORKED OUT WITH STAFF AND
IF YOU STILL NEED ANY TECHNICAL
HAVE ANY TECH TO QUESTIONS-
WIDELY HERE REAL FAIR TO NOT
FROM OUR LEAGUE. THIS IS- GO
AHEAD MR RUIZ THERE YOU GO THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR CERTAINLY THANK
YOU SENATOR- THANK YOU COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND CHAIR- TWENTY BUT
WITH THE A CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION THAT WE ARE THE
SPONSORS OF SB ONE ONE THREE
THREE- AS WE ALL KNOW THE
EMERGENCY SERVICE ACT ENABLES
THEGOVERNOR'S DECLARED STATE OF
EMERGENCIES TO ALLOW.
GOVERNMENTS TO RESPOND TO THIS
VAST AS IN. AND PANDEMICS LIKE
COLD QUICK- AND OVER THE COURSE.
OF THE PANDA. THERE'S BEEN FIVE
HUNDRED ONE- STATE EMERGENCY
PROPERLY THAT WERE DECLARED. AND
WITH THOSE HUNDRED
APPROXIMATIONS HAVE BEEN
DECLARED LOCALLY AND STATEWIDE.
THE NEED TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
ORDER IS IN EFFECT AND HOW IT
APPLIES. IS CRUCIAL. FOR
COMPLAINTS IN THE MARKETPLACE AT
THE CENTRE MENTIONED-
UNFORTUNATELY IT IS TOUGH TO
UNDERSTAND- CURRENT LA AND- I'M
SORRY. AN UNFORTUNATE COLONEL
MAKES IT TOUGH FOR LANDLORDS TO
KNOW IF THEIR UNITS. ARE INDEED
SUBJECT TO THE ANTI PRICE
GOUGING LAW. WHICH IS TRIGGERED-
WHEN DECORATIONS CALLED- THIS
BILL PROVIDES YOU THE CLARITY AS
OUTLINED BY SENATOR ARCH LETTER.
THAT WILL HELP- INSUREDS FROM
THE COMPLAINTS IN THE
MARKETPLACE. FOR BUSINESSES AND
RENTAL PROPERTY OWNERS ALIKE.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECT THE US
RIVAL. THANK YOU- AND MISTER
BERRY FOR. THAT OVER THE CHANGES
IN THE UP POSITION OF THE
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION THE
SPONSORS. ALL RIGHT LET US SEE
IF THERE ARE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO WANT TO TEST
FIND SUPPORT. ALRIGHT THEN WE'LL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR
YOU WANNA QFC- PHONE LINES TO-
TO THOSE ON THE PHONE TO SEE IF
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF SB ELEVEN THIRTY THREE. YES
THANK YOU. WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
SB ELEVEN THIRTY THREE PRESS
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
LET'S GIVE US SUPPORT FOR S.
THREE ONE ONE THREE THREE. WE'RE
GONNA LIE NUMBER THREE THIRTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THERE
ARE GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS GREEN TREE YEAH THEY
HAVE TO CALIFORNIA THE TEACHER
REALTORS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND ONCE AGAIN RAISED WHO ARE
SUPPORTIVE THAT'S THE ONE ONE
THREE THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THE TIME. THANK YOU
PERSONALLY WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT GREAT LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S A I DON'T KNOW IF WE
HAVE. EARLY- FOR TO MANY PIECES
OF PAPER THE FIRM. WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY OKAY SIR
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IS THE WEEDS LEAVES
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION AS- THAT
PERSON I THINK IS ON THE LINE
SO- MODERATOR PLEASE ALLOW OUR
LEAD OPPOSITION TO- PRESENT
THEIR TESTIMONY. GOOD AFTERNOON
FOUR NINE FROM THE AUTHOR YES WE
CAN'T. OKAY WONDERFUL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AFTERNOON HEARING
MEMBERS MY NAME AND THE NUMBER
OF VIOLENCE ON BEHALF OF THE
WESTERN CENTER ON I'M PRETTY
VOCAL ON BEHALF OF YOUR ROLE
LEGAL FOUNDATION. AND THAT SURE
WE'RE CLOSE THE DELL CURRENTLY
IN FRANCE HOWEVER IT REPEATEDLY
AFTER THE MOMENT LATE LAST NIGHT
WE JUST HAVEN'T HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO FULLY EVALUATE
THE AMENDMENT. NO WELL THEY YOU
APPEAR TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
MANY CONCERNS WE HAVE TERRIBLE
FROM PARTS I NEED IT HE WORKED
OUT VERY VERY MUCH SO IN ORDER
FOR US TO CONTINUE TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION WE URGE THIS
COMMITTEE TO HOLD THE BILLING
AND THAT. FROM NEXT YEAR YOU CAN
KEEP TALKING IT GROW AND ALLOW
FOR A MORE ROBUST CONVERSATION
WITH THE. OFFICER AND- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU THAT WAS
WAY CENTER KEENER'S ARE SO
THAT'S ONLY LEADER THIS IS LET'S
SEE IF THERE'S ANY OPPOSITION IN
THE ROOM WHO WANTS TO- TESTIFIED
AGAINST THE BILL. ALL RIGHT
MODERATOR SEE IF THERE'S ANY
OTHER PHONES- PUBLIC WHO WANT TO
SPEAK ON THE PHONE IN OPPOSITION
AND IN THIS CASE NOW YOU WOULD
JUST BE SAYING YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND THAT YOUR
POSITION. THANK YOU. YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION AS THE ELEVEN THIRTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN THAT
OPPOSITION. AND YOUR PERSON AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
GREAT ALL RIGHT SO WE HAVE HEARD
FROM THE PUBLIC AND-
STAKEHOLDERS- LET'S TURN BACK TO
OUR- COMMITTEE MEMBERS GO AHEAD
SENATOR WIENER. I'M ALSO HAPPY
TO MOVE THE BILL- HELLO I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND SPONSOR
FOR WORKING WITH- WITH- WORKING
WITH US TO ON THE COMMITTEE TO.
REALLY TRUST SOME OF THE ISSUES-
FIVE BUT I THINK THE CHANGES I'M
REALLY POSITIVE- AND I KNOW IT
SEEMS LIKE THE HEART OF THE BILL
IS I THINK I DON'T WANT TO.
SPECULATE BUT I THINK IT'S ABOUT
THE- YES WEBSITE SEEMS LIKE. A
VERY IMPORTANT THAT YOU DON'T
CALL THE HEART OF THE GOVERNOR
VERY IMPORTANT. PIECE AND I
REALLY- SYMPATHETIC TO THE
FRUSTRATION THAT. LANDLORDS AND
FRANKLY TENANTS- WHO WANT TO
KNOW LIKE WHAT'S THE SCOPE OF-
PARTICULAR EMERGENCY AND KNOW
WHAT THE REAL EVERYONE SHOULD
KNOW WHAT THE RULES. ARE AND I
WAS SURPRISED TO LEARN THAT.
SURPRISED NOT SURPRISED I'M NOT-
YES THAT'S A REALLY GOOD JOB IN
A LOT OF WAYS BUT JUST GIVEN
GOVERNMENT IN GENERAL GOVERNMENT
WEBSITES ARE NOT ALWAYS KNOWN-
FOR BEING- AS OF TODAY AS A-
NEED TO BE THE CDC WEBSITE FOR
EXAMPLE SOMETIMES I GO THERE
AND- IT'S OUT OF DATE AND CVC-
SO- I THINK ANYTHING WE CAN DO
TO GET. THAT WBSITE UP TO DATE
FOR EVERYONE'S BENEFIT IS
IMPORTANT. AND SO I KNOW THEY'LL
BE CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS
WITH- OPPONENTS ON BUT I THINK
THIS IS A REALLY POSITIVE STOP
AND SO I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BALL- AND BEFORE YOU CLOSE
SENATOR ARCHULETA ID. I THINK
THE OTHER PORTION IS OF COURSE-
YOU KNOW THERE'S BEEN CRITICISM
THAT- SOME OF THE STATES OF
EMERGENCY HAVE LASTED LONGER
THAN A YEAR THOUGH I THINK THAT
IN. WHAT IS BEEN DEMONSTRATES
THAT A NUMBER OF THESE
EMERGENCIES REALLY DO YOU HAVE
IMPLICATIONS LONGER THAN A YEAR
IF WE TAKE FOR EXAMPLE THE FIRE
IN PARADISE PARADISE. IT WAS FAR
MORE THAN A YEAR. BEFORE MANY OF
THE PEOPLE DISPLACED. WERE ABLE
TO GET- THEIR HOUSING REPLACED
AND IF HOUSING WAS AVAILABLE.
FOR THOSE WHO DID YOU KNOW WHO
HAD LOST THEIR- HOMES AND WE'RE
STILL TRYING TO GET THEM
REPLACED WE CERTAINLY WANT. THIS
KIND OF PROTECTION FOR THAT
RIGHT WE DON'T WANT THEM- AND OF
COURSE WE KNOW THAT. ALL OWNERS
OF HOUSING OR NOT. FIVE PRICE
CHARACTERS BUT WE CERTAINLY WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
PROTECTED HEN THEY HAVE BEEN
THE VICTIMS OF KINDS OF
EMERGENCIES. AND THERE CERTAINLY
I COULD GIVE OTHER EXAMPLES
WHERE. AND YET THEY'RE SOME OF
THE STATE'S EMERGENCY WHERE IT
MAY BE LEGITIMATE FOR THE
GOVERNOR TO HAVE TO RE CLARIFY
WHY HOUSING IS STILL AN ISSUE IN
THAT STATE OF. AMENDMENTS THAT
YOU'VE AGREED TO WHEN YOU WERE
AT WORK OUT I THINK THAT IT IS
LEAST HAD SOME CLARITY ABOUT.
NUMBER ONE PEOPLE KNOW. THAT
THIS IS IN EFFECT AND THEY CAN
GO TO OUR WEBSITE AND FIND OUT
IN NUMBER TWO THAT YOU CAN BE
REAFFIRMED YOU KNOW WHY THIS
PARTICULAR NEED OF PREVENTING
THE PRICE GOUGING AND HOUSING
NEEDS TO CONTINUE. SO WILL- LET
YOU CLOSE AND THEN WE'LL TAKE
ABOUT- MANAGER THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND I URGE YOUR I THOUGHT. ALL
RIGHT SO IT'S SEVERAL CALLS AND
IT WOULD BE- TO PASS AS AMENDED
WITH THE- WITH TWO MINUTES STILL
TO BE WORKED OUT AND- IT GOES TO
APPROPRIATIONS OKAY GREAT. A B.
R. S. B. ELEVEN THIRTY THREE
SKINNER BY SKINNER I INTRO BOGUE
TROUBLE GUY KAMAGRA. KAMAGRA I
WINNER WINNER I. FORTY ZERO.
EXCELLENT THAT BILL IS OUT AND
THEN WE HAVE NOW HAVE SENATOR
GORGEOUS AND- THANK YOU VERY.
MUCH FOR CHILLS OUT FOR ZERO-
AND WE HAVE A HARD STOP AT FIVE
. ONE SENATOR- PHOTOBOOK I'M
HERE DO THEY LIKE JUST FOR A
MOMENT I WILL BE RIGHT BACK AND-
WE'LL PROCEED I WILL BE RIGHT
BACK. FOR SUCH A HIGH TECH
BUILDING SCOTT YOU MIGHT
APPRECIATE IT THIS SHOULD. I'VE
I'VE I STOPPED MAKING JOKES
ABOUT IT AFTER LIKE THE FIFTH
HEARING BECAUSE I BECAME LIKE
THAT GUY THIS IS MY FIRST TIME
IN THIS. HERBAL THE RAISED THE
ISSUE. HAHA I LOVE IT THEY'RE
GOING TO FIX IT. TO START SAYING
THAT I ACTUALLY LIKE IT TOP
RATED PERFECT. I FEEL LIKE WE
GOT DELAYED INTO. A STOOL.
WELCOME SENATOR PORTIONS PLEASE
PROCEED WELCOME I THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE IT- THANK YOU A MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT S. B.
THIRTEEN THIRTY A BILL THAT
SEEKS TO CLOSE A LOOPHOLE IN OUR
CURRENT FETAL KERR AS IT RELATES
TO THREATS DIRECTED AT SCHOOLS
AND PLACES OF WORSHIP. SOME OF
YOU WHO WERE SERVING ON THIS
COMMITTEE IN TWENTY NINETEEN MAY
RECALL HEARING A SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR BILL AT THE TIME IT WAS
B. B. NINE OH SEVEN AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLYMAN GRAYSON. THE BILL
RECEIVED SUBSTANTIAL BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT FROM THIS COMMITTEE AND
I WANT TO THANK ALL THOSE NOT
HERE CHAIRMAN BRADFORD- AND
SENATORS SO SKINNER AND WIENER
FOR SUPPORTING THAT EFFORT BACK
THEN IN HOPE- TO A CORNER THAT
SEEM SUPPORT TODAY FOR S. B.
THIRTEEN THIRTY. SCHOOLS AND
PLACES OF WORSHIP ALL ACROSS
CALIFORNIA HAVE SEEN AN UPTICK
IN PRODUCTIVITY. THREATS IN ACTS
OF VIOLENCE HAVE BEEN CARRIED
OUT AT CHURCHES AND PLACES OF
WORSHIP ALL OVER THE NATION MOST
RECENTLY AT THAT YOUR BOT
SYNAGOGUE IN POWAY. WHERE ONE
WOMAN WAS KILLED AND THREE
OTHERS INJURED INCLUDING AN
EIGHT YEAR OLD CHILD. IN
DECEMBER YOU MAY RECALLTHERE
WAS A NATIONWIDE TICK TOCK
THREAT WHICH KEPT COUNTLESS
CHILDREN HOME AND OUT OF FEAR OF
THE WHAT IF IT WERE REAL.
MORNING SIDE HIGH SCHOOL IN
MONROE MIDDLE SCHOOL IN CENTER
BRADFORD'S DISTRICT WERE
THREATENED WITH A SHOOTING.
CENTER COM LOGGERS DISTRICT A
STUDENT AT CULVER CITY HIGH
SCHOOL MADE CRIMINAL THREATS
THREATS AS WELL. EVERY CISCO
STATE IN SENATOR WIENER'S
DISTRICT ALSO RECEIVED A THREAT
EARLIER THIS YEAR. IN CENTER
SKINNER- REPRESENTING BERKELEY
HIGH SCHOOL- THAT SCHOOL RECEIVE
AN ONLINE THREAT FOR POTENTIAL
SCHOOL SHOOTING JUST A FEW YEARS
BACK. THE STOCK BE REPORTED
SIXTEEN THREATS JUST IN THE
SACRAMENTO AREA DURING THIS FALL
ALONE. THESE THREATS INCREASED
NUMBER OF INCIDENTS AT SCHOOLS
HAVE STUDENTS FEARING THAT A
TRAGEDY COULD OCCUR ON THEIR
SCHOOL GROUNDS. FBI HATE CRIME
STATISTICS SHOW THAT INCIDENTS
IN CHURCHES AND SYNAGOGUES
TEMPLES AND MOSQUES INCREASED
NEARLY 34% BETWEEN TWENTY
FOURTEEN AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND
AS WE ARE AWAITING MORE RECENT
NUMBERS WE WILL SURELY FIND
THOSE NUMBERS. INCREASE IN EVEN
MORE ALARMING. WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
A THREAT IS MADE WHEN A THREAT
IS MADE TO A SCHOOL OR PLACE OF
WORSHIP BECAUSE THIS FEAR IT
DISRUPTS THE LEARNING PROCESS.
IN THE SENSE OF SAFETY. THESE
THREATS ALSO DIVERT LAW
ENFORCEMENT RESOURCES LEAVING
OTHER AREAS OF COMMUNITIES
VULNERABLE MEMBERS. SOMETHING IS
VERY WRONG HERE I THINK WE ALL
UNDERSTAND THAT TO BE THE CASE
IN OUR CURRENT CULTURE THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THESE THREATS ARE
ELECTRONIC SOCIAL MEDIA POSTINGS
DIRECTED AT THE ENTITIES SUCH AS
A SCHOOL OR CHURCH NOT
NECESSARILY AT A SPECIFIC
INDIVIDUAL. THERE IS A
DEFICIENCY IN THE CRIMINAL THE
CURRENT CRIMINAL CODE AS NOTHING
ADEQUATELY CAPTURES A THREAT TO
A SCHOOL OR PLACE OF WORSHIP THE
CLOSEST CURRENT STATUTE IS PENAL
CODE FOUR TWO TWO HOWEVER IT IS
LIMITED TO THE THREAT OF AN
INDIVIDUAL. THIS LOOPHOLE. IN
THE LAW AS IT OCCURS WHEN THERE
IS NOT A NAMED INDIVIDUAL OR
INDIVIDUAL THAT IS THREATENED
BUT RATHER A PLACE SUCH AS A
SCHOOL OR PLACE OF WORSHIP.
WITHOUT A NAME THE VICTIM
PROSECUTORS HAVE HAD GREAT
DIFFICULTY IN BEING ABLE TO
ADDRESS THIS CRIMINAL ACTIVITY.
UNDER EXISTING LAW AN INDIVIDUAL
MUST BE THE TARGET OF THE
OFFENSE. IN THE THREATEN
INDIVIDUAL MUST BE IN SUSTAINED
FEAR. WITHOUT PROVING ALL THE
REQUIRED ELEMENTS BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT THE PROSECUTION
WOULD FAIL. S. B. THIRTEEN
THIRTY SIX TO CLARIFY. DEAD AT
THAT A THREAT IS TREATED THE
SAME WHETHER IT IS AGAINST A
PERSON IN ENTITY OR PLACE MANY
OF THESE THREATS COME FROM
JUVENILE OFFENDERS AND WITHOUT A
TRUE FINDING OF A VIOLATION OF A
OFTEN WILL NOT RECEIVE SOCIAL
SERVICES OR MENTAL HEALTH
ASSISTANCE. THESE THREATS MAY
INDEED BE A CRY FOR HELP AND
WILL CONTINUE TO SLIP THROUGH
THE CRACKS OF OUR CURRENT SYSTEM
. TODAY I HAVE WITH ME I HOPE I
STILL HAVE WITH ME AT THIS POINT
REPRESENTED FROM THE FRESNO
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE- GALEN READY AGA. CHIEF
DEPUTY DA FROM THE JUVENILE UNIT
AND BETH HOLTZMAN COUNSEL FOR
THE ANTI DEFAMATION LEAGUE. DO
WE HAVE GALEN RIVIERA ON THE
PHONE. I'M HERE PERFECT PLEASE
PROCEED FOR. THANK YOU MY NAME'S
KAELIN READY AGAIN THE CHIEF
DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY FOR
FRESNO COUNTY I'M IN CHARGE OF
THE JUVENILE UNIT AND MANAGED
CARE AND MEMBERS I COME IN THE
SPONSOR FOR F. B. THIRTEEN
THIRTY AND URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL I DID SPEAK TO PROTECT
SOME OF OUR MOST VALUABLE
MEMBERS OF SOCIETY DIDN'T AND
RELIGIOUS. WORSHIPPERS AS WE ALL
KNOW THE THREAT OF GUN VIOLENCE
IS ALL TOO PREVALENT IN OUR
SOCIETY CURRENTLY. AS EVIDENCED
BY THE RECENT EVENTS THERE IN
SACRAMENTO. WE ALL AGREE ABOUT
THE IMPACT OF TRAGIC EVENT. THE
MASS SHOOTING HOWEVER THE METER
READ OF A SHOOTING AT A SCHOOL
OR HOUSE OF WORSHIP. IS ALSO
DRAMATIC AND THE DISRUPTIVE
EVENT. WITH THE PREVALENCE OF
SOCIAL MEDIA AND IT IS JUVENILE.
AND INDIVIDUAL CAN'T CREATE
ANONYMOUS SOCIAL MEDIA PAGE THAT
THREATENED A SCHOOL OR A HOUSE
VERSION IN GENERAL WITHOUT
NAMING OR CARRIED IN AN
INDIVIDUAL. WHEN THIS OCCURS HE
WALKED IN THE FACT THAT THESE
POLICIES DO NOT MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS NEEDED TO PURSUE A
CHARGE. THE CLOSEST- STATUTE AND
THE ONE WE OFTEN LOOK AS AS
MENTIONED BY SENATOR BORDERS IF
HE'LL COACH FOR TWENTY TWO.
HOWEVER THAT. STATUE WAS NOT
MADE OR CREATED. OR THE CURRENT
SCENARIO WE SEE. AND THERE'S A
LIMITATION TO PROMOTE ACT- RIGHT
UNDER PENAL CODE OR TWENTY TWO.
AS STATED BY HER BORDERS IT
REQUIRES AN IDENTIFIABLE VICTIM
TO BE ASSISTING IN FEAR FOR
THEIR OWN SAFETY. OR THEIR
IMMEDIATE SAFETY OF THEIR MEAT
FAMILY UPON BEING MADE AWARE OF
THE THREAT. AND THE VICTIMS FEAR
WAS REASONABLE UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES CIRCUMSTANCES.
WHAT MANY TIMES NO SINGLE PERSON
FACTUALLY MEETS ALL THOSE
REQUIREMENTS NEEDED TO SUSTAIN
THE CHARGE OF A CRIMINAL THREAT
. THE HOPES OF IT THIS. BILL
WILL FIX THAT HOLE I'M GOING TO
GO ON IT IS UNCOMMON LIGHTLY
TOWARDS THE- PUBLIC SAFETY
ANALYSIS MENTIONS OF TWO CASES
IN PARTICULAR FIRST WHAT IS IN
RATE AG WHICH IS FOUND THAT
FIFTY EIGHT CAL APP FIFTH SIX
FORTY SEVEN. FOR A PETITION WAS
THE STANDS WERE GENERIC THREAT
WAS POSTED TO A SNAP CHAT. OR A
WHICH IS A ONE MEANS OF SOCIAL.
HOWEVER IN THS CASE BOTH A
STUDENT AND A TEACHER DIRECTOR
RECEIVED THAT PERPETRATORS
ACTUAL MEDICINES AND CAME IN AND
TESTIFIED AS TO THAT FEAR BASED
ON ONCE UPON A RECEIVING THAT
MESSAGE. WE ARE TRYING TO
CAPTURE NOT ONES WHERE WE HAVE
AN INDIVIDUAL BUT WHERE WE DO
NOT HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL THAT WAS
IN THE STATE FAIR. ALSO MENTION
WITHIN THE STATE IT ALSO THIS.
IS A- SECOND CASE. IN RAY LF-
IT'S A UNPUBLISHED OPINION WHICH
IS NOT AVAILABLE RECORD HOWEVER
THAT ONE TO PERPETRATE ME
NUMEROUS COMMENTS ON SOCIAL
MEDIA BELIEVE WITH TWITTER. AND
WAS CLEAR THAT THE STATEMENTS
WERE READ. THE VICE PRINCIPAL
RECEIVED A SCREENSHOT OF THE
ACTUAL THREAT. AND CAME INTO
COURT AND WAS ABLE TO TESTIFY
BEING SCARED AND NERVOUS HAVE
YOU SEEN THOSE THREATS. FOR HIS
OWN SAFETY AS HE IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR IMPLEMENTING THE LOCKDOWN
PROTOCOL HE WOULD BE A WOULD BE
IN DANGER IN DOING SO- AS WE
NOTED AND AS THE OTHER BORDERS
NOTED WE ANTICIPATE THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THESE TO BE
JUVENILES THAT ARE- ENCOUNTERS.
WITH THIS AMENDMENT OR CHANGE-
AND AS A NOTED IN AN ENGAGING
THE PRIMARY GOAL OF THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM IS GENERALLY
BILLET KATE OFFENDERS. RATHER
THAN PUNISH THEM SO- WE FEEL MR
AREA WOULD YOU MIND- WRAPPING IT
UP JUST A TAD FASTER RIGHT NOW
SO WE CAN HAVE A BETTER CHANCE
MAN COME AND SPEAK. YEAH YEAH.
BUT WHEN WE WHEN WE DO THE
SITUATION OF A LOT OF THE LOCK
PASS THE THOROUGHLY FIND OUT
WHAT IS GOING ON THIS YOUNG
PERSON TO CAUSE HIM TO REACH OUT
IN THIS MATTER. FIFTY FIFTY- I
LOST CHANCE REVISED SERVICE TO A
STRUGGLING YOUTH AND ASSIST THEM
IN AVOIDING THESE SCENARIOS TO
PULL HEM BACK ONTO THE RIGHT
PATH. LASTLY WILL HELP US
MAINTAIN PUBLIC SAFETY WHEN
FILLING PHASE THAT OUR STUDENTS
PARENTS TEACHERS AND WORSHIPERS
THAT THEY HAVE A STATE
INSTITUTION TO ATTEND TO LEARN
OR PRACTICE THEIR RELIGIOUS
BELIEFS. ARE YOU AN ICE SUPPORT
FOR SD THIRTEEN THIRTY THANK YOU
THANK YOU MR READ AT ROUTE READY
AGA WE WILL NOW MOVE FORWARD
WITH THEIR SECOND SUPPORT LEAD
WITNESS- BETH HOLTZMAN ARE YOU
ON THE LINE. YES I AM. PLEASE
PROCEED MA'AM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BETH
HOLTZMAN I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE ANTI DEFAMATION LEAGUE TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR
CALIFORNIA SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
THIRTY FOUNDED IN NINETEEN
THIRTEEN EIGHTY OUT OF THE
NATIONAL LEADING ANTI HATE
ORGANIZATIONS COMBATING ANTI
SEMITISM AND ALL FORMS OF
BIGOTRY DISCRIMINATION AND
EXTREMISM. EACH YEAR HUNDREDS OF
FAKE BOMB THREATS WERE CALLED IN
TARGETING DEMAGOGUES AND OTHER
JEWISH COMMUNAL INSTITUTIONS
LIKE JEWISH COMMUNITY CENTER IN
JEWISH DAY SCHOOL THERE
UNFORTUNATELY LIVING IN A NEW
ERA FOR SCHOOL BASED MASS
CASUALTY EVENT ATTRACTED SUCH
VIOLENT ATTACKS AGAINST PLACES
OF WORSHIP ARE INCREASINGLY
COMMON. THE REALITY IS RESULTED
IN HEIGHTENED FEAR AMONG
STUDENTS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
AND THE NATION BUT IT GOT THE
TRAGEDY COULD OCCUR IN THEIR OWN
SCHOOL OF ANY KIND BUT IT'S
CALLED A PLACE OF WORSHIP AT
THEIR END IT CAN AND IT DOES
COST REASONABLE AND IMMEDIATE
CARE FOR ANYONE ON THAT
INSTITUTION'S PROPERTY. UNDER
EXISTING LAW HOWEVER LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN ONLY CHARGE A
PERPETRATOR FOR MAKING A
CRIMINAL THREAT IF THE TARGET
PERSON IT'S REASONABLE BECAUSE
THE B. AND THE FANFARE OF HIS OR
HER OWN SAFETY OR THAT OF HIS OR
HER IMMEDIATE FAMILY IF THEY'LL
WITHHOLD THOSE WHO THREATEN
SCHOOLS AND PLACES OF WORSHIP
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE YEAR THEY
CREATE AND MAKING IT A CRIME FOR
ANYONE TO MALICIOUSLY INFORM ANY
PERSON THAT A TERROR INCIDENT
WILL OCCUR. AT ANY SCHOOL ANY
SCHOOL SPONSORED EVENT OR ANY
PLACE OF WORSHIP KNOWING THAT
THE INFORMATION ITSELF. ALL THE
PLACES OF WORSHIP ACROSS
CALIFORNIA HAPPINESS OPTIC AND
THREATENING ACTIVITY PLEASE
CORRECT THE CURRENCY OF PEOPLE
CAN BE ENORMOUS COUNTLESS HOURS
OF BLOCKAGE OCCASIONS I
RESOURCES AND OF COURSE THE
CHILLING HERE THAT NO INDIVIDUAL
SHOULD HAVE TO FEEL STUCK
BECAUSE THEY TEND TO GO OTHER
PLACES OF WORSHIP. FOR THESE
REASONS WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA SB THIRTEEN THIRTY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS BETH
HOLDEN YOU HAD ABOUT TWELVE
MINUTES TWELVE SECONDS LEFT ON
YOUR TWO MINUTES OF THANK YOU
FOR STAYING WITHIN THOSE TWO
MINUTES- WE WILL NOW BEGIN WITH. ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE EIGHTEEN THIRTY HERE IN
FROM TWO TWO HIGH. SCENE NINE
THANK YOU ONE NUMBER TO WITNESS
WAITING TO VIA THE TELL ORVIS MY
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE FROM THE END
OF WE TO TESTIFY INSTEAD OF S.
BEAT THE THERE. YES IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF. THE THIRTEEN
THIRTY PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME WHAT KIND OF
SUPPORT FOR SD THIRTEEN THIRTY
THAT'S ONE. ONE MOMENT. YOUR
LINE NUMBER THREE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JUST. THAT'S A
GAME IS PARAMOUNT HOW MUCH THERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
THIRTY THANK YOU. NOW WHAT DO I
NUMBER THREE FORTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. A PENNY PARKER I
SUPPORT THE BILL. WHEN ARE WE
GOING TO LOT NUMBER TWO TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE CASHIER
WILLIAM AND SHOWING A LATCH
REPRESENTING CHANGE PRETTY
BROADLY FOR US SENATE WERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO LIE NUMBER
THREE FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON THIS IS BREANNA
DOLLAR CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
SAME COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
SUMMER STEPHAN OUR OFFICE IS IN
SUPPORT OF. THE BILL THANK YOU.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE
SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN THIRTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE TO ZERO AT THIS
TIME. HE JUST A MOMENT PLEASE
OUR NEXT PARTY. WE JUST ANOTHER
MOMENT.
WE'LL BE LINE NUMBER THREE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE THREE
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
NUMBER THREE FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AND YOUR FIRST AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
AND THEN WE WILL- GO TO OUR LEAD
OPPOSITION. AND I HAVE LISTED IS
CATHY HERE FROM ACLU AND LESLIE
CALDWELL HOUSTON FROM CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS THEY'RE BOTH ON
THE LINE SO MODERATOR GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU YOUR LINES ARE OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON HAPPY SURE ABOUT HALF
EIGHT YEAH HELLO TRANSACTION WE
MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE
THIRTY THIRTY. AT THIRTEEN
THIRTY THREE YOU KIND OF HE'S A
HATER THAT IS ALREADY PUNISHABLE
UNDER THE LAW. YOU KNOW BECAUSE
FOR TWENTY OR THIRTY FROM
BELFAST DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THEY ARE
STILL IN REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
THE FACT THESE MAKE THE PERFECT
PERSON. OR TO A GROUP OF PEOPLE.
FURTHERMORE IF ALL PART OF AN
EMERGENCY MADE OF OFFICIALS YOU
KNOW CO WHAT SECTION ONE EIGHT
THREE FIVE AS A RESULT FROM THE-
NO NEED FOR THE PENALTY FOR WHAT
HE NEEDS CREATE A NUMBER AT.
THIRTEEN THIRTY. WE KNOW FROM
THE INVOICE OF EXISTING LAWS ARE
YOU COMING THANK YOU IT'S NOT
LIKELY TO BE. IT IS THIS KIND OF
BEHAVIOR YOUNG PEOPLE AND WITH
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. EVEN
PEOPLE WHO NEED NOT PUNISHMENT
AND NEED TO FIND WAYS. OKAY OUR
- THE WHICH IS PART OF THAT
THIRTEEN THIRTY BOTH OF THE NEED
TO FOR THE TO ENSURE THAT THE
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO DO MAKE A
PRACTICE ARE ABLE TO GET THE
ASSISTANT THEY NEED- HEY YOU WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THESE PEOPLE
DON'T FALL THROUGH THE CRACKS.
WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR NATION
THAT HELP NOT PUNISHMENT IS WHAT
IS NEEDED. BUT IF NEW CRIMINAL
PENALTIES AND THE ONLY WAY WE
CAN MAKE SURE YOUNG PEOPLE CAN
GET HELP. I FIND ARE BROKEN WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE WHO
NEED HELP YOUNG PEOPLE AND OTHER
MEDIA IDENTIFIED AND PROVIDED
WITH HIS INPUT OUT BEING CHARGED
WITH A CRIME. EFFECTIVELY URGE
YOUR NOSE ON. AND OUR NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LESLIE
CALDWELL HOUSTON AND I'M
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE SB THIRTEEN THIRTY OUR
THOUGHTS ARE VERY SIMILAR TO THE
ACLU AND I WILL BE VERY. THIS
BILL WILL UNDOUBTEDLY SWEEP UP
INDIVIDUALS SUFFERING FROM
MENTAL ILLNESS AND BONE BONNER
BO YOU IN YET ANOTHER NEEDLESSLY
ADDED CRIME CURRENT LIFE OF
COMMON SENSE IN TERMS. OPERATION
OF THE REPORT WHICH FOLLOWS THE
GREATEST POTENTIAL HARM TO THE
COMMUNITY FROM THOSE. FOR WHICH
IMPOSITIONS OF CRIMINAL
PENALTIES WOULD BE UNNECESSARY
IN THE CUSTOM ESTATE THIRTEEN
THIRTY COMPLETELY DISPENSES WITH
THOSE GUARD RAILS OR ANY GUARD
RAILS. MAKING SOCIAL MEDIA
THOSE. MESSAGES IN CASUAL
CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN ANY TWO OR
MORE PEOPLE POTENTIALLY CRIMINAL
THIS IS A DANGEROUS EXPANSION OF
THE STATE POWER THE POLICE ALL
MANNER OF COMMUNICATION. THIS
EXPANSION IS PARTICULARLY
DAMAGING FOR PEOPLE WITH L.
MENTAL ILLNESS ESPECIALLY ARE
YOU WHO WE ALL KNOW OUR INTAKE
US AND DO NOT. THINK THINGS
THROUGH BEFORE ASKING. DO TO
INCOME FORMED. WE MUST NOT CAN
NOT CAST MORE. DOESN'T SHARE OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE IN OUR SOCIETY
MEMBERS SUFFERING FROM MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS IN THE
CRIMINAL SYSTEM. THE THIRTEEN
THIRTY IS A SIGNIFICANT
EXPANSION OF THE WAS SERVING
FALSE REPORT OF CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY WHICH USUALLY ARE
LIMITED TO RECORDS THE
PARTICULAR PEOPLE IN POSITION TO
TAKE ACTION. CONCERNING THE
FALSE REPORT FOR INSTANCE ONE
FORCE THAT WOULD FURTHER SPREAD
THE POSTER BOARD. FOR INSTANCE
MEDIA EMPLOYEES. BILL IS A AND
DISARM THESE REASONS WE REQUIRE
YOU NO VOTE THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
LET'S SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WHO ARE
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM. SEEING
NONE A MODERATOR WILL YOU QUEUE
UP ANY WITNESSES THAT ARE
CALLING IN THAT ONE- TESTIFIED
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AND
THEY WOULD GIVE THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND THEIR POSITION.
THANK YOU ASIAN GENTLEMAN IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN AFTER THE OPPOSITION OF
THE THIRTEEN THIRTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. JUST
A MOMENT. WE'RE GOING TO Y.
NUMBER THREE FORTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BUT I DON'T REMEMBER-
BRANDON UP ON BEHALF OF THE LA
COUNTY- ARMEN ACTUALLY SUPPORT I
APOLOGIZE FOR BEING OUT OF LINE
I OWN DIFFICULTIES GOING ON.
THANK YOU. ONE NUMBER THREE
FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON THEY'RE HOPING WITHOUT
BIGGER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO THAT.
ALKALINE NUMBER THREE THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AM I
WONDER CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
SISTER WARRIORS FREEDOM
COALITION AND THE YOUNG WOMEN'S
FREEDOM CENTER IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY THREE STEPS ONE
BEEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND YOUR
FIRST BUT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. SORRY LET'S
RETURN IT TO THE- DYESS-
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS YES
SENATOR WIENER- THANK YOU A
MANAGER. ON WE'RE HAVING SOME.
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW THIS BILL
COMPARES TO EIGHTY NINE OH
SEVEN- BY SOME MEMBER GRACE AND
THAT. THIS COMMITTEE ACTUALLY
PASSED UNANIMOUSLY AND TWENTY
NINETEEN WAS OLD MY HELD- ON
SUSPENSE IN THE APPROPRIATIONS.
COMMITTEE AND I KNOW ONE
DIFFERENCE IS THAT BILL WAS A
MISDEMEANOR FOR JUVENILES IN
SORT OF A WOBBLER- AND I THINK
THE LIABILITY MAY HAVE BEEN.
POSSIBLY BROADER IN SOME
RESPECTS- BUT I IT- I'M
DEFINITELY INTERESTED IN IN
KNOWING HOW THE TWO BILLS. ARE
COMPARE- IF I DON'T HEAR. IT
MIGHT MAKE SENSE TO POTENTIALLY
PUT THE BILL OVER TO HAVE A
CLEAR ANSWER- ON- BUT THAT'S
JUST MY- WON'T TAKE BECAUSE I
KNOW I'VE HI ALONG WITH EVERY
OTHER MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE
VOTED FOR THE GRACE AND ALL
TWENTY NINETEEN SO- THAT'S JUST
MY- COMMENT. YES SENATOR CORKER
THANK YOU WELL I WAS NOT ON THAT
COMMITTEE I WAS IN PUBLIC SAFETY
WHERE IT WAS HEARD. AND I
ACTUALLY- DID NOT VOTE FOR THAT
BILL I HAD SOME CONCERNS AND
THOSE CONCERNS ARE VERY SIMILAR
TO THE CONCERNS THAT I HAVE WITH
THIS BILL AND- HE I AM. WELL AS
I WAS LISTENING I WAS ALSO SORT
OF THINKING ABOUT A REAL LIFE
SCENARIO THAT HAPPENED WITH MY
FAMILY- WITH MY YOUNG CHILD- AND
HAVING A FOURTEEN YEAR OLD- WHO
IS OBVIOUSLY HAVING CHALLENGES
AT HOME TO BE CHARGED WITH A
FELONY. DOES IS DOES IS NOT IN
CONCERT WITH HOW I REVIEW- BILLS
THERE- YOU KNOW I DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE
INCONSISTENCIES OF
IMPLEMENTATION WITH THIS
DEPENDING ON THE COUNTY THAT
YOU'RE IN DEPENDING ON THE
SCHOOL- AND HOW THAT IS RUNNING
MAYBE THE PRINCIPLES IN THE
FRAMEWORK OF THAT PARTICULAR
INSTITUTION- I WILL ALSO SHARE
THAT- AND I CERTAINLY AM NOT
GOING TO GET INTO. DETAILS
BECAUSE MINORS WERE INVOLVED BUT
THERE WAS GRAVE INCONSISTENCIES
WITH HOW PUNISHMENT WAS- EXACTED
ON A YOUNG BLACK CHILD VERSUS
PUNISHMENT EXACTED ON THE YOUNG
BLACK A WHITE CHILD. FOR VERY
DIFFERENT. ISSUES BUT WHERE THE
MORE EGREGIOUS- ACTUALLY WAS NOT
WITH THAT- THE BLACK CHILD AND
SO I WOULD JUST WANT TO I HAVE A
LOT OF QUESTIONS ABOUT.
APPLICATION ABOUT CONSISTENCY
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES ARE CERTAIN PEOPLE
ARE NOT TARGETED- IT WAS RAISED
ABOUT THOSE THAT HAVE MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES THERE'S ALSO AN
ISSUE ABOUT SOMEONE WHO'S IDT-
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES- YOU
KNOW. WHEN SOMEONE IS MAKING A
TRUE THREAT VERSUS A FALSE
THREAT HOW THAT IS HANDLED-
GIVEN COVE IT AND THE FACT THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN STUDIES THAT
COME OUT THAT HAVE COME OUT THAT
SAY FOR EXAMPLE THERE'S BEEN A
51% INCREASE IN SUICIDE ATTEMPTS
OF. OF FROM GIRLS OF GIRLS AND
SO IF HOW ARE WE MANAGING EITHER
THE ANXIETY OR DEPRESSION OR THE
SADNESS THAT THEY'RE FEELING
THAT THEY MIGHT NOT UNDERSTAND
HOW TO SHARE IN A WAY THAT IS
HEALTHY FOR THEM- AND DO WE LEAN
ON THE CRIMINAL SYSTEM. TO HELP
THEM COME TO THOSE DECISIONS I
JUST DON'T KNOW BUT I AM
CERTAINLY INTERESTED IN WOULD BE
WILLING TO HOLD IT OVER SO THAT
WE CAN GET MORE INFORMATION TO
SEE IF THERE IS- YOU KNOW IF
WHAT THE PARALLELS MANY MAYBE
WITH ANOTHER BAIL. BUT I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU CAN ADDRESS ANY OF
THOSE CONCERNS THAT I RAISED BUT
THEY WERE SIMILAR- TO WHAT I
RAISED THEM WITH THE OTHER BILL. GO AHEAD SIR BORDERS PICTURE.
TO MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT WE
GET INTO THE REAL PARTICULARS I
WOULD CERTAINLY WANT TO BRING
UP- MR RUDY I GOT- TO GET INTO
THE DETAILS OF THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN FOUR TWENTY TWO ONE
TWENTY EIGHT BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT ASSEMBLY
BILL- NINE OH SEVEN THIS IS
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR. AND I
THINK WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN WITH
THE BILL PROCESS IS THAT. IT'S
ALSO AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
AUTHOR TO LEARN WHAT IS
IMPORTANT TO- HIS OR HER
COLLEAGUES. AND IF IT MEANS THAT
HE WOULD MEET WITH THE APPROVAL
OF THIS BOARD AND CONTINUE THIS-
THIS COMMITTEE A MOVE THIS
PROCESS ALONG. I COULD
ABSOLUTELY I AGREE THAT WE WOULD
CONVERT IT FOR MINORS TO BE
MISDEMEANORS I IF THAT WAS ONE
DISTINCTION THAT WAS EVENTUALLY
ACHIEVED WITH THE PREVIOUS
AUTHOR. BECAUSE THERE ARE THERE
ARE THERE ARE ISSUES WHEN YOU'RE
DEALING WITH MINORS. BUT LET'S
ALSO NOT FORGET THE FACT THAT
THERE ARE SUBSTANTIAL ISSUES.
ARE WITH THE IMPACT TO THE
COMMUNITY TO THE SCHOOL ARE TO
THE MOSQUE TO THE TEMPLE TO THE
CHURCH. WINDIES THREATS OCCUR.
ODD WHICH IS WHY WE HEARD FROM
THE- FROM THE PROSECUTORS THAT
THIS IS APPROPRIATELY- A FALSE
REPORT UNDER ONE FORTY EIGHT
WHICH IS WHY IT WAS PUT. IN ONE
FORTY EIGHT AS OPPOSED TO FOUR
TWENTY TWO. BUT IN TERMS OF- OF
LOOKING AFTER INDIVIDUALS THAT
MAYBE HAVE- DISABILITIES OR WHO
HAVE NOT FULLY APPRECIATED THEM
RAMIFICATIONS OF THEIR HANDS OF
THEIR ACTIONS. A MISDEMEANOR OR
DO YOU THE POTENTIAL FOR THE
APPLICATION OF A MISDEMEANOR
CHARGE. I OPENS THE DOOR
CERTAINLY FOR MENTAL HEALTH AND
SOCIAL SERVICES TO GET INVOLVED.
BUT LET'S NOT FORGET THAT ALL IT
TAKES IS A THREAT AND THEY CAN
CLOSE DOWN AN ENTIRE COMMUNITY
IT CAN CLOSE DOWN AN ENTIRE
SCHOOL THERE HAS TO BE A SENSE
OF. BALANCE THAT LOOKS AFTER THE
INTERESTS OF THE INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS ALLEGED TO HAVE PERPETRATED
THE THREAT. AS WELL AS THE WHOLE
UPON WHICH THAT PERSON IS ACTING
IN AFFECTING AND THAT'S WHAT I
THINK THIS BILL DOES IS THAT IF
IT MEETS WITH YOUR APPROVAL AND
I KNOW IT IS DONE SO IN TWENTY
NINETEEN AS IT PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY THROUGH THIS
COMMITTEE BEFORE. THAT IF WE
WERE TO CONVERT THE EIGHTEEN AND
UNDER TO MISDEMEANORS. THEN I
WOULD ABSOLUTELY GIVE YOU MINE
MY WORDS THAT IS HOW IT WILL BE
REDRAFTED ONCE IS MOVED TO THE
NEXT STAGE. I'M. SENATOR WIENER
YEAH AND I AND VICTOR I'M NOT
MAKING A ANY COMMITMENTS ON THIS
BILL THERE'S WHEN. USE NON WEEKS
SUPPORTED BELLA COMMITTEE UNDER
ANY REAL YOU KNOW COME BACK
FEARS YOU TAKE ANOTHER AT A YOU
SORT OF. REALIZE MAYBE SHOULD
HAVE SUPPORTED THE FIRST TIME I
SCAN REMEMBER YOUR THREE YEARS
AGO SOMETHING TIME ALL THIS
HAPPENED LAST THREE YEARS- SO
ARE. YOU KNOW AND I. TO ME ALSO
THIS IS I DON'T GET ME WRONG
IT'S TERRIBLE WHEN SOMEONE CALLS
IN A FALSE THREAT AND SHUTS DOWN
THE SCHOOL IT'S EXTREMELY
DISRUPTIVE- IT'S ALSO NOT LIKE
PHYSICALLY HARMING SOMEONE OR
IT'S DISRUPTIVE TO THE COMMUNITY
AND IT'S BAD DON'T GET ME WRONG-
BUT I. I ALSO WONDER IF WE
SHOULD EVEN BE- A WOBBLER IF
MAYBE IT SHOULD BE A MISDEMEANOR
AND MAYBE EVEN FOR YOUTH. YOU
KNOW INFRACTION WITH. ANGER
MANAGEMENT OR THIRTY OR
SOMETHING I JUST I'M JUST SORT
OF BRAINSTORMING OUT LOUD- YEAH
I DON'T KNOW SO I WILL SAY IN-
AND THIS IS ONLY ONE INSTANCE
BUT IN YOU KNOW- THE INSTANCE
THAT I'M SPECIFICALLY REFERRING
TO THERE WERE RAMIFICATIONS FOR
THAT PARTICULAR STUDENT. THAT
BIRD THAT CHILD WAS IMMEDIATELY
EXPELLED THEY HAD RAMIFICATIONS
WITH THE PARENTS IT IMPACTED
THEIR ABILITY TO GO TO ANOTHER
pIMMEDIATE CONSEQUENCES- AND IT
WAS THE END NOTHING HAPPENS THEY
DID NOT ENACT THEY DID NOT GO
THROUGH WITH THE THINGS THAT
THEY WERE SAYING. EIGHT AND
TRUTHFULLY. THE NEXT WEEK
SOMEBODY ELSE DID SOMETHING THAT
WAS EQUALLY SORT OF. USEFUL AND
WILD AND THAT BECAME VERY OLD
NEWS THE RESILIENCY OF YOUNG
PEOPLE IS EQUALLY ASTONISHING
BUT I WILL SAY IN THIS
PARTICULAR INSTANCE- AND THE
THING THAT HAPPENED. WAS NOT
NICE SO I'M CERTAINLY NOT TRYING
TO PLACATE OR OR GLOSS OVER BUT
THERE WERE IMMEDIATE AND SEVERE
RAMIFICATIONS FOR BOTH THE
PARENT AND THE CHILD THAT ARE
STILL FELT TO THIS DAY BY THAT
PARTICULAR FAMILY I DO THINK
THERE ARE OTHER WAYS TO GO ABOUT
. TRYING TO CREATE THE KIND OF
SAFETY AND CONSEQUENTIAL
EXPERIENCE THAT WE'RE ALL
LOOKING FOR- I SIR AND I DON'T
ALWAYS KNOW IF USING THE WEAPON
OR THE TOOL THAT IS THE CRIMINAL
LEGAL SYSTEM IS APPROPRIATE
ESPECIALLY FOR YOUNG KIDS. HE
WAS VERY CLOSE MADAM CHAIR ARM I
WILL SEE IF THERE'S ANY OTHER
COMMENT OTHERWISE THEY WILL
ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE. OKAY GREAT.
THE SECOND WITNESS THAT- APPEAR
TELEPHONICALLY IN OPPOSITION.
IDENTIFIED ON THE LIST OF EVENTS
THAT. THIS IS A BILL LIKE THIS
WOULD TARGET CASUAL CONVERSATION. NOTHING COULD BE FURTHER FROM
THE TRUTH. I THINK WE ALL KNOW
HIS SPECIALLY IN OUR DIGITAL ERA
AND SOME OF US PREDATE THAT SO
HE CAN CLEARLY. MYSELF INCLUDED
CLEARLY DISTINGUISH WHAT THINGS
WERE LIKE PRIOR TO SOCIAL MEDIA
AND- EVERYBODY HAVING A
SOPHISTICATED CELL PHONE. THIS
ISNOT APPLYING TO CASUAL
CONVERSATION FOLKS. WE'RE
TALKINGABOUT THREATS. THAT
COULD BE LEVIED AGAINST A
TEMPLE. IN THE CONTEXT OF
EXTRAORDINARY ANTI SEMITISM. TO
WHICH MEMBERS OF THE
CONGREGATION AND LEADERSHIP OF
THAT COMIC CONGREGATION CANNOT
AFFORD. TO TAKE IT AT FACE VALUE
AND THEY MUST RESPOND CANCEL
SERVICES OR CANCEL THE EVENT AT
THE- THE COMPLEX OF THE
RELIGIOUS INSTITUTION. AND
FORCIBLY REMOVE FOLKS FROM THE
AREA. SAME THING WITH A SCHOOL
SETTING. THAT THEY CAN'T AFFORD
NOT TO TAKE THESE THINGS
SERIOUSLY SO WE HAVE TO ALSO
TAKE THREATS LIKE THIS SERIOUSLY
. BECAUSE WHEN I HAVE TWO LITTLE
BOYS IF THERE IS A THREAT LEVIED
AT THE SCHOOL I'LL BE IF I'M
GONNA WANT THEM TO STAY IN THERE
AS WE FIGURED OUT THE MERITS OF
THIS THREAT. I'M GOING TO WANT
THE PROTOCOL TO BE IMMEDIATE
SHUTDOWN REMOVAL OFF PREMISE END
OF STORY. WHAT DOES THAT MEAN
FOR KIDS. THAT MEANS THEY ARE
TAKEN OUT OF SCHOOL. THEY ARE
SCARED AND WE ARE NOT PROVIDING
ANY ENVIRONMENT THAT FOSTERS
EDUCATION AND COMFORT. THINK OF
THE SOCIAL IMPLICATIONS OF HOW
THIS TOOL IF USED
INAPPROPRIATELY CAN AFFECT ALL
OF US WHETHER IT BE A SYNAGOGUE
A MOSQUE OR CHURCH OR SCHOOL OR
UNIVERSITY. OR ANY NUMBER OF
ACTIVITIES THAT TAKE PLACE AT
THOSE FACILITIES. THIS BILL IN
SHORT CLOSES A LOOPHOLE BY
ALLOWING A THREAT AGAINST AN
INDIVIDUAL A THREAT AGAINST IT
INDIVIDUAL TO NOW INCLUDE A
PLACE. IT SOUNDS IT'S A SOUND
REASON TO ALLOW FOR AN EXTENSION
LIKE THAT BECAUSE THE
PARTICULARITY OF A THREAT
AGAINST AN INDIVIDUAL THAT
INDIVIDUAL CAN RESPOND OR THE
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATOR CAN TAKE
SENATOR SKINNER OUT OF THE
BUILDING BECAUSE SHE WAS
THREATENED. A THREAT AGAINST A
SCHOOL THE ENTIRE SCHOOL IS AT
RISK. IT IS A MULTIPLIER EFFECT
WHEN YOU HAVE A SITUATION LIKE
THIS. SO NO I UNDERSTAND THERE
ARE SOCIAL CONSIDERATIONS AT
THAT WE ALLOW THIS BILL SHOULD
YOU BE WILLING TO MOVE FORWARD
AND I THINK ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT IT IS AT PLAY HERE IS
WHETHER OR NOT. IT SHOULD NO
LONGER BE A WOBBLER FOR MINORS
BUT INSTEAD A MISDEMEANOR. IF I
WOULD IF I'D BE ENTITLED TO YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY I GIVE YOU MY
WORD. I WILL CONTINUE TO ENGAGE
WITH THE INDIVIDUALS- IN- WITH
THE ACLU AND OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
AND OTHER FOLKS VERY
KNOWLEDGEABLE ON HOW RULES LIKE
THIS CAN APPLY IN BE MISUSED
SHOULD BE THAT WAY. TO MAKE THIS
EVEN BETTER BUT I HAVE TO BE
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY NO THIS IS
THE THIRD TIME THIS BILL HAS
BEEN BROUGHT FORWARD. ONCE BY
TWENTY IN TWENTY NINETEEN BYE
BYE SIMPLY MEMBER GRAYSON WHICH
PASSED THE ASSEMBLY PASSED THIS
COMMITTEE IN JUST GOT HELD UP IN
APPROACH. I INTRODUCE THIS
AGAIN- BUT DURING COVE IT AND
THEN I GOT KICKED OUT BECAUSE A
COVE IT. AS ALL OF US WERE
CALLING OUR BILLS FOR THOSE THAT
WERE BY RICK VERY IMPORTANT. SO
THIS IS THE LAST OPPORTUNITY AT
LEAST TO TRICK MY TENURE. AS AS
A SENATOR AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY- ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE IN CLOSING THIS IS A
SIMPLE BILL. IT CLOSES A
LOOPHOLE IN CURRENT LAW AND
MAKES CLEAR D. OR AMBIGUITY
CURRENTLY EXISTS- NO INDIVIDUAL
SHOULD BE SCARED TO ATTEND
SCHOOL OR GATHER TO WORSHIP IN
THIS BILL WILL BE HELPFUL.
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. SUPPORT AND ALLOW ME
TO CONTINUE WORKING ON THIS BILL
THROUGH THE NEXT EVOLUTION. A
THOROUGH BEFORE I CALL ON VOTE-
I WILL BE VERY HONEST I WOULD
SHARE THE COMMITTEE I THINK AT
THAT POINT AND- I DON'T REMEMBER
THE ANALYSIS ON GRAYSON'S BILL
SO I. WHILE THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS SHOWS US THEIR
SIMILARITIES I CERTAINLY CAN'T
WITH CONFIDENCE SAY THAT. IT IS
. SAY COMPARABLE TO YOURS AND
THAT SAY THE ONLY DIFFERENCE IS
A MISDEMEANOR NOT SO I'D HAVE TO
GO BACK AND READ THAT ANALYSIS
AND REVIEW ALL THE MATERIALS.
AND IN LISTENING TO THE
PRESENTATION TODAY I'M STRUCK
THAT LET'S ASSUME THAT THEY ARE
ALMOST COMPARABLE. THEN I WONDER
THREE HONEST ANSWER WHY WE
WOULDN'T HAVE PUT IT AS AN
INFRACTION AND NOT A MISDEMEANOR
BECAUSE IN THESE KIND OF
CIRCUMSTANCES ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
RELATES TO SCHOOLS IF IT'S A
MINOR. THEN THE- THAT PERSON
COULD BRING IT TO A CRIMINAL
OFFENSE I MEAN IT'S GOT SERIOUS
. THE ACTION AS YOU'RE YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT CENTER BOARD
JUST THAT THEIR ACT. DISRUPTS
EVERYTHING AND ABSOLUTELY WANT A
PROTOCOL THAT WHEN YOU DON'T
KNOW WHAT IS REALLY BEHIND THAT
ACT YOU WANT TO PROTECT
EVERYBODY YOU HAVE TO- HOWEVER
SHOULD THE CONSEQUENCE ON A
MINOR BE A CRIMINAL OFFENSE IS
WHAT I THINK. WAIT IT LEAST ARM
SOME OF US ARE TOYING WITH NOW.
AND THE OTHER ISSUE THAT I SAW
IN THE ANALYSIS IS THAT WHILE.
THE IT'S SEVENTY EIGHT SEVENTY
KIDDED THAT THEY REQUIRES THE
PERPETRATOR TO NAME OF THE
VICTIM IN ORDER TO DO THE
PROSECUTION THERE WERE CITATIONS
OF CASES WHERE THE PERPETRATOR
IN THESE CASES WAS A MINOR AT
THE HIGH SCHOOL DIDN'T SPECIFY
THE VICTIM BUT INSTEAD TARGETED
ALL STUDENTS AND STAFF OF
PARTICULAR HIGH SCHOOL AND THEY
WERE PROSECUTED. SO AGAIN NOT
BEING THE DA NOT BEING A LAWYER
YOU KNOW IS IT THAT I'M SURE
LIKE A LOT OF US- HI EVERYBODY
WANTS THINGS YOU KNOW
COMPLETELY- DIGITAL NO GRAY AREA
RIGHT BUT IT WOULD APPEAR THAT
THERE IS THE ABILITY TO
PROSECUTE OR AT LEAST IN THAT
CASE THAT WOULDN'T HAVE HAPPENED
AND THERE WERE A COUPLE OF OTHER
CITATIONS. SO I AM. YEAH YOU
KNOW I'M VERY. WISHING THE
MISTER BRADFORD WAS HERE SO THAT
HE COULD EXPRESS BECAUSE HE'S
THE CHAIR DOT YOU KNOW I'M
SITTING IS THAT YOU'RE RIGHT NOW
BUT I. AND I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
YOU KNOW HIS THE COMMITTEE'S
AGENDA MAY BE VERY CROWDED FOR
ITS REMAINING TWO HERE THANKS-
AND I THINK FOR YOU KNOW WE DID
LEASE FOR MY I WOULD HAVE TO
FULLY. ANALYZE THE GREASE UNTIL
BEFORE I'D BE COMFORTABLE
SAYING. YOU KNOW SO I THINK THE
BEST. I'M JUST THINKING RIGHT
NOW ON THE FLY THE BEST WE COULD
DO PERHAPS IS GIVE YOU
RECONSIDERATION. AND THEN ALLOW.
MISTER BRADFORD TWO ENDS SCOTT
AND WHOEVER ELSE SENATOR WE
APOLOGIES FOR DOING- TO LOOK AT
THAN THAT AT THE COMPARABILITY
IS BETWEEN THE TWO BILLS AND
WHETHER IT'S APPROPRIATE TO YOU
KNOW MODIFY IT SUCH AND STILL
MOVE THAT. I'M PERSONALLY
THINKING THAT. EVEN A
MISDEMEANOR WOULD NOT BE
APPROPRIATE THAT IT ISN'T
ESPECIALLY FOR MINOR THAT IT'S
MUCH MORE IN THE INFRACTION AREA
BUT GO AHEAD SIDNEY. I AM SORRY
I COULD SIT IN A LATE SO WE'RE
ALL YEAH I KNOW I ACTUALLY THINK
THE GRAYSON BILL APPLY TO ACTUAL
THREATS IN MIND OF AN ACTUAL AND
PERCEIVED BUT- ITS ACTION THEY
WERE ACTUAL RECORD VERSUS. THIS
ONE WHICH IS A FALSE REPORT SO
OKAY I THINK IT CONJOINED BUT
ANYWAY RIGHT AFTER REVEALING A
ROLE. RIGHT DID YOU WANNA MAKE A
COMMENT SCISSOR WINNER NO. NO I
MEAN I HAVE A HARD STOP INTO IT
YEAH I THOUGHT THE AGES YOUR
COMMITTEE I KNOW AND- YEAH I'M
A- I'M NOT. HERE TO SUPPORT IT
NOW ALL BUT I THINK IF WE- THERE
THERE COULD BE A FORM. MAYBE
TAKE OUT SCHOOLS MAYBE JUST
PLACES OF WORSHIP I MEAN MAYBE
IT'S INFRACTION IN IT MIGHT MAKE
SENSE AFTER WE CONSIDERATION SO
THAT MORE IDEAS CAN COME TO THE
TABLE. THE CHAIR WITH DOC YEAH.
PART THREE OF THE CLOSED WE HAVE
A MOTION AND- ALL RIGHT. THEN WE
WILL DO A ROLL CALL. S. S. B.
THIRTEEN THIRTY DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER SKINNER
NOT VOTING A TROUBLE OAK HI JOE
BOAKAI KAMAGRA. KAMAGRA NOT
VOTING WINNER. WINNER NOT VOTING
ONE VOTES WE ARE GRANTING
RECONSIDERATION. THANK ALL RIGHT. OKAY SO LET US- WE'LL REOPEN
THE VOTE ON. BILL HE IS YES THE
- WINDOWS IT PLEASE THAT'S B. R.
TEN FORTY TO GO AT A SPEED TEN
FORTY TWO COM LONGER COME LONGER
NO VOTE IS ONE TO TWO. RIGHT
THAT BILL FAILED I WANT TO DO
BUT IT WAS GRANTED RECONSIDER.
ALL RIGHT EARLY- DISPENSE WITH
OLDER BUSINESS. ALL RIGHT SO. DO
I NEED TO LAUGH IT IS NOT
APPROPRIATE TO LEFT- WE HAD A
LOT OF SERIOUS SUBJECT TODAY
AND- ALL RIGHT RECALLING. THE
DAYS WHEN I WAS HERE AND WE
WOULD HAVE THESE A MARATHON
MEETINGS BUT ANYWAY THANK YOU
ALL FOR PARTICIPATING THANKS FOR
THANKS TO THE PUBLIC. THE
STAKEHOLDERS THE AUTHORS AND
WITH THAT THE COMMITTEE IS.
ADJOURNED.